script
as chair of the house education
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the open 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the education committee
executive session on pending legislation
may be held
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen continuously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
lawyer i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all the necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
or email hcs
ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us today
jennifer ford committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
states their presence please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
amendment can you please call the rule
yes
representative cordelli
here in the committee room
representative
representative allard
you're in the committee room
representative
representative ford
my homeowner's office alone in chester
representative leon
here in the committee room
representative saudi arabia
representative miler
here in cantuc in my office alone and
representative lay will be late this
morning uh madam clerk
thank you
i'll go back
representative sean here
in manchester my husband is
uh in and out of the room and i'm
wearing a mask not out of extra caution
but out of the fact i visited the
dentist yesterday
representative cornell
representative uh tanner
uh here in uh george's mills part of
sunapee um i'm here with my rescue dog
representative ellison
uh president i'm
home alone in in concord new hampshire
representative moulin
here in the basement in bedford
representative uh
woodcock
here in santa claus new hampshire
with fresh six inches of snow great for
skiing and my dog and my wife
thank you uh representative luna
reporting from hopkinson
thank you and representative lay i will
check in on him later
all presents sir thank you very much and
rip some lad is here in the committee
room
oh sorry yeah i knew that
hope that tooth feels better
i hope so
okay folks so we have uh nine bills on
today
the first bill is scheduled for this
moment so we're gonna go right into hb
500 this is relative to reducing school
food waste and addressing child hunger
uh is rexella and uh
woman in the uh
cube
[Music]
you hear me okay
yes we can
excellent um good morning mr chairman
and members of the house education
committee i'm representative tom lockman
of hampton uh i'm pleased to be with you
this morning to introduce hb 500
relative to reducing school food waste
and addressing child hunger
this bill mirrors hb 1512 from last year
which underwent an interim study by this
committee and was recommended
unanimously for future legislation
this concept came about from a school
district in indiana that chose to
partner with a non-profit to take their
prepared but never served extra food
and package it into frozen-to-go meals
these meals would then be distributed to
students on fridays to take home with
them
this went a long way to solving two
problems it reduced school food waste
while also addressing child hunger over
the weekends
child hunger during the weekends is
something non-profits like n68 hours of
hunger have done an excellent job of
raising awareness of and addressing
uh what's particularly great about
the food that would be involved in this
bill is that it's nutritious by
packaging school food into frozen-to-go
meals we're not limited to providing
children with non-perishable food
or drier food instead it's freshly
cooked well-balanced
and while this bill has enjoyed
bipartisan support there were areas of
interest expressed in last year's
version and in leading up to today's
introduction that i thought worthy of
greater clarity through an amendment
each of you should have amendment 047h
which i had prepared for your
consideration
it provides greater clarity on food
safety and liability while also
providing greater flexibility for
program implementation
i believe it addresses the areas of
interest that have been expressed
specifically
the amendment ensures schools can
implement such a program with or without
a non-profit partner
makes clear that portions and not whole
meals may be distributed as well if that
were the case
that state food safety regulations and
fda requirements and guidelines do apply
also that the bill emerson good
samaritan food donation act shall apply
to any participating school which
provides some liability protections
finally it provides flexibility on which
students may receive these meals
i believe in this concept and the
amazing potential it has to do good and
to bring comfort vital nutrition to
children who experience food insecurity
i'd greatly appreciate your support of
this important bill and amendment and
i'd like to conclude by saying thank you
for your time this morning and i'm happy
to take any questions that you may have
thank you very much
i do have one question for you could you
do explain a little bit more for us the
bill emerson goods american food
donation act and how that impacts
our provides liability protections
sure if you bear with me for just a
moment i'm going to
open a
it was essentially designed for
situations not unlike this where we do
have excessive food in this country in
various
sources
and
you know there was an understood need to
protect
organizations that would want to donate
that food so hold on as i open up this
note here
this is from 1996 signed into a law by
president clinton
um encouraged the donation of food and
grocery products to non-profit
organizations for distribution to needy
individuals
makes it easier to donate it protects
the donors from liability when donating
to non-profit organizations it protects
donors from civil and criminal liability
should the product donated in good faith
later cause harm
to the needy recipient
it standardizes donor liability exposure
um
it sets liability floor of gross
negligence or intentional misconduct for
persons who donate grocery products uh
so there's some
structure there and and definition
um
let's see congress recognized that the
provision of food close to recommended
date of sale is in and of itself not
grounds for finding gross negligence for
example cereal can be donated even if
it's marked close to the code date for
retail sale and so there were all these
opportunities
to make it easier and more streamlined
for
you know sources of food
to be able to donate to um needy
individuals or programs and and provide
some protections uh and i think that
would apply here
thank you very much uh for your
explanation are there questions of the
representative
thank you mr chairman thanks for taking
the question one of the things i believe
this came up last year was a thing on
privacy
how do we protect the students privacy
for
taking these meals because this looks
like another way for bullying so you
have any comments on that
yeah that's a really good question and
you know in my experience in talking
with different stakeholder groups and
schools is there are
programs not unlike this where they try
to get resources to needy individuals
and they all seem to have
creative and innovative and thoughtful
ways in which they go about that and so
i thought it best to leave that to the
schools themselves and the individual
programs to design the ways in which
they can most effectively do that rather
than
stipulate here
how it needs to happen of course i think
the privacy of the individuals should be
thought of and considered and it should
be as discreet as possible
i just you know
short of just simply saying that which
doesn't say much i thought it would be
you know leave it flexible to the
schools to decide how best to go about
it
thank you very much representative shaw
yes what is the amendment number
representative laughlin
it is um
0 4 7 h i emailed it to you all uh last
evening
and also sent it to jennifer four uh to
facilitate distribution to everybody
okay thank you
i i like to make correction on that uh
represent shaw it's zero four seven four
h i i think that represent left the last
four out
ah
okay well thank you i appreciate that
thank you just understanding too that um
we can discuss this uh
amended version of section one
however we won't be uh able to take any
action until it's presented by a
committee native member later on in the
next session i understand
yes represent mullet
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking the question
um i noticed that there is a difference
between the original bill and the
amended bill in that the language about
free and reduced lunch has actually been
removed
could you
explain your thinking behind that and
uh whether or not that satisfies what
representative baum was inquiring about
sure um you know this came about
in one of the
conversations i've had regarding ways to
make this bill more suitable there was a
discussion around what's happened in the
past year
because of covid for instance the
participants in free and reduced lunch
has expanded
greatly to the point where the data on
it is
fairly muddy and i wondered if
it wasn't best to
make it more flexible since
uh you know so any any parent who wants
um to participate in this program wants
their children to participate in this
program could
and so you know i didn't i i suppose i
thought it'd be best to be more flexible
rather than less flexible and that needy
children would still
have the path to pursue participation in
this program
regardless
and maybe some additional children on
the fringe maybe not quite eligible but
close could as well
and i thought that was a positive thing
thank you
thank you representative for
representing this bill
um it seems to me that the bill
last term
had issues related to
the freezing of food
and
when and who would be doing that would
it be done by
school staff in the cafeteria or would
the food be
provided to the non-profit who would
then
i think that was an issue with the last
bill if i remember correctly and i was
just wondering if you have any thoughts
on along those lines
yeah you know and it's a great question
thank um representative cordelli i
i recall the question and i in in my
sort of studies of similar programs and
an example the indiana program they did
work with a non-profit who would collect
the food package it freeze it and then
bring it bring all the packaged frozen
meals back to the school to distribute
on fridays and
there are many ways to go about it
this bill allows for
multiple configurations where someone
could be responsible for the freezing
and packaging whether it's the schools
themselves or a non-profit partner on
premises off-premises
so long as you know they're abiding by
the food safety regulations
and i think that's the best approach
because many of these programs are
successful but they're finding a lot of
different ways to go about doing it
and i thought that's best because these
are
essentially pilot programs in in new
hampshire having this kind of model but
also the flexibility to
pursue multiple configurations may find
an even more efficient or effective way
to do it and i thought the bill should
allow for that
thank you
representative cornell
yep um the bill says a school a school
may partner with a non-profit so this is
enabling legislation right it's not
telling school districts or schools that
they have to do it
that's
thank you for the question
representative cornell and absolutely um
this is enabling
i see it as a
a way of you know certainly some of this
is codifying some protections and all of
that but it's
it's illuminating uh organizations or
schools that this is a
concept that can be implemented because
one of the questions that came up last
year was well can we do this now and
you'd be surprised how
nobody quite had the answer to that and
i think this does answer that not only
can we do it but we're providing a
little bit of structure and guidance
around it so that it can be done well
and properly and safely
and so correct it is enabling
legislation
thank you
further questions represent moment
not seeing hands thank you very much
representative
thank you mr chairman much appreciated
okay uh next is representative murray
welcome to education
thank you for having me thank you mr
chair honorable colleagues for the
record my name is megan murray and i
represent the town of amherst district
22.
um
so briefly i understand your schedule is
busy today so i'll be as brief as
possible
currently in new hampshire one in eight
are experiencing food insecurity and
unfortunately that number has grown due
to the pandemic
now more than ever families who
experience household food insecurity are
navigating food pantries and snap
services but this issue existed well
before
hb 500 and its proposed amendment offers
communities another avenue for efficient
supplemental food distribution
especially during a time of hunger and
insecurity
as a former educator myself i am well
aware of the complex nature of food
insecurity
relating to self-esteem self-efficacy
stigma mental and physical health as a
child i was one of those who for a time
received free and reduced lunch
not unlike many who experience food
insecurity there were times where
spaghetti sandwiches got my mom through
stretching
food to meet our needs
it was literally two slices of bread
buttered
and spaghetti between the slices
food insecurity is one of the daily
barriers children experience in their
academic days and it absolutely affects
their learning day food insecurity for
children is related to aces
as the committee knows adverse childhood
experiences have profound and lasting
impacts and left unaddressed in children
can be harmful
data shows that children in homes where
aces are high have higher instances of
household food insecurity
hunger affects a child's ability to
focus have energy and learn throughout
the day
and no child should have increased
anxieties around attaining meals or
sustenance
states across the nation have enacted
varying degrees of legislation like this
and the usda recognizes food recovery
for school programs in the first
paragraph of their website and
throughout it
such permissible language as in hb 500
and the amendment would allow school
communities if they choose to to
participate in getting food to those in
need in their learning communities
addressing food hungering hunger excuse
me while bolstering partnerships with
nonprofits would increase the ability to
feed those in need and keep good food
from being tossed into costly and heavy
waste streams
and if the food can't be recaptured it
should be composted and not landfilled
with hp 500 and the amendment simply
this permissible language would allow
schools in partnership with a
third-party nonprofit or on their own to
safely package freeze
and distribute the unserved food
to those in need i wholeheartedly
testify in support of getting food
safely to those who need it most and
urge the committee to adopt the
amendment when the time is right and
pass hb 500 with it i humbly thank you
for your time and consideration with
this important legislation and it would
change the lives of so many thank you
[Music]
the
doe office of food nutrition programs
um and then they mentioned the
health and human services bureau of food
protection
uh do you know if anyone has uh talked
with
that hero about this program
yes so i there have been stakeholder
conversations with both of those and i
do believe that with within with respect
to the
um schools themselves and the nonprofit
organizations um they are fully aware of
what are called hassip food safety
protocols which is the hazardous
analysis and critical control points
and so they are when considering
packaging those foods they are already
in compliance with how those
procedures work within their school
communities and within the non-profit
organizations
thank you
further questions of the representative
not seeing any hands thank you very much
representative murray
you're welcome thank you for your time
yes i can hear you um i just want to
make sure my unmuted that you can hear
me as well yes we can
well good morning
mr chair and members of the committee my
name is mike appleberg
and i come to you today as president of
the united way of greater nashua in
support of hb 500
prior to the pandemic we partnered with
the nashua school district to establish
a program of what's called share carts
in the schools whereby students could
systematically get uneaten unopened
foods to their fellow students this was
a first in the state initiative this
came about as a partnership that
included the schools the united way as
well as our local department of public
health
since the pandemic began and the
shutdown last march our united way
partnered with the nashua school
district to distribute over 90 000 free
breakfasts and lunches in our community
we also partnered with the school
district and other
organizational entities to stand up over
a dozen weekly fixed and mobile food
pop-up pantries getting critically
needed food into the hands and bellies
of thousands of local residents
during this time we have identified that
there is both a great need
to support children and families with
food security as well as a great need to
work on the distribution systems
in our community there's often a surplus
of food
along with a great need but no way to
get the food from the source to the
recipient school systems are
phenomenal for distributing foods to
kids in their physical school locations
but often not well positioned to get
food out into the community on the other
hand local nonprofits have the ability
to get food into the community but often
have a need to access the indiv the
additional resources of food itself
this bill helps to bridge the gap and
for this reason we are strongly
supportive of hb 500 and we look forward
to continued support of our community
during these tr during these trying
times
thank you and if you have any questions
i will be i will be here on the call
thank you very much mike are there
questions from the committee for
uh
hi can you hear me
yes we can sophie
all right uh thank you mr chair and
members of the committee for taking my
testimony today my name is sophia
biandalilo i'm 14 i live in manchester
and i'm speaking today on behalf of the
new hampshire high school democrats in
support of hb 500
i believe as i'm sure each of you does
that no child in new hampshire should
ever go hungry yet according to feeding
america one in eight new hampshire
children struggle with hunger and the
kova 19 pandemic has only exacerbated
this crisis
there are many students in our state who
have nobody there to greet them when
they get back home they walk home by
themselves and have their own key to the
door
by allowing food that would otherwise go
to waste to be sent home with children
in need this bill will be a step towards
ensuring that no child in new hampshire
goes to bed hungry
in the united states about 30 to 40
percent of the food supply is wasted and
according to the 2019 world wildlife
fund report
schools make up about 530 000 tons of
this waste
this is not only a waste of resources it
is also harmful to our planet
according to the environmental
protection agency food is the single
largest category of material placed in
municipal landfills in the united states
and landfills food produces methane
which is a harmful greenhouse gas
allowing schools to repackage this food
would help
would help keep food out of landfills
and put it in the hands of our students
this bill would help tackle climate
change and hunger at once and therefore
i ask the members of the committee to
support
house bill 500 thank you for your time
thank you very much are there any
questions for our young high school
i'm sorry i think you broke up could you
could you repeat that i said are there
any uh questions that the committee
would like to ask of you sophia
um and i'm looking around the room here
and there there are no further questions
uh thank you very much for your input
today
okay uh no no i have nobody else lined
up to testify
uh we have that's been given us here on
the remote testifying sheep supporting
it
opposed zero neutral zero total number
okay we are a few moments early here
we have about five minutes before the
next
okay i think what we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and accept this
bill uh
i'm looking for a motion from
representatives
i um
i guess we have to do the amendment
first yeah
so i vote i would like to move otp on
amendment
0474 h
yes every second representative seconds
the motion that we have a motion
to pass on zero four seven four h
that's the amendment to the bill that
we've been discussing uh bill 500 so
we're voting on the amendment is there
further discussion on the amendment
looking around i'm not seeing anybody
with the maker like to say anything of
the motion nope
okay madam clerk you're out there
somewhere
gotcha
okay this is on the
excuse me this is on the amendment
representative cordelli
yes
uh representative bowm yes
representative allard yes
representative lycus
yes
representative moffett
representative hobson
yes
representative andres yes
representative ford
yes
representative leon
representative saudi
yes
representative miller
from blue now yes representative shaw
yes representative cornell
yes
representative tanner yes
representative ellison
yes
representative mullen
representative lay you here yet yes i am
mommy i am present i am in beau and i
vote yes
thank you that's in the wood car yes
20-0 on the amendment
it represents yes also oh
i'm sorry representative ladd
i don't know what's happening okay uh
do we have another motion please
represent like this yes i would like to
move otp
second and we have a second from
representative bones so the motion is
over to pass on
the
bill hb 500 as amended with zero four
seven four h
not seeing any hands
uh would you please go ahead and call
the roll madam clerk
i will
representative
this is on house bill 500
uh ought to pass as amended
representative cordelli
yes
representative paul yes
representative hallard
yes
representative lycus yes
representative moffitt
yes
representative hobson
representative ambrose
yes
representative ford
representative leon
yes representative saudi yes
representative miler
yes
representative luna
representative shaw yes
representative cornell
yes
representative tanner
representative ellison
yes
representative mullen yes
representative lay
yes
representative woodcock
20 nothing
consent calendar
yes
i hear a yes out there thank you very
much yes thank you very much
representative
that's a moment i'd like to thank you
very much for working with us on this
and coming back with an amendment that
seems very very well put together and i
appreciate you calling me earlier this
fall and discussing this
um
congratulations
okay
hb
140 relative to private rights of action
regarding pupil safety
senators
representative cordell you're
recognizing
thank you chairman for the record
representative
representing
nationally and in new hampshire
i sent out an information packet i
believe on sunday that i hope you all
received
and uh in it there was a report from the
department of education for
the 2018-19 school year with over 1600
reported cases of bullying
be aware that there are also estimates
that 65
of bullying incidents
go unreported
a cdc report stated that even
students who witness bullying incidents
are impacted and have a greater feeling
of helplessness
a yale review of bullying studies found
five studies that reported bullying
victims were two to nine times more
likely to report suicidal thoughts than
other children
there have been multiple attempts to
deal with bullying both by the
legislature and by school districts
but
are 1600 reported incidents acceptable
uh i think you might hear from some
people who think not
uh the current
statute rsa 193 have colon 9 states that
nothing in the chapter on public safety
shall create a bright light of action
in 2015 there was a case
daughtier versus manchester school
district that went to the new hampshire
supreme court and that case involved an
altercation on a school bus with one
student being punched in the face
after a week of threatening messages to
the student she was attacked in the
cafeteria and had had to be reported to
be transported to the emergency room
the parents had never been informed
about the school bus accident
they only found out about it in the
emergency room
the supreme court ruled in favor of the
school district citing this statute
and seeing that there was no private
hb 140 is very simple
it states that if there's gross
negligence and willful misconduct there
shall be a private right back
we talk much about accountability in
discussing other legislation
how about talking about accountability
for
groceries
conduct or willful negligence in
bullying cases
your handout includes a number of news
reports about public site cases in new
hampshire
and remember that
the statistics that there are thousands
of reported cases that have not gotten
this publicity
each one of these cases represents
multiple students who have been impacted
for those of you who do not have it in
front of
you it's the rsaf 193f is the capture on
public safety and violence
uh prevention and let me read you from
the purpose and intent of that uh
chapter
intent all pupils have the right to
attend public schools including public
charter schools that are safe secure and
peaceful environments
one of the legislature's highest
priorities is to protect our children
from physical emotional psychological
violence by addressing the harm caused
by bullying and cyber bullying
in public schools
it goes on the intent of the legislature
to protect our children from fiscal
emotional and psychological violence
uh by addressing employing cyber
bullying
of any kind in our public schools
for the for all of the historical
reasons set forth in deception and to
prevent the creation of a hostile
education environment
we the general court needs to make sure
that bullying issues are being taken
seriously and that parents of bullying
children are being listened to it is our
duty
we would all like to think that every
district is doing everything possible to
address and respond to reported bullying
cases
that is there
but when districts not follow their own
policies or the law
families deserve and remedy
passing hp 140 will send a message
throughout
new hampshire that the legislature means
business and we are standing with
bullied students and their families
we owe it to them
thank you mr chairman thank you very
much representative are there
questions for representative yes
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
please define for the committee
the term right of private action
and secondly define for the committee
what is gross
and willful misconduct thank you very
much
i am not a lawyer but uh there is a
dictionary
definition that i found a private light
of action that states the right to begin
and prosecute an action in the courts
um in terms of gross misdon conduct
definition
i believe that the courts have declined
uh entire cases to come up with such a
definition but uh the term gross
negligence and willful
misconduct are in
our statute throughout our statutes i
can cite
650 170 21 p12c
186 c14 173 b12 200 and poland 6 329
these colon 21
a
hole in 22 and 508 12-a
were just the results of a simple search
i did um and there might be others as
thank you very much for representing
further questions for representative
cordelia
thank you thank you for waiting mr chair
trying to move that arrow all the way
over to the other side of the screen uh
uh thank you for letting me speak and
representative kodaly thank you for
taking the question
um
so in late terms you didn't i i asked i
was listening uh attentively
after representative milor asked you the
definition of willful misconduct and you
gave them all a citation but you didn't
give me definition so i was curious the
definition
and specifically
in very lay terms
can you walk me through a scenario what
this might look like with a youngster or
a parent i'm concerned about
who they actually against the school
district is it the school teacher or the
school principal
the superintendent of the district
itself so those couple of things just
if you would uh rosanna cordelli explain
explain willful misconduct and then just
tell me how it might show itself out in
a little uh scenario here please i can
lay understand it in very late terms
for a couple of questions there first
our state statutes do not include the
definition for florida's fondue
but
use the term throughout our states
i think the court
courts could make that determination
this
act applies to school districts there
are
protections
further on in our statutes for school
individuals school staff so this would
apply to school districts in terms of
the white back
further further questions
yes uh thank you mr chair thank you
representative cordelli for taking my
question with possible follow-up
i just have a question about the the
term aggrieved
uh i understand the term injured uh
that that legally uh but aggrieved i'm
just wondering you know if somebody's
feelings are hurt is that what the
grieve means or can you speak to a
grieved a little bit
um
it's someone who
feels injured
i think that there are other attorneys
who might be uh better to weigh in on
that deny in terms of the legal
definition of agreed
but
there is a higher
degree
um
with this
uh action
with this uh act and that it requires
gross negligence or willful misconduct
a simple
incident of calling someone a name i
don't think would uh
meet the qualifications of this uh
statute
but thank you
further further questions representative
tanner
thank you um in reading a little bit
about this uh it seems that there is a
countersuit often
for freedom of speech
when there's been suits uh
for cyber bullying i'm just wondering if
there is limited liability
for schools if they um
are trying to deal with bullying and the
the issue of the first amendment free
i know of
none
but
i'm not clear on
how freedom of speech
[Music]
applies in this
instance
may i follow up on that
um so i think what happens is that in
the cyber bullying
uh they're using you know public
internet and they're making
all kinds of uh issues about a person
uh isn't that an issue of free speech
that that
is somewhat protected
i think that uh in statute already uh
and i believe in this chapter um there
are definitions uh for cyber bullying
uh that might clarify that for you but
uh
i think that's uh documented in statute
currently
further questions representative uh
woodcock did you have a follow-up
i did arizona and i missed it thank you
very much for coming back reverendo
cordell back to the same question can
you just give me a small scenario walk
me through a lay man scenario a student
in a school the parent does this what
happens i'm trying to figure out how
this process works
not not citation but rather scenario how
might work
there is a process outlined in our uh
statutes already uh for uh schools
dealing with uh reported bullying
incidents
[Music]
part of that
figured into the manchester school
district case that i
mentioned earlier and other cases as
well so there is a process already in
our statutes that
defines on how the school is to react uh
when there is a reported case of
bullying and uh the investigation that
further further final fall of this chair
i understand that brother you're trying
to find out how we go from that step
through your bill that's all how we get
to the world from this card i'm just
trying to
um
after the investigation if the parents
um are
not satisfied
that the school is
complying with their own rules or
policies
then they would have the private right
of action
you have fitness
thank you very much
uh are there further questions from
representative cordelli
next we have shannon bouchard she's been
promoted
shannon uh can you unmute your machine
please
oh sorry about that
i am going to be reading
from
my story a little bit with my daughter
um
my daughter
if you have something you want to read
can you please submit that to the clerk
uh where we put that into the minutes
however to read something straight out
where it's gonna i see you're requesting
10 minutes that's much longer than
we provide for testing okay it might not
it probably won't take ten minutes
honestly
okay go for it then
okay my daughter was bullied over
her entire school career at the district
she has um verbal apraxia sometimes
called dyspraxia which is a motor
planning speech disorder so it was hard
for her to if somebody said something to
come back with something you know and be
able to get her point across that it was
happening
i requested a manifest educational
hardship which is the
policy in law that your you request it
in the district
the superintendent brings it to the
district and you're allowed to go before
hearing on your board and when i did
that i was denied by the superintendent
stating that she had a disability so i
couldn't go
through the manifest educational
hardship so i had to then in turn
go and find an attorney that could help
me just to get the just to get in front
of the school board
i was able to
tell the school board what was happening
and prove my case and they awarded her
the manifest educational hardship which
would have meant that she would be
allowed to go to a different district
only there are no districts that will
accept her
stating kovid as the reason so she is
remote learning in the district that she
has had
nothing but hardship in
um
i wanted to say that
my daughter um because of not being able
to really get across clearly like what
was happening to her
because of her disability
um
she started self-harming and had
suicidal thoughts and
i
have a lot of things i could go to due
process for but i'm on disability from
my own ms and my husband's the only
person that works and to go in and
obtain a lawyer
would be such a hardship for us that
it's impossible
um
i think that the schools have full-time
attorneys that they're backing call and
even
most people don't go to due process
because they can't afford to go up
against
the school and they're high-powered
attorneys and meanwhile these kids are
suffering in silence because everywhere
they turn
there is no help for them they
i mean we have kids that she reported
the bullying i reported the bullying and
they handled it as peer mediation and we
know how well that goes she was then
bullied even more for tattling and so
she kept it all inside and didn't report
it again
i'm faced now with her being remote
because of covid but i can't find a
district that is within reason that
because i'd be responsible for
transportation that either myself or my
husband on his way to work would be
capable of getting her
there the two districts that would be
fine they both have denied her stating
covet as the reason and not saying that
as soon as
they're back full time that they would
accept her they
pretty much told me that they will
contact me if it changes if not
shannon are you still are you finished
yeah
that thank you very much are there
questions for
the person presenting right now
shannon bouchard
representative
thank you thank you mr chairman and
thank you ms bouchard for taking my
question
as you pursued your issues in advocating
for your child
what was the relief that you were
looking for
that would that you felt would
resolve the issues that your family was
facing
um most of the issues were around um the
school had her in a learning center
which was a segregated she had to go
into a different part of the building
you know where it was labeled special
education she had to go into that to get
her services and that was the worst part
for her because the kids were seeing
that she was different so they were
you know calling her the r word every
day and
laughing and poking fun at her and
it just i felt like if we could get her
into a different school that didn't the
school district we were at told me that
she had to have a learning center or she
wouldn't qualify for an iep and that's
not the truth and i learned that by
getting an attorney which
was only limited representative
from the disability rights center and
before that i wouldn't have had any clue
i believed what they said obviously
and so
by changing school she would get an
inclusive education instead of a
push-out education
so so the relief you were looking for
was just a change in school
and what uh what year is your child in
school
um she is a freshman
thank you very much
thank you very much representative milo
and shannon are there further questions
for shannon bouchard
yes represent hobson uh
can you hear me okay thank you for
taking my question i was just wondering
if you could explain
how this legislation might have helped
you
um i think that
there are a lot of issues besides just
the change of school that there were a
lot of issues that i could have gone to
due process for
that the school wasn't implementing but
because of the cost of getting an
attorney and and having that
i just i couldn't afford it honestly
thank you very much thank you very much
are there further questions for
mr bouchard
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you chairman ladd and um thank you
committee members for your public
service
um
my name is jerry zellen i'm a lawyer in
portsmouth i specialize in representing
school districts primarily in matters
involving special education and
disability rights
i'm speaking today as a volunteer for
the new hampshire association of special
education administrators
which is our statewide organization
150 170 members that represents among
others all special education directors
bullying is a terrible thing and school
districts should do their best to combat
it
however not all reports of bullying are
well-founded
special education includes some students
whose disabilities cause them to
misperceive social communications
they sometimes misinterpret innocent
remarks as insults that amount to oral
or cyber bullying
i filed a letter with the committee that
explains why the nha sea opposes hb 140.
uh in a nutshell um while the bill is
well intentioned it is poorly crafted
but i'd like to focus on the first
reason why we oppose the bill which is
perhaps the most important one
the bill as written allows any person
aggrieved
by any violation of rsa 193 f
to sue and recover attorneys fees so
long as the lawsuit alleges
that the violation was a result of gross
negligence or willful misconduct
the bill allows a plaintiff to prevail
even if no actual bullying occurred
so long as
there was
some violation of some provision in rsa
193-f
now rsa 193 f includes many technical
provisions for reporting
investigating
um and following up on suspected cases
of bullying all within very tight
deadlines and those deadlines are under
some circumstances easy to miss
so it's easy for a technical violation
to occur
and as this bill is written
such a technical violation
would allow a lawsuit as long as the
complaint alleges that there is gross
misconduct or willful violation
and then the district would have to
defend itself in court
and if there was a technical violation
that may have been the result of gross
negligence or willful misconduct but
just technical with no harm no foul no
no one was injured that would still give
rise to a finding against the school
district and an award of attorney's fees
now a year ago the house defeated an
identical bill house bill 1335
and in their minority port the sponsors
of that bill said
quote last year
we passed legislation allowing parental
suits in cases of discrimination in
schools
are we now saying that parents can sue
for discrimination cases but not when
the district has been guilty of gross
misconduct in a bullying case unquote
but here's where that analogy fails
a victim can prevail in a discrimination
case only if one there has been actual
discrimination and number two there is
some causal connection between what the
district did and the discrimination
house bill 140 in contrast allows the
plaintiff to prevail and to recover
attorney's fees for a technical
violation of rsa 193 f even when no
bullying actually occurred
this is a recipe for frivolous
litigation look at the three ingredients
number one liability for any technical
violation regardless of whether any
bullying occurred number two a standard
of liability gross gross negligence that
as my letter points out the law does not
define and third a prevailing plaintiff
can recover attorney's fees but a
prevailing defendant cannot
so please defeat or amend house bill
140. it's well-intentioned but grossly
overbroad thank you
thank you very much attorney gesellen
are there any questions
yes representative
famous jude thank you attorney zone you
touched on a point that i brought up
earlier
i'd like to ask you if the word
aggrieved was changed to injured would
that change your view of this
bill
well um
that's sort of that's an indirect way i
i would um rather have uh the the meat
of the provision um uh talk about um an
actual
injury uh being um being the bullying
and the district either that the child
was bullied and that there was some
causal connection
between um the bullying and what the
district did or did not do
because injury in the abstract you know
what um
how do you define that there could be an
injury to someone's feelings there could
be an injury to a legal right it's still
a very vague term and we'd be litigating
that in the courts just you know what is
injury is it just an injury of a legal
right a violation of some technical
provision
thank you
thank you very much uh representatives
yes thank you for taking my question
um
it says
and i'm just not understanding as a
result of gross negligence away from
this conduct in violation of any
provision
so if it was just a
technical
and the school district was doing their
best and maybe missed a deadline because
of uh holiday or something
uh
but they were trying or didn't manage to
get hold of a parent or whatever
that wouldn't be gross negligence or
willful misconduct would
well one can um
gross
one count through gross negligence
violate a technical provision
of the statute
one can ful through willful misconduct
a technical provision of the statute and
yet
it's possible under those circumstances
that there was no bullying
in addition as a practical matter anyone
can file the lawsuit
and the plaintiff will prevail only if
uh the defendant can prove that there
was not
gross misconduct or willful violation
but the meanwhile the the school
district has to go through defending
itself
so this will open the door to lawsuits
that that claim the gross misconduct
that ultimately can't be proven
but the lawsuits will tie up district
resources and staff time
so the bottom line is
a technical violation when no one was
injured should not give rise to a
lawsuit
no matter how no matter what the
represent boom
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
section 193 f1 its purpose and intent
is to
protect students
and it goes through all the stuff
and so why
haven't along at all
if at the end f9 says you can't do
anything about it so what's the purpose
well there are ways to enforce statutes
there are complaints one can file with
the state department of education
remember that this statute
supercharges the right to seek judicial
relief by allowing an award of attorneys
fees
but again
to to air is human and sometimes people
gloss over a provision of the statute
but again if there was no injury if
further questions
representative
um thank you mr chair thank you mr
chairman thank you mr zelen for taking
my question um i
i'd like to ask your professional
opinion i'm still
still very very
traumatized by an incident that happened
in 2008 in one of my in my former school
where a bully student
who
had been sexually harassed and
physically harassed by another student
had his concerns complete repeatedly
minimized by the school
and it was never addressed to the point
where this child brandon mcginnery was
left with the faulty reasoning of the
middle school student and
killed his classmate in the in the
computer lab
this child found the wrong solution to a
problem but this child was failed by the
school
and i don't know if there's anything in
new hampshire where
a student who has been
who has not been supported by their
school and has been subject to bullying
at this level can find a remedy against
the school district so that they're not
left with such a horrible choice is
there anything that they that a student
or parent can do here in new hampshire
now for that sort of gross negligence on
a school
well there is that hurdle of our
municipal immunity statute
as well as the
statute that grants what's called
official immunity to school officials
and i recite what they provide in my
letter to the committee but if
if the committee wants to
protect those who have been bullied
which is the case you've just described
then the answer is to craft a more
narrow bill
that
allows the lawsuit
if there has been actual bullying
and if the district's actions or
inactions were somehow causally
connected to that bullying
so that means legally there was no
there's no recourse for a student like
that so they truly are left to their own
devices
at the moment that's generally the case
um unless
the parent can
surmount the provisions of the municipal
immunity statutes those municipal
immunity statutes do not grant immunity
to school districts or school employees
for
when there's extreme culpability okay
but if this committee wants to create a
lower bar for suing school districts or
school employees
[Applause]
understood
that might be warranted but
that
allowing the stew for the damages
should be when there was actual bullying
and not simply a technical violation
of the statute now if a technical
violation of the statute
well if a district for example tech
ignored what the statute required for
bullying or for intervening to take
remedial action and then the bullying
continued so the student remained
bullied then then there is a causal
connection between the district's action
or in action and that later bullying
um
and
so that is the if this if this
legislature wants to create a remedy
that targets the vic
targets the perpetrators or that targets
the school officials who allow the
bullying then then write a statute that
does that but don't write a statute that
says a district may be sued for any
violation of rsa 190 3f whatsoever write
a statute that allows um a
cause of action
when there has been bullying and when
the district somehow contributed to that
yes
thank you again for taking another
question
um
i noticed that
it doesn't say that
they automatically recover court costs
but they may recover court costs and
reasonable attorney fees
as the prevailing party so my question
is would a judge
award them that if it was a frivolous
lawsuit
it's
depends on what you call frivolous if
the law if the plaintiff prevailed
um
and the plaintiff won because the school
district failed to do something within
48 hours as some provision in rsa193f
requires it wouldn't be frivolous in the
sense that it wouldn't be an unfounded
lawsuit to play if the district violated
that deadline then um it was it violated
the statute and then the plaintiff could
recover attorney's fees but do we want
every case where uh the district failed
to provide uh a notice by the 48-hour
deadline where it took 49 hours
the plaintiff would prevail is that the
sort of loss that we want to invite
by um
offering the the plaintiff's attorney
the prospect of recovering attorney's
representative
thank you mr chairman representative
attorney zell and good to see you again
i'll see you
uh remember the lad this is just a
clarification case of may um i don't
i've heard attorney zones speak about a
document he has sent his testimony i
don't see any of that document on my
legislative mail do you know where that
went or
did everyone receive it or am i the only
one
well actually jane bowden sent it or at
least i she was supposed to send it and
did you receive that
i have to check on that new name
attorney zelen the name with what please
jane bowden okay
but what i can do as soon as i get off
as email it to the committee if that
would help me help me thank you
thank you are there further questions of
attorneys ellen
thank you very much jerry
well thank you folks and thanks again
megan douglas do you hear us
again can you hear me yes we can
okay um i'd like to start basically by
saying that i dispute just about every
single thing that attorneys ellen just
told the committee
um and we can start
um
trying to figure out where to start
i think that attorney zalan said
that
this
provision hb 140 if enacted
would give plaintiffs the right to
successfully pursue
a lawsuit
and get a finding by the court
for a mere technical violation
of rsa 193
f
that is false as representative alicia
lake has pointed out
in order to be successful
in a lawsuit against a school
under rs sorry under hb 140 if it is
enacted
a student is going to have to show
gross negligence
in application of rsa 193 f4
or
willful misconduct
what that means is outrageous
carelessness
in application of the duties that this
legislature has prescribed to the adult
professionals in public schools
outrageous carelessness
or
intentional harm
in application or or omitting
application of rsa 193 f4 that's what a
court is going to interpret gross
negligence and willful misconduct as
that's what those terms
are likely to be construed as
and i want to tell you i mean
representative woodcock
asked what does that look like i want to
lay out for you what it looks like
it looks like
a poor child
who has to come to school
every day
in the same fila t-shirt because he has
no other fila t-shirt
he's in school he's in middle school
and a kid
who is a leader of another group of kids
pulls on that t-shirt
every single day
and calls him skank
until finally
it's ripped and it's ripped before a
teacher
and a teacher sees
that act
and actually has been seeing the pattern
of behavior
leading to this
and does
nothing
nothing but that still that's not even
gross negligence that would be
that that would be perhaps a negligent
or mistaken
uh
application of rsa 193 f4 to be gross
negligence that same student would have
to have that same type of experience
perhaps the shirt is ripped entirely off
in front of the vice principal this time
and the vice principal documents it in
an email or in an in a record in the in
the school's office
but as was the case in the gravlin
case uh which with the goatee the
manchester school district which was
discussed earlier
that vice principal
is
too busy
to address the issue
still not gross negligence
gross negligence
is now the principal
sees this child
walking without a shirt
and being taunted and beaten by book
bags
in the hallway
and there's a record of this and still
there is no action by the school
that is the case that a plaintiff's
attorney is going to take
because that
finally looks like gross negligence as a
plaintiff's attorney i can tell you
that the mere prospect
of attorney's fees may be being awarding
to me
at the end of a year's worth of work and
a hundred thousand dollars of work hours
invested in a case is not enough to get
me to take that case
and i don't know of any plaintiff's
attorney who is who is moved
by the by the mere
mere promise of maybe preserving uh
attorney's fees to the prevailing party
and again i i compliment you
representative lakers you also picked up
on the fact that mr attorney zellen was
inaccurate and misrepresented the way
the fee shifting provision works it does
not go to the prevailing plaintiff only
it goes to the prevailing party the
prevailing party so that could be the
defendant
okay
um
i i just i i am really
frankly gobsmacked
at
the way in which
this provision which
it actually does very little to change
the status quo
has been presented over and over again
as some tremendous burden on public
school officials
when all it really does is hold
our adult
hub
school professionals
accountable
for not being outrageously careless
or willfully harmful
with the safety of our children in
school
that is all this bill does
and if you vote against it what you're
really saying is we don't want schools
to have even that
low standard of care
we don't want that because it's too much
and i think that that's that's a
travesty for new hampshire's children
there are a number of other things that
um
were brought up that i'd i'd like to
address
the first amendment the first amendment
has very limited application
uh or it has limited application in
public schools
um so what does that mean
it means that speech that interferes
with the school's mission
to include the mission to educate and
include a child
in the school community
is not protected by the first amendment
okay
um
aggrieved
it is
very likely i don't think it's a big
deal to change the word aggrieved to
injured i mean i could talk to uh i
could maybe speak with representative
cordelli about that
um
but
i think that a court is very likely to
interpret the word aggrieved
to mean injured because there's a basic
principle in our in our common law
that a plaintiff doesn't even have
standing
to come before the court to bring a
lawsuit unless he or she can can show
some harm or injury
so i don't i don't think there's a real
risk
that a court is going to
interpret aggrieved
to mean anything different
than injured or harmed some provable
the municipal immunity statute was was
raised
and i i want to address that as well
because i think
attorneys allen was was inaccurate about
that too
i think he said that there would be a
municipal immunity
problem
with
the enactment of house bill 140
and i don't find that to be true because
the emissive municipal immunity statute
basically revoking immunity
when
there is a private right of action
expressly included in another statute
so there's provision in municipal
immunity that says essentially this
immunity shall have no effect on private
rights of actions guaranteed by or
provided by other other statutes
that's one of the reasons why it's so
important to have an express private
right of action for
again gross negligence and willful
misconduct
in rsc rsa 193 f
because without it if it's just
if it's just uh if rsa
r193f9 is simply repealed
then um there's a there's still a chance
that a cause of action may not lie
um and and then rsa 193f and all the
duties prescribed
by it
would only be enforceable even in the
cases of most outrageous carelessness or
intentional harm
at the local school board level
or
via the department of education
which as we know does not perfor uh
provide
um
any economic relief
to to parents and children
nor
really any um incentive
i think for schools
to um really pay attention to their
uh
we're running out of time um and we need
to get this closure so that questions
can be asked of you yep i'm done
thank you very much representative milor
thank you mr chair i think
mr chair for the record i think when
people come before the committee they
need to identify
if they are representing an advocate
group
or a law firm
for those members of the committee and
my understanding that
ms douglas is an attorney
and she's appeared before this committee
on this particular bill before
and i think it's important for the
committee knows that she does represent
a particular viewpoint from a legal
standpoint and
should i
don't know which law firm you're with
miss megan but it would be uh miss uh
douglas but it'd be good for you to i
think to identify that for the committee
thank you i can happily do that i um i
want it gives me an opportunity to add
that i did submit written
testimony um on this subject matter
uh and it should be in your email inbox
um and i i am an attorney at douglas
leonard and garvey
i am a plaintiff's attorney i identify
that in the very first paragraph of my
written testimony i am the attorney um
who represented um
uh
morgan gravlin who was badly beaten
in the cafeteria uh back in the early
2010s
um
and i represented her
uh with my co-counsel all the way up to
the supreme court and that was where we
learned
um the
the ineffectiveness of rsa 193 f4
thank you very much thank you
are there further questions uh uh ms
tapas
not seeing enhanced thank you very much
welcome mr christina
thank you chairman ladd good morning
members of the committee thank you as
always for taking my testimony for the
record barrett christina executive
director of new hampshire school boards
association
um we are uh opposed to house bill uh
140. um a couple provisions of of
statute that we had talked about earlier
that i just sort of like to reiterate
and then um i'm going to go back and
read the legislative history um on the
um on rsa193f
when it was an act in 2010 this may jog
the memory of i believe at least three
members of this committee represent
chairman ladd representative shaw and
representative boehm you were on the the
committee um at the time this bill was
passed
so uh we talked a little bit about the
purpose and intent um in rsa 193 f2
the sole purpose of this chapter is to
protect all children from bullying and
cyber bullying um
and and in reading the the the um the
note in the legislative calendar from
this bill offers greater guidance to
school districts to improve their
policies and procedures for reporting
investigating documentation and response
to incidences of bullying harassment
intimidation and cyber bullying it also
requires annual training for school
personnel students and parents
this is the bulk of the testimony
nowhere in this bill
is there a requirement that school
districts eradicate bullying indeed that
would be absolutely impossible
as representative cordell we noted there
were 1600 reported cases of bullying um
whatever that'll i forget what year he
said that was
that's a good thing that's a good thing
that we have that number of reported
cases of bullying and response to the
fact that 64 65 percent of those go
unreported
you know we wish that that number was
actually higher the higher that number
gets the more responsive our school
districts are to addressing issues of
bullying and cyber bullying
so
it's terrible that these kids are still
bullied but school districts can't
eradicate bullying we can respond to the
statute we can respond to our local
policies and we can uh interject with
the intervention uh services that are
either found in local policies or found
within the statute itself
relative to the accountability aspect uh
you know
it seems that the accountability of a
bully should be with the parents there's
a lot of discussion in this committee
about parents rights
what parents should be able to do and
how parents should be able to raise
their children and the accountability
ultimately falls on the parents so if
there's a bully in school the school
district has limited responses that it
can that it can do it can intervene it
can do the pure mediation it can
discipline a child detention suspension
whatever the case may be
um but also relative to that the
accountability of the parents to ensure
that they're not sending in a bully into
the school um miss douglas i spoke to
miss douglas last year when the bill was
being heard the house bill 1335 and i
asked her after the hearing why didn't
you sue the parents of the bully and she
said well they didn't have any money so
if ever there was a perfect statement as
to why the plaintiffs bar may be
supporting this bill i think it sums up
in in in that statement
um we also need to be careful with the
specific language of the bill as people
have mentioned out the language any
person aggrieved
um
by a school district decision i just
want to make the committee
understand and recognize
that's not just going to be
the the victim of bullying it could be
the perpetrator who insists that it was
not bullying so school districts are
going to get it not just from the bully
we're not going to be sued just by the
i'm sorry not we're not going to be sued
just by the victim of bullying but the
language states that if you know a kid
has found to have been a bully and the
parents disagree with that they can now
sue the school district because the kids
reputation has somehow been damaged
um the other aspect that's very
challenging with this when we talked
about a representative moffitt i think
you brought this up with changing the
word aggrieved to injured um
that may help but
what we have to ascertain is what's the
level of injury so i called johnny a
name
how do you ascertain monetary damages
for for for for me
picking on johnny or calling him names
now i understand that bullying takes on
you know more significant actions than
just name calling there may be physical
uh uh uh
intervention physical acts that result
to bullying and and and other things
that that come along with that but
ascertaining the damages is i don't i
don't know how you do that if a kid's
being called a name or a kid's feelings
are hurt
uh some other aspects to the um to the
uh to the bill um i see that this is uh
only applies to to public schools and
charter schools
it should probably
be expanded to apply to the
approved school tuition programs under
rsa 193 colon 3 i believe that's
paragraph
six that's the decrying bill or sb8 um
from a couple years ago that allows uh
school districts to send their kids to a
private school why they are not included
in this um i don't understand but if
we're sending public schools off using
public money to a private school again
it seems that they should be held to the
same same standards as traditional
public schools uh and the other thing
that i'd like to to to mention as well
too
as we know uh governor sununu signed i
believe it was senate bill 263 a couple
years ago that opened up private rights
of actions in the discrimination realm
um if the student's being discriminated
against um
it's very possible and and
and i forget which of the speaker
representative leon it may have been you
or it may have been miss douglas talked
about a student who was being sexually
harassed or bullied on on one of those
protected classes there's a private
right of action um uh already available
uh under under that bill or under that
under that statute um and you know if
you ask more practitioners that defend
school districts on these bullying
allegations one
or school administrators if
superintendent or principal
one of the challenges um with these
bullying investigations is how to
interweave
the
the the bullying investigation under rsa
193 f um versus um a
federal investigation i'm sorry for the
investigations under what would be
federal anti-discrimination laws so if
it's a mix of bullying and sexual
harassment you're basically trying to
run two concurrent investigations
there's certainly some overlap um but so
it's not just bull bullying isn't just
sort of a separate
you know category out there there's
there's there's a plethora of
anti-discrimination laws as well too
that allow for private rights of action
against school districts so
um we don't think this is good public
policy um i just remind the committee
that again the goal of the statute
reading through the legislative history
and looking at the plain language of the
statute is not to eradicate bullying
within public schools that's absolutely
impossible the goal and the purpose of
the current version of the bullying
statute as it stands now
has been to implement greater school
district responsibility in terms of
investigation reporting parental notice
and things of that nature and the fact
that we have 1600 reported cases of this
tells me that school districts are doing
the right thing and we're investigating
these you know in the way that they need
to be investigated
so that concludes my testimony i'm happy
to take any questions thank you very
much
are there questions for
some
this
thank um representative
thank you for taking my question you
were talking about parental
responsibility etc but part of
um 193 path is reporting and it's very
difficult for a parent to take
responsibility if they are never told
about the
incident
um thank you representative was there a
question there
i did and i just didn't i'm sorry that's
quite a representative i understand the
point you're trying to make and um
further question represent leon uh thank
you mr chair and thank you for taking my
question you spoke to the protections
for protected classes
is that something where when is the
transgender
child sexually harassing the
cisgendered student where they also have
a private private rate of action or is
that only if it had been reversed and it
was the cisgendered student who is
sexually harassing the transgenders
thank you for the question
representative just please uh
excuse me sometimes the volume is not
great if a transgender student
sexually assaulted a a what a
cis-gendered student yes um thank you
for the question representative i'm not
an expert by any means an
anti-discrimination law i know that the
the bill uh that was enacted a couple
years ago i don't believe um has been
tested or litigated in new hampshire yet
so i can't say
thank you because that was the situation
at hand thank you
are there further questions of uh mayor
christina
i don't see anything i don't see any
either so thank you very much
thank you very much for allowing me to
speak for the record my name is marisa
chase i am the executive director for
the new hampshire association for
justice um the plaintiffs bar as um
attorney christina just mentioned
a couple points i wanted to make
one you know
attorney christina just mentioned that
senate bill 293 the anti-discrimination
suit um the anti-discrimination bill
passed with the private right of action
a few years ago has not yet been tested
that means that there have not been any
lawsuits filed testing that i think that
lent that explains
or demonstrates rather that there are no
frivolous lawsuits filed in new
hampshire we have a very collegial bar
our organization represents about 400
members
and something else you know frankly i
found mr christina's testimony to be a
bit
condescending when talking about lawyers
wanting to make money
as
attorney douglas mentioned
plaintiff lawyers take cases on
contingency fee
that means they better be pretty well
sure that a case is viable before they
take it
a potential client someone has been
injured nobody ever wants to think they
need an attorney
they call a law firm the law firm does
hours of investigation usually having to
spend thousands of dollars on experts
for that investigation to determine
whether a claim is viable before even
taking it an attorney spends money all
throughout the case and may not even
recover at the end they don't recover
unless they prevail
that means again that new hampshire
attorneys do not take claims that are
not viable
that's why we don't have frivolous
lawsuits in new hampshire
new hampshire also has no punitive
damages we don't have runaway jury
verdicts so the claim that lawyers want
this to make money is frankly appalling
to me as someone who represents lawyers
and plays one before the legislature
um
you know i think that
as
mr
barrett christina
mentioned
again
senate bill 293 has not yet been tested
there have been no claims filed as
attorney douglas mentioned these cases
would have to show outrageous lack of
care
um it is important to note something i
would perhaps suggest is an amendment
new hampshire's civil justice system
does not recognize degrees of negligence
the criminal context
recognizes gross negligence willful
misconduct etc our supreme court has
never
interpreted
degrees of negligence a negligent act
i think
you can infer is is much a much
higher degree than we think of
colloquially
to be
immune you just have to be responsible
responsibility is the only immunity you
need
and
a law without
a
penalty is just a suggestion in my
opinion
thank you very much marissa are there
questions
not
thank you very much thank you i
good morning mr chairman uh good morning
members of uh house committee uh for the
record my name is carl ladd i'm the
executive director of the new hampshire
school administrators association i'm
not going to take up a lot of your time
repeating testimony that you've already
heard
i would just like to know
that so far you folks have heard from
four attorneys and each one of them have
come up with a different definition or a
different explanation of gross negligent
willful
gross negligence or willful misconduct
um
the one of the attorneys indicated that
the court would likely
determine that gross negligence is
outrageous carelessness but there is no
legal definition of gross negligence
in the state of new hampshire in any
case law
so what we would be doing with this
particular bill is opening up a whole
new
slew of lawsuits
contrary to
the prior speaker's
indication
there's going to be a whole new slew of
lawsuits at public taxpayer expense
to define gross
gross willful
negligence
i think that
without there being a clear definition
and some guard rails placed around this
piece of legislation
it will open up
an incredible number of lawsuits
having been a school building principal
for many years
and a superintendent when the statute
was first
initiated i can tell you that building
administrators spend hundreds if not
thousands of hours
investigating all of
the complaints of bullying that are
brought in front of them
and i can tell you that parents often
feel
that they are aggrieved because the
decision
by the administrator
may not have been what they wanted
or because of student privacy act they
cannot provide
the aggrieved parent
with the exact disciplinary measure that
the
administrator may have taken
so therefore they are upset because they
feel that the student may have gotten
off
but that may very well not be the case
with this
language within this bill any aggrieved
individual
so a parent who is aggrieved because
they feel that the school district just
simply did not listen to their
complaints and did not punish
the other child sufficiently enough
could also
bring forth a lawsuit stating gross
negligence or willful misconduct
i think that if i do agree with
attorneys alan if you folks really want
to
put forward some legislation
that gets at the heart of what it is you
would like then i think the language
needs to be much more narrow
um and i think that um you know i i do
think that there are uh certainly uh
school attorneys
who would be willing to work with the
sponsors on this um
and um
in the interest of time um i'll end my
testimony there and be glad to answer
any questions representative shaw i will
be sending a written
testimony as well thank you very much
carl are there questions for the school
i'm not sandy thank you very much dr
ladd
thank you
um as a as a courtesy i feel like a
judge here with attorneys wanting to um
rebut things i'm going to provide uh
jerry sallin
uh another very short time
short jury
to
thank you rick in the interest of the
committee's time i can just send an
email with my follow-up remarks would
that be best
that that would be fine
thank you that's what i will do
thank you very much have a good good
morning
you too are there any further folks to
testify that we have on this
okay so in uh summary here uh we have
i have 18 people supporting 29 opposed
neutral zero testifying
one two three four five six
okay thank you very much with that i'm
going to close uh
testimony and the hearing for hb one
um for those sitting here i'm going to
take a four or five five minute break
and then we'll come back in
silencio
okay for all our committee members uh
is that i'm muted now
because for all of many we're ready to
uh
open up the next hearing here we are
looking at hb 257
prohibiting political advocacy in public
schools
the prime minister i bill is max
abramson representative
as he
he has been promoted he's there welcome
yeah i hear you can you hear me yes we
can
okay i'm still not used to these zoom
meetings
just forget being a zoom and just do
what you normally do max
all right i'll do my thing uh i'm
representative max abramson i'm here
introducing house bill 257
um
which is uh aimed at
preventing political advocacy in public
schools
um this bill is is absolutely not aimed
at
public school teachers
my grandmother was a public school
teacher for 30 years and there were in
her time they're only handful of
school teachers who are pushing partisan
politics and what i've heard in
the seabrook school district and
winneconne school district is there only
handful of school teachers
um who are doing this the numbers are
are pretty low but the
the the principle is that public schools
are there to teach children how to
question all of our old
uh um assumptions the example that i use
is when i was attending school
we were being told over and over again
in the movies and textbooks and
material that was pushed in front of us
that dinosaurs were cold-blooded
reptiles
and we even saw a number of videos with
tyrannosaurus rex still dragging their
tail along the ground
and
i had read some articles
from
more recent magazines on paleontology
that showed that that wasn't true so a
lot of the material was outdated
um but they were i
was upset they were kind of taking sides
um the next issue that i saw when i was
a kid was that they were pushing this
idea of an ice age happening and that
continued all through
the 1970s and 80s and early into the
90s and at the same time they were also
telling us that um
global warming was going to happen
and i said this is
you know even as a kid i said the most
advanced super computers that we have
and the most advanced
uh information we have on uh weather
predictions and meteorology there's no
way we can predict so it's
climate change is one of those areas
that's uncertain and finally the schools
have come around
to
supporting what i think is a scientific
view
that
the
climate change is happening but it's
unpredictable and there's no way we can
know what what
the human contribution
to that is
the bill
simply says three things it says no one
no public schools shall campaign for or
against any political candidate or
measure that is on the ballot within
that district
we've seen
school district employees at winneconne
high school and some other schools
holding signs and i don't object to that
at all that's their absolute legal moral
and constitutional right
um whatever influence that may have and
whatever trust they may have with the
with the parents coming through
but i found that they were using paid
personal days to do that and so as i
walked by or as i even held signs myself
at some of the polling locations i felt
that they were using literally using
taxpayer dollars for for campaigning and
i think that's a big
that's a big no-no i'm not sure that we
need to spell that out in in the statute
in detail but i i felt like the use of
tax dollars for
political campaigning was was
was just not right as a matter of
principle
uh number two no employee of a public
school shall advocate for or against any
political doctrine or subject any
political position
to ridicule while instructing students
that's really two ideas um the idea that
that the whole notion of education is
teaching children to
you know take on the scientific method
and subject our old ideas to scientific
scrutiny whether they're political
scientific economic or otherwise most of
the things that they were teaching in
public schools
in the 1970s and early 80s in the area
of economics
have been disproven and a lot of the
historical debates that have gone on
have not been fully resolved and some of
them if you've watched
the article 5 convention debate and what
happened with the
philadelphia constitutional convention
and the
annapolis
uh convention of the states
that there's there's a lot of dispute
going on
uh
right now part three no student shall be
deprived of the right to freedom of
speech or of the press unless that
expression is not protected under the
first amendment
there are some schools
that have been selectively
censoring news stories
um
i'm not sure that it's it's more
conservative or liberal if it's more
right-wing or left-wing
but the idea of students having their
own paper
and expressing their own opinions
as long as it's not hate speech or or
something that creates a hostile
learning environment for the kids
i don't think that
that the
school district should intervene that
what we're supposed to do as adults is
maintain an environment where kids can
question promote their own ideas debate
them
whether they're for or against the death
penalty or their pro-choice or pro-life
i i think that it's something that we
have to do we have seen
rare instances
for example in seabrook there's a school
teacher who's still discouraging
her students from standing for the
pledge there's another
um
there's another school teacher in
winnicotta high school
i've been told that he finally stopped
doing this but he was promoting videos
that were
obviously very democrat leaning
historical videos
um
the the biggest concern though for me
has always been the textbooks it's the
teaching materials the videos uh the
films that they used to play
um
the majority of public school textbooks
come out of massachusetts and they have
a tendency to come out with a heavy bias
whether it's intentional or not when
people have looked at it objectively
um
they're they're seeing that it's not
objective at all
there's a report on a
one of the most popular textbooks out
there called the american pageant
says whereas democrats woodrow wilson
and franklin roosevelt are described
respectively as quote a lover of peace
and quote the premier american orator
unquote
republicans dwight eisenhower
republicans dwight eisenhower was an
example of quote the bland leading the
bland unquote and ronald reagan was
quote no intellectual unquote
the report on the american pageant
uh materials high school curriculum goes
on to
uh show other examples where they're
promoting an interventionist form of
government they're promoting
progressive economics and they're
promoting a one-sided view
of american presidents and
this shouldn't have any great impact on
people but i see kids coming out of
high school
and when we talk to them they know
absolutely nothing about our history
they don't know uh that for example
dwight eisenhower was one of the great
civil rights leaders of our our
uh our country's history so much of that
just gets washed under or even barry
goldwater's
civil rights voting record most people
don't know about it because the public
schools don't teach it and so the media
doesn't mention it it doesn't get
mentioned in debates
or that seven out of eight civil rights
acts were signed by republican
presidents
parents find out after the fact that
books like this one i'm not going to
open it it's called it's perfectly
normal and planned parenthood
puts
material like this
in the public schools
and a lot of parents have objected to
that after their kids have been exposed
to it we passed legislation a couple of
years ago to try to
notify parents before
their exposed kids are exposed to this
but it has
um drawings and depictions of children
as young as 10 years old boys and girls
masturbating
gay sex interracial sex and things
that some parents object to and those
parents have a right to raise and
educate their children according to
i don't want to go into into
too many of the examples of specific
cases of censorship this bill is really
aimed at just the general principle of
protecting in in public schools and
charter schools it's meant to protect
the environment that kids grow up in i
personally don't have any objection to
parent-teacher conferences if politics
comes up
even though that might violate some
other
uh
constitutional principle
for me in particular
kids when they're young and
impressionable
need to be exposed to lots of different
ideas
good and bad ideas they need to learn to
compare individualism and collectivism
keynesianism versus socialism
and laissez-faire and all the different
ideas that are out there all the
different political and economic
philosophies and views
on on history so what the bill is
intended to do is strengthen some
existing laws like rsa 191
that kids are not getting a one-sided
view of things that if there are
textbooks and there are teaching
materials that are heavily biased or
partisan
that
we reject those that that
school districts not select textbooks
and teaching materials and video
that are are one-sided but that
the ask questions rather than take the
heavy-handed approach of telling you
what to think or believe
so
that's that's why i've introduced this
bill
i had intended to introduce it um two
sessions ago
um but i think that
that now that this has become much more
public and now that we're outside of a
you know
the national partisan environment that
we had a couple of years ago i think
that this is a better time to introduce
this kind of language
thank you very much representative
stevenson are there questions for the
sponsor of the bill represent milo
uh thank you representative vlad thank
you representative for taking my
question
so i have a concern here if we have for
example
a charter school that has been granted a
charter
and that charter school basically uses
uh
let's say rush limbaugh's text
and only invites in conservative
candidates
this law would
and parents have chosen the school
because of that particular mission
i would assume that this law would
prohibit
that kind of uh granting of a charter to
that particular school is that correct
it's not it's not meant to prevent you
that reminds me of a quick story
it's not meant to prevent you from going
into a school
and stating things as a matter of fact
so i was invited into a high school a
few years ago to speak on what is
classical liberalism the kind of
jeffersonian gladstone philosophy and i
explained
what it is i didn't i didn't advocate
for those positions i simply said you
know here are the ten points of
classical liberalism
um
i was when i was in public school i did
have one teacher who would listen to to
rush limbaugh and a lot of conservative
talk radio but as soon as the literally
as soon as the first bell rang he would
push the stop button on it because
classroom time is for
learning and questioning
so
this bill would say you know yeah you
have to you know push the stop button
and you you can't use classroom time and
you can't use the public schools for
advocating for one position or another
obviously uh
rush limbaugh was was certainly pushing
for conservative positions but i think
he he's spending about two-thirds of his
time
mocking liberals and mocking uh
democrat politicians
um and there's there's no question that
he was definitely partisan so this
wouldn't be allowed
like the rush limbaugh show wouldn't be
allowed
in public schools or charter schools but
if if you had a conservative speaker or
liberal speaker or social democrat
coming in
uh they could speak but they they
wouldn't be allowed to come in and
advocate for positions they could simply
as a follow-up but my my question though
to you representative is that if the
mission of the school
is in fact
granted through its charter
to provide
a conservative viewpoint only
this law your proposal here
would negate that possibility if only
one side of the picture is in that
particular mission is that correct
that's the that's actually the intent
that's the intent of the building to say
that
when we're talking about tax dollars
this is money that's taken from you
you shouldn't be made as thomas
jefferson said to pay for the advocacy
of a position that you find morally
reprehensible or which you just disagree
with
thank you
representative
famous chair thank you representative
taking my my question
uh i come at this from both a public
school person and also from the
professor level but let me ask you this
oftentimes uh teachers or professors
when there are certain discussions going
on in class employ the
socratic
method they ask questions
oftentimes they teachers play devil's
advocate when some issue is being
discussed and to make sure that both
sides of
of an issue are addressed the teacher
will play demos africa and ask questions
uh from one perspective and then they
may
ask questions from the opposite
perspective so my concern my question is
if if a teacher in the course of trying
to get all perspectives
uh
you know represented uh gives expression
to
a perspective one way or the other
uh are they at risk of being reported on
by their by students is
you know committing advocacy is is this
a concern to you at
all well you're at risk of being
reported on
uh regardless but if if you mean what
what effect does the law have i don't
think that the use of the socratic
method provided this objective provided
that your
whatever it is a student advocates for
states as a political position the use
of the socratic method or even you know
hard cross-examination
of of
that student's viewpoint or statement
to eat whether it's to sharpen the edge
or really put in the question is that a
collectivist idea is that an
individualistic idea
that
that this bill certainly wouldn't
wouldn't prevent it provided it's fair
and objective and public schools and
charter schools
anything that's taxpayer funded must be
fair and objective and
equal to all sides
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my two quick
questions just for clarification one on
your first point about paid personal
days for teachers
your position is that if i'm a teacher
and i have personal days written into
the contract that i cannot use one of
those to hold a sign and outside a
voting uh
building
right you should not you should not be
able to parents when they found out that
i i have no problem whatsoever if you're
taking an unpaid day off
to go out and campaign for any position
that you want to once you're off the
clock as far as i'm concerned you're off
the clock the argument for paid personal
days was that those were personal days
where they were for stress or
uh
medical or
almost anything else that was for
you know personal
use that to kind of unwind as a as an
employee school teachers are in fact
employees
um
but it shouldn't it shouldn't be used as
a way to
compel taxpayers to pay for
one site on a on a warrant article or a
campaign or a candidate or another
thank you mr chairman one more quick
question please
uh
clarification on the example you used of
a teacher i think at winneconnet who was
implying or telling their students his
students her students they should not
stand for the pledge
i think that's the example you used um
that was uh i think that's seabrook
schools and i i actually don't know the
teacher's name but i'm not i'm not going
to use a specific teacher's name oh i
i'm not asking you to would you feel the
same about a teacher in that school who
was telling their students they should
stand for the pledge
um
as a liberty guy i believe that standing
for the pledge or making any statement
must be a completely voluntary act
joining a
any organization should be a voluntary
act payment should be a voluntary act
that whatever we want to get someone to
do has to be strictly voluntary
you can use persuasion and education you
can argue the case or or warn about uh
consequences of doing something or not
doing something but i don't believe in
forcing something on someone
thank you
thank you mr chairman so um
i had a question here uh
regarding the first portion of your bill
uh which states that um no public
schools shall campaign for or against
etc
uh first
i mean does that encompass all of those
who work there i mean
what what is meant there
the public schools the school district
as far as how the courts view it is it
it it's they'll be the school district
or they'll view the public school as a
as a kind of entity in it of itself and
it would be the same
um
if you had a company a company should
not be able to
campaign for or or any other
organization
when someone's acting in their capacity
within that organization that that they
shouldn't be using that capacity to do
so
none of this is about district
facilities or books or materials thank
you
so
um you're saying campaign for against
any political candidate or measure on a
ballot um
rsa 659 colon 44-a already states that
actual electioneering by public
employees
is prohibited
would that already cover
the employees of the public schools and
the school district
completely because not all advocacy
it's okay
all right it's it but it does say that
electioneer means to act in any way
specifically designed to influence the
vote of a voter on any question or
office which sounds remarkably similar
that to your statement or your language
that is on a ballot within that district
what would be the difference between
those two phrases there you're saying
that is on a ballot within that district
and the current statute which states uh
cannot influence uh the vote of a voter
on any question or office
are you saying rsa 659 section 43
44-8
sorry i i'm i'm on the the wrong statute
for uh prohibited acts
3 it's the definition of election year
there
all right i don't have it in front of
you i have i have 659 section 43
um but i don't i don't
um
i don't agree that they're the the exact
definition
um but it certainly is happening um
uh when i was gathering signatures for
citizens petitions and for
putting candidates independent
candidates on the ballot um
electioneering included
if i recall correctly just getting
signatures for a candidate it wasn't my
intention that if somebody wanted to
gather signatures whether they're a
school district employee or not they
should be
is that okay yes yes okay thank you uh i
just had another question on the second
what would how would you define
and how would you define political
position
um both of which are mentioned there
uh
particularly uh is there
would this encompass all historical
political doctrines
and political positions um as well as
contemporary current
uh political doctrine would just be
something that that is actually up for a
vote either for the voters
or for the elected officials
that it
it's some it's something that people
argue for where you're trying to get
people to vote
uh in favor of or
or
um
against for example my civil rights bill
of 2019 that's uh that's a political
position
the civil rights acts of 1866
1871 and 1875. those were all civil
rights acts they were they were
political questions
and uh a doctrine would favor something
like abolition or suffrage women's
suffrage suffrage for for free blacks
and so forth that's advocacy
sorry advocacy for positions that i
think 99 of people support
um
but it it still wouldn't be appropriate
even if it's something that you and i
agree with and probably everyone in this
room agrees with
to
to to push for that doctrine to push for
a doctrine because what what schools are
supposed to do is get kids to challenge
absolutely everything even if 99 even if
100 of people in society agree with
something
the learning process is about learning
it's about learning how to question
things it's about learning the
scientific method itself it's about
learning to apply that or to choose
whether or not to apply the scientific
method to political questions and
political doctrines it's not about
pushing you know one set of conclusions
or another
i i
one final uh i certainly agree with you
on the notion that um you know the one
of the major functions of teaching and
of education is to um
promote
questioning and promote uh i think the
generic term often is used as critical
thinking uh
but i wonder who would determine
uh the line between simply promoting
questioning and critical thinking
versus
advocate
or ridicule
which are both words in your
proposal here who would make that
determination who would determine that
who would define what is advocacy and
what is ridicule as opposed to simply
promoting questioning
every time
we
enact a law or propose a law whether
it's this committee or
it's well understood that the ultimate
determination the ultimate determination
of fact is usually handled by a jury
and that the
questions of law are handled by the
courts um ultimately by the new
hampshire supreme court um and in very
rare cases it moves up to the federal
courts but i would think that it's uh
it's something that would ultimately be
decided by the new hampshire supreme
court
if it's unless it's a matter of fact in
which case it's handled in trial courts
thank you
uh represent woodcock
thank you mr chairman representative
anderson thank you for taking my
question if you may i'm looking
specifically at line four and line five
on your on your bill max
uh the part that talks about
uh
a measure that is on a ballot within a
district is so it's not as no school
public school show
um
i just want to be clear
it
when
at least at least in my school distance
this school district i live in uh when
they have a building bond
when they have positions on the warrant
annually they send out to all
people in this town or on the postal
patron mailing list
information about the bonding and that
why it should be supported what's
necessary or the warrant why it should
be supported or other pieces of the
budget the why should be supported i
mean it's you know it's a it's a
high-gloss brochure they take ads out in
the local newspaper explaining their
budget why these bonds or bills or
warrants whatever it happens to be
should be supported but i'm reading here
the school public school which you said
was the district shall not any measure
that is on the ballot within the
district and these these um typically
always come out before the the uh the
ballot uh for the town meeting or where
it happens to be uh in our former
government so with that under your bill
would that prohibit the school from
sending out that
position and informational items on
bonds and warrants et cetera
it wouldn't prohibit them from sending
out material i'm from washington and we
had um
we had uh you know voters pamphlets that
would come in and they were really thick
they were they were as thick as the
house calendar
and
they had information they had
information from both sides
um sorry my phone's ringing gotta ignore
it
and they're sending out information both
sides
it would be fine
if the school district or the town or
the city sent out mailers saying here's
information
about what the what the article does or
what its intent is but it wouldn't be
appropriate to advocate for let's say
pay raises for the the supervisors union
or for or against it wouldn't be
appropriate for them to
to lobby the voters at taxpayer expense
that wouldn't be right
and in seabrook we people have seen that
happen occasionally on articles where
the town government is advocating for a
position
and people object to it they raise
objections but currently they don't have
uh or the school district does or when a
kind of high school does currently they
don't have any avenue
to
to put a stop to that
it's okay to make statements of facts
and it's okay to make state to allow
um equal time for both sides on an issue
but it isn't okay to take a one-sided
position and force taxpayers to pay for
the one-sided position advocating you
know against taxpayers interest
just default mr chair for me we're
running kind of short on time here and
we have another person like to ask the
question well this is one follow-up uh
representative davidson so
on that behalf on in those written
documents if it says the school board is
supporting this 7-zip or 9-zip
and
that's what they're doing they're
supporting this bill bond warrant where
it happens to be or pay raise or
negotiate a contract um they're telling
you what their position is
so you're saying they would not be
allowed to do that because they're
taking a singular position
they would be allowed to make that
statement in fact the reason that they
are allowed to make that statement is we
have another statute a more specific
statute that says
that they're required to tell you
um
you know if the budget committee or the
selectmen or the school board took a
position so when you
pick up the town warrant and you look
through it it'll say the school board
supports this five to zero or the board
of selectmen supports this three to zero
they're allowed to say that
represent ford do you have a question or
are you okay
no i have a question uh mr chairman can
you hear me now
yeah yeah
uh my concern has to do with uh i don't
sense much in your
bill that recognizes the academic
freedom of teachers and faculty
in terms of what they teach and what
opinions they might expect or their
concomitant academic responsibility to
present
a full range of perspectives on it and
this would seem to impede
on those rights which i'm sure they're
going to stand up almost immediately
do you do you have any
do you have any room i suppose in the
way the bill is stated that protects
their academic freedom to maintain
their interpretation
i don't think that the bill does
uh
step on uh
a teacher's
um
right to express their opinions i just
don't believe that while the school is
on the clock or while the teacher is on
the clock or any public employees on the
clock that they should be
promoting one side or the other like i
say my grandmother was a public school
teacher for 30 years and i
i
knew quite a lot of school teachers and
the vast majority of school teachers
would never even give the appearance of
advocating for one side or another they
just like a judge insisted on being
completely objective to the very end
trial by jury that
the judge tried to remain as objective
as they possibly could we put this a
similar position on the ballot and
winneconnet in 2013 and it passed with
about two-thirds of the vote it passed
in every single town from northampton to
southampton
and the teachers union
officials were arguing that this would
this would take away freedom of speech
and
that was presented from in front of the
voters and the voters said no it doesn't
take away freedom of speech and
is it 60 to 70 percent of the voters in
each town
uh voted for this similar measure to say
you know public schools should not be
used for promoting political positions
or political doctrines and it should
they shouldn't be used for political
advocacy or
or any
partisan position
of any kind
thank you very much
are there further questions
not seeing your hands thank you very
can you hear me
yes yes okay thank you
so i'm penny colton i'm from temple new
hampshire i'm representing just myself
um in the interest of time i think that
representatives layton and woodcock
already covered um section one of this
bill which i oppose
um quite well so i'll go on to some
concerns about section two
um the bill's sponsor mentioned history
text so obviously the section does not
apply
only to local ballot measures as i
mentioned in the first section
and i'm wondering would this prohibit
showing for example
american world war ii era anti-nazi
propaganda as part of instruction
these things were often satirical and
satire ridicules ridicules excuse me
political doctrines
would a teacher who is presenting these
be subject to some kind of discipline
because of
the wording of this bill should it
for example also should teachers teach
that the separate but equal doctrine
didn't have any ill effects just remain
neutral on it one
be neutral on comstock laws or the dred
scott decision
should they be prohibited from
discussing the tensions that exist
between democracy and capitalism for
example
this section of the bill would i think
have a chilling effect on the free
marketplace of ideas that we expect our
public schools to be
after all as i think was alluded to
teachers often posit doctrines positions
and theories that
we're not advocating
but we're trying to prompt critical
thinking in students but
literally we would be violating
this law if this bill becomes law
in doing that so
i think that
um presenting something via certain
types of literature could be confused
with advocacy
and finally on this section over the
past 30 years i have taken i'm a teacher
and i have taken several contractual
personal days to testify before this
committee
over the past 30 years maybe about five
times
and i think that's a citizen's
responsibility um the personal days are
bargained into the contract and i'm not
instructing students when i'm doing it
the spot the bill's sponsor says it
would prevent
teachers from taking personal days to do
what i'm doing right now happen to be on
vacation right now but i'm being paid
for my vacation should i give up a day's
pay
this is a paid vacation i'm on right now
so i shouldn't be testifying in front of
this committee i hope not it's my
responsibility to testify about things
like this
at the present
school officials can forbid some types
of expression if they can prove that
these would quote materially and
substantially interfere unquote with the
operation of the school and i'm quoting
from the 1965 tinker versus des moines
supreme court decision tinker states
that first amendment rights applied in
the light of special characteristics of
school environment are available to
teachers and students it can hardly be
argued that either students or teachers
shed their constitutional rights
to freedom of speech and expression at
the schoolhouse gate a
very famous phrase i'm sure you're all
aware of this bill however would seem to
both
unreasonably restrict pedagogical
decisions of professional educators
while extending
the free expression rights of students
with no mention
of exceptions forms of expression that
could be deemed disruptive
currently forms of expression not
protected under the first amendment
include obscenity fighting words
defamation league libel or slander child
pornography and the bill sponsor
mentioned pictures of 10 year olds in
sec doing sexual activities that would
clearly be prohibited
it would fall under child pornography
perjury black male incitement to
imminent lawless action
true threats and solicitations to commit
crimes there is no mention
in this list of substantial interference
with school discipline or the rights of
others that's in tinker it applies to
schools
in light of the special characteristics
quote-unquote of the school environment
these are considerations that are
mentioned in tinker decision
and they're the current considerations
that administration uses for
restricting expression within schools
as somebody who's been teaching for over
35 years i'd have to say that issues
like this almost always come down to
whether or not something is disruptive
or infringes upon someone else's free
expression
um i think that
just limiting this bill to student
publications would work okay student
publications i think
they should get that freedom
um in conclusion it's my position this
bill should be found in expedient to
legislate in its current form um also
leave us with one last thought later in
the day this committee will consider hb
234 concerning freedom of speech and
association and post-secondary education
institutions i favor that bill and i
suggest
that the
provisions of it apply to secondary
institutions
excuse me when we're
starting to talk about other bills
there's a time for hearings on those
bills we are not talking 234 right now
we're talking
this bill which is addressing 257
political advocacy in public schools k
through 12.
so i'm not going to allow discussion to
go that direction we are a very tight
timeline here where we passed a couple
bills i uh prefer to stay with this bill
so can you find me
i'm done that was it okay thank you very
i don't see any questions thank you very
much
next we have natalie rotensi
good morning thank you all for giving me
a moment to speak you can hear me thumbs
up
yes okay okay great um my name is
natalie rotundi i am a citizen in
milford new hampshire i'm also a parent
of school aged children um
and i thank you for the opportunity to
weigh in a little bit on some of my
impressions from not only the bill as it
was written and i was prepared to speak
to this morning already but also in
reacting to some of
the ideas and questions that have
already been
discussed at this point
first and foremost i find it
i
find it a little um
scary that we would use uh past history
as president precedent for what we are
willing to talk about in schools i think
that our society is rightly pushing to
move political conversations from being
impolite to being necessary and the fact
that we need to learn to talk about
things with civility
um and with critical thinking is
important not only for us as a society
but also for us to model for our
children
um
right off the bat i have to respond to
the paid personal days i i just object
really strongly to the fact that as our
educators are paid with taxpayer money
that they somehow relinquish any right
to participate in our government
i have a corporate job i get paid time
off and um and and paid vacations and i
am not prohibited from using the that
time
to um advocate one way or another and
participate in local government uh that
does not mean i'm representing my
company's stance it just means that i'm
using my time um so i just don't
understand why we would expect teachers
and educators
um to relinquish their own personal um
personas and take up uh just a public
persona whenever they're participating
in our local government um that was one
thing uh the the
i'm
forgetting i've gotten to open another
oh it's perfectly normal i think that
sounds like a completely separate
discussion i don't think we should be
politicizing sexual health if that's a
concern that's a completely different
conversation
i don't think that
we need to
include this in this large of an
umbrella
i think it's very important when uh
schools should be able to link
legislation that has an impact on
schools and education and it doesn't
need to be only in the ballot i think
it's very important that our children
and students are exposed to any local
political movement
that does have an impact on their
education i think we're raising future
members of our society and i think we
need to trust our educators to be
responsible in imparting this knowledge
i think if there's an overdue um
overreach in terms of
either disagreeing with a student who
might ask a question or represent a
different stance i think those things
should be taken on a case-by-case
difference i don't think that that needs
to be handled by a court of law
as a first pass i think that those are
things that
students and parents need to bring to
their school administration i think we
need to have confidence in our educators
we need to have confidence in our
administrators to hear from parents if
they have concerns i don't think we need
to be shutting down conversations um for
for fear that our children may hear
something that we disagree with i
actually would encourage my children to
come home and share different views and
different perspectives that they're
hearing from in school even if i
disagree because it's an opportunity to
talk through these things
it's an opportunity for me to justify
why i might feel differently and why
they may feel differently um i cannot
if i'm releasing my children into the
public school system or they're leaving
my home i cannot reasonably expect that
they're not going to hear things that i
disagree with or that they may disagree
with or that are offensive to us i i
don't think that's a realistic um
goal or objective to have from public
education um
specifically uh the second section where
it says nor subject any political
position to ridicule i think that's
really vague i think that that is um in
direct opposition to that
socratic method that was discussed by
some of the representatives before me i
think that um it's much too vague the
way it's written that is
an
absolute um
tried and true effective measure of
education i used that both in my uh
secondary school education and then as a
college student
um many times having to be divided up
and to um represent a certain stance and
it's not always going to happen that in
one class block or however school has it
that you're going to hear from both
sides in that conversation that doesn't
mean that they won't come up
but i just think that's
much too much too vague and we need to
give children an opportunity to discuss
things and to use their ability to do
critical thinking that's going to
involve role-playing that's going to
involve breaking down different
perspectives and um and views
uh the third piece which the freedom of
speech peace um i think penny who spoke
before me um and thank you for your um
contributions to the education in the
i failed to see how this is going to be
read differently from hate speech um
the the freedom of speech in the public
domain is very much different from um in
institutions for example i can wear
whatever i want on the streets around
milford
but i cannot wear that on a professional
call
necessarily i cannot discuss
professional views um or in professional
settings certain political views
i think it's similar argument for the
school um i wouldn't want to see a child
wearing something that could be
offensive or saying something that could
be offensive or hurtful to others in
their school
and i realize that doesn't
mean any uh attempt at freedom of speech
is going to
necessarily be off-putting in those ways
but it doesn't say that those um those
things would be restricted so i just
think
what do we mean by freedom of speech and
i also want to know where
i wrote this down before and i realized
some examples were provided this morning
but where where have we prevented a
child um from having freedom of speech i
i would love to hear some concrete
examples where a child was stifled from
their freedom of speech because i think
as was said by some of
our representatives very well
um
if it ends up being disruptive to
learning
um disruptive to a collegial environment
with peers and with educators um then it
that that's no longer a freedom of
speech issue that is um inflammatory to
a learning environment and i think we
need to make sure that we're protecting
our educators and administrators from
being able to make those judgments
trusting ourselves that if we disagree
we can have civil conversations with the
people involved
to
to address it um so again i have very
much concerns over the the vague use of
um freedom of speech
um
excuse me for a second i hate to cut in
but
we
i'm looking at all the people are
testifying they sign up for three
minutes or two minutes
and we've gone well beyond the time here
and we are very tight with our schedule
so pretty please i wrap it up and then
i'm going to ask the remaining people to
i totally respect that i do have to say
this is my first time participating um
in front of the house so it you know
thank you for um showing me some grace
with this being new to me um it also was
very difficult to prepare a testament um
before hearing some of this dialogue so
i would just hope that maybe we take
that into consideration um in the future
that it's very hard to restrict the time
and have a prepared
testimony when i haven't heard some of
the things that i'm reacting to
but i i think the board
gets it and i'm happy to document this i
did not provide a written testimonial um
for exactly this reason i wanted to hear
some of the dialogue that was happening
this morning i would happily put a more
concise written testimony to this to
provide the host um the house
thank you thank you very much
thank you
are there questions
uh what i'd like to do is please remind
of those that are coming up to try and
stay
with the time that you
again
yes we can
all right um thank you mr chair and
members of the committee for taking my
testimonies today my name is sophia
biandolilo i'm 14 i live in manchester
and i'm speaking today on behalf of the
new hampshire high school democrats in
opposition to hb 257 and once again i
will keep this quick
um the essential issue with hb 237 is
that it is entirely unnecessary and i
can say firmly that as a high schooler i
have never seen a teacher make a
political stance during a class or try
to advocate for any candidate or another
teachers are professionals who want to
improve the lives of their students and
create a nurturing environment they have
no interest in making a space where
students feel divided based on politics
were they a teacher who is purposefully
advocating for some political stance
there are already policies in place that
deal with that type of conduct
schools can handle this themselves and
the legislature doesn't need to impose a
rule that schools are already enforcing
second and others have as others have
already said promoting discussion is a
central part of class engagement and i
think this language is dangerously close
to prohibiting that consider a class
like english or social studies if for
example a teacher has feedback on an
essay where a student covers something
political would they not be allowed to
instruct their students accordingly
would that part of the curriculum be
considered viol to violate the language
in this bill
i think limiting what teachers can and
cannot say could very quickly become
overreaching and would interfere very
directly with instruction
finally there's a section of the bill
that clarifies that students have the
right to free speech once again this is
just unnecessary students have been
guaranteed guaranteed the right to free
speech multiple times before and we
don't need to restate it here
if there is selective censorship going
on in schools that's already illegal
there was a case that reached the
supreme court in 1969 which concluded
that if censorship does occur in the
school
does occur in a school the school i'm
paraphrasing a little bit here basically
must be able to show that the censorship
was justified by something other than
the desire to avoid discomfort based on
the unpopular opinion
so based on what i've heard from the
sponsor this bill is supposed to prevent
that so therefore that type of
censorship is already prohibited as a
legislative body the state's
responsibility is not to simply declare
solutions to problems that don't exist
and i think our efforts would better be
focused on other places where there is
actual work to be done
so in conclusion i don't think there is
any real reason to support this bill as
it is just a solution seeking a problem
i asked the committee to vote in
expedient allegedly on hb257 and i will
send in my written testimony after the
hearing is over
thank you very much of the other
questions
okay much we have a brian hopkins brian
you've been promoted
thank you mr chairman
members of the committee
not sure what's going on with my camera
here
but
um
my name is brian hawkins i'm here to
testify in
opposition to hb 257
i will be extremely brief because i
think the last three speakers covered uh
everything that
i was going to mention
lack of definitions and vagueness in
this bill particularly as a as it
relates to
uh what is a political doctrine um
fine line around
advocating uh
and um
also um you know i think there
with respect to the uh issues that the
sponsor brought up around electioneering
as representative lay mentioned earlier
i think that it is already covered in
uh 659 44a
election hearing for public employees
and so i i don't think
uh with respect to that issue um this
bill is necessary
um and so i'll just i'll just close my
testimony there one thing i will mention
people talked about uh
time off uh you know obviously people
have freedom of speech and public
employees in addition also have
freedom of speech rights under 98e
and
and those have long been
held as an important
component
to
our
statutes for
freedom of speech for public employees
i'll close my testimony there and let
you
move on with the hearing if you have any
questions i'm happy to answer them
thank you very much all right uh
represent sean
yes brian who do you represent
uh nea new hampshire
sorry if i didn't mention that at the
top
you might have i missed it
thank you very much brian
questions uh mr hawkins
dancing thank you very much thank you
um
are you there
i am thank you chairman thank you
members of the committee i will be very
brief as most of nhsba's concerns with
house bill 257 have been addressed
representative woodcock you mentioned um
can a school board advocate for its
budget or a bond or the collective
bargaining agreement because those
issues appear on the warrant those were
some of the concerns that nhsba has
um specifically as it relates to
collective bargaining agreements school
boards have obligations under rsa273
to actively support passage of a
collective bargaining agreement so this
may be in conflict with that um and
certainly nhsb believes um uh school
boards have have a right under existing
first amendment law to advocate for
their own budget initiatives their own
bond initiatives things of that nature
um and last uh relative to paragraph
three of the bill where it speaks to
freedom of the press there's a supreme
court case from i believe 1987 or 1988
commonly referred to knows the hazelwood
decision in that decision uh the united
states supreme court ruled that if it's
a school-sponsored publication the
school district has a right to
maintain some editorial content over
that so um the while the speech within
the the article itself it was protected
speech a student wrote an article um
about teen pregnancy that certainly
protected speech but the court said it's
a school district newspaper it's an
extracurricular activity the school
district has the right to control the
content within its own publication so
we think that um that provision about
students having
unlimited freedom of the press um would
run contrary to uh current um scopus
decisions and interpretations of the
first amendment with that i conclude my
testimony uh we're in opposition to the
bill and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you very much
are there any questions of the school
boards
good morning again mr chairman
members of house ed for the record my
name is carl ladd the executive director
of the new hampshire school
administrators association
um nhsaa is opposed to this legislation
i think primarily because
it provides the opportunity for too many
unintended consequences
because the language is so overly broad
and vague
as an administrator for many years
definitions matter because that is how
we define
our actions uh so when a school board
makes policy or when there's a statute
we look for the definition and the
meaning behind the definition in order
to be able to interpret that and then be
able to enforce it
so very practically
[Music]
my concerns are around some of the lack
of definition of what a public school is
representative abraham said it was
basically everybody uh who works in the
public school
um
so that means the superintendent the
school board the custodian the food
services worker
not just the the teacher which is what
this seems to be aimed at uh there's
also no real clear definition of what
campaign means
um does that mean
if i'm campaigning as a superintendent
does that mean i'm calling people does
that mean
if i meet people at the transfer station
because as a superintendent i'm never
off the clock
um so if i meet people at the transfer
station and they ask me about the bond
or the budget or the cba that's coming
up that i can't talk to them about that
and advocate for the board's position
because i would then be campaigning
um for a measure that's on the warrant
i think that that um
i think that that could have a really
chilling effect
and i don't think that's the uh
intention of the sponsor but that could
definitely be an unintended consequence
um
dependent upon interpretation which
could then end up leading to lawsuits
in order to define it which is what the
sponsor said would have to happen so
that means that
if i'm campaigning
uh at the transfer station answering
questions which i often did when i was a
superintendent
that means we could end up in court
in order to define that
that seems
a bit of a stretch
so
the other two parts of this i think have
been addressed really well
i'm always concerned about the practical
implications and the applications of
what these
proposed bills do
and so
for those reasons we're opposed to this
legislation i'd be glad to
answer any questions
thank you very much uh carl
are there any questions of the school
administrators association
ralph
yes representative
do you think
rsa 65 659 column 44a covers this anyway
uh thank you for the question uh
representative baum i don't have that
rsa in front of me so i i would be
hesitant to
uh say yes or no just because i haven't
i don't i don't have that one memorized
thank you very much all right
are there any other questions for
thank you
thank you mr chairman welcome are there
any other folks that have signed up for
a hands up
okay with that i'd like to close this
hearing
um
and in
reading the sheet for everybody where
which your folks signed up on to testify
or just to submit their position
neutral zero
and total to testify
okay with that we'll close this hearing
on
now we have two hearings left that are
scheduled for lunch and we're obviously
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go into the next one
but then uh hopefully we might be able
to get through that
and then to
um
open up uh 458
and then um
recess until following the last bill we
have up today 234
so we can get back on schedule following
launch
so with that i'd like to open up um
my hp 215
committing school districts to contract
independent schools and private schools
and i'll recognize uh
chairman ladd for uh construction of the
bill
thank you very much i'll be very brief i
think this is uh first
for the record my name is rick vlad
i i'm a representative from haverhill
this is among several bills which are
going to be coming forward during this
session referencing private schools
in the past we reference private schools
be it in the tuition contracts
or be it uh for some other form of a
contract as either uh sanitarian or
non-sectarian but not both
and
this one this bill right here you can
see that there's uh incorporation of
independent school
independent school it's there just for
reference it's already defined elsewhere
in statute very clearly an independent
school is one that has a board or
trustees which are not elected publicly
elected
and we have several of those schools
which are our students in this state are
attending
pembroke and st johnsbury academy are
then the other part a literary
institution
our research people over the legislative
services look up literary institution
there is no determin a definition for
this term
in fact it came about back in 1874 it's
kind of hold over in our
our our stem story language
uh i did have some information quietly
yesterday there are no
literary institutions in the state has
this point
uh however there was an article that was
appeared in one of the papers back uh in
about the new hampton literary
institution in new hampton new hampshire
and i'll just read this little article
it's it's advocating for schools located
in the foothills of the white mountains
near the center of new hampshire
no saloons billiard halls or other
temptations to wrongdoing
school educational ambitious and worthy
students cordially
six solicited
courses of study one classical with the
use of a four-year degree
our school with greek classical without
three
latin scientific the requirements of
technical and scientific schools english
scientific
academic
prepares for general life's work
and commercial a few college preparatory
schools are prepared to cover a field so
broad religious influence uh cost very
moderate
um
in full particulars upon application
that was by the principle back then a
man named preston that's the only thing
we could find referencing of this type
of institution in our state so it's a
feeling that where it doesn't exist
anymore to scratch that from our
statutory laws
the insertion of private school though
is one which has been done in accordance
with recent uh
supreme court uh findings uh espinoza
versus montana
uh that that occurred this previous year
and to to allow
public funds to be used to make
contracts with religious schools
and the religious schools
we
it's my expectation we don't exclude
religious schools from public benefits
solely because of religious status
and that decision was made
as the
supreme court saw in violation of the
free exercise clause of the federal
constitution
and it all goes back to the blame
amendments
so throughout this country so i'm
looking to
in regard to what we have going on in
our society today with this awful
pandemic
you cannot even get your kid in our
student in a private school now they're
all booked they're loaded including the
church uh schools
um homeschooling is double
and parents are looking for these
options and they're not necessarily
looking for a religious school they're
looking for a school
that is in business and willing to
accept their children so that they can
take advantage of these months that are
being lost in terms of
many of the schools being closed many
days during the week
so in conclusion this is an effort to
incorporate private schools as a
that can be contracted with by schools
to receive students in the state thank
you very
much mr chairman
any questions
scene none
good
afternoon everybody um
my name is jody underwood
i have just finished eating so i
apologize
um i am vice chair of the croydon school
board and i'm repping representing
myself today
i appreciate the opportunity to speak in
favor of hb 215.
my town was a defendant in the court
case that ultimately led to the passage
of the so-called croydon bill i
participated as the chair of the board
the school board
during that case the presiding judge
looked at the phrase including but not
limited to in an rsa and interpreted it
to mean
limited to
but that experience taught me is that
until the legislature reigns in the
judiciary's ability to redefine common
english words to rationalize the
outcomes it prefers there's really not
much point in fussing over the words of
statutes but if we're going to fuss over
words it would it would be a mistake to
take a phrase
well like literary institution or
something more general to to speak to um
representative lad's point
that was clear until the the court
decided to arbitrarily interpret it to
exclude private schools and replace it
with a phrase that would exclude
everything but schools
um because as the past year has
demonstrated vividly having alternatives
to the traditional schooling model is
essential to the resilience of our
society
so if
there's still a chance to amend the bill
i would add private and independent
schools to be clear because
that that was the intention but it ended
with a more general phrase
again probably not literary institutions
but to keep it in the general sense
that's intended by this um rsa
thank you
did representative did you have a
question previously yes i i do and i i
apologize it was it's for representative
ladd and i couldn't get my hand up soon
enough uh
just a clarification representative ladd
you're i think you're
i need a clarification you're saying
that
under the determination of private
school or the definition of private
school that would include religious
institutions and therefore under under
the bill as written a local school
district could write a contract with a
religious school and local school
uh educational money would be used to
fund that is that permissible under this
that's correct thank you
next
thank you very much uh chairman cordelie
members of the committee bear christina
new hampshire school boards association
opposed to house bill 215
um i i guess one of our
one of our questions is why is this
necessary
um i don't i don't understand
what this clarifies i certainly don't
understand
why it needs to be added to to rsa 194
colon 22.
um we have senate bill 8 the croydon
bill that was referred to found in rsa
193-3
um i i
that that may or may not cover this this
this issue um i'm not going to get into
a conversation about the espinoza
decision um
this bill and absolutely no way
addresses the espinoza decision or what
the supreme court said about um uh
privatization and voucher programs um so
i just i i opposed the we oppose the
bill because i don't understand what it
does or or
what the intent does and i think there
may already be
coverage in
in rsa 193 3 paragraph 6 and the
subsequent provisions thereafter so
um that's that's the scope of my
testimony i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you
questions from the committee
scene
thank you very much for the testimony
thank you very much
mr and the
best uh person to testify it looks like
good morning again thank you very much
chairman cordelli and members of house
ed for taking my testimony on hb 215
nhsaa is opposed to
this legislation
primarily because once again it doesn't
provide for transparency and fiscal
accountability
that should exist in the distribution of
public funds
we've witnessed recently
with a specific charter school within
new hampshire um significant issues that
can arise without a strong fiscal
reporting and monitoring accountability
system in place
in that particular instance there was
over a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in misused taxpayer funds as
reported by the doe
that resulted in the rescission of the
school's charter and left over 40
students and their families scrambling
to provide an alternative education
that was due to poor oversight and lack
of accountability
private schools independent schools
especially those in other states are not
responsible in any way to the local
taxpayers who are funding those proposed
contracts
there's no level of direct
accountability in the way of publicly
available policies procedures
requirements except whatever they
provide
nhsaa really views this as just another
attempt to divert public taxpayer funds
to private and independent schools who
operate under significantly different
rules
if public schools are held to a high
level of accountability because they
accept public funds
then so should private and independent
schools
so we really respectfully request
that you vote this as an expedient to
legislate thank you very much
thank you for the testimony
uh representative
uh thank you
thank you for taking the question
in the case of
a school district saying we want to send
x number of kids to this private school
don't the voters
in that district have the final say as
to where their money is going
they very well may depends on the the
it is up to the the local taxpayers
in order to enter into any kind of a
contract
i think the the concern really is about
where that uh where that fine level of
accountability goes to and whether or
not um those schools have to follow the
same rules that public schools do uh you
know we just spent a great deal of time
talking about uh hb 140. um if this goes
into effect does that mean that these
private and independent schools are
going to be held to that private right
of action
uh like public schools will be even
though they're accepting public school
funds
i just think that if we're going to
uh if we're going to make these
these rules
they should be applicable to everyone
who accepts public funds on not just the
chosen few
thank you
[Music]
i think we're oh
thank you mr chairman
dr lead
how would do you know how special ed
funds or services
or idi idea compliance
relates to this particular proposal
thank you for the question
representative miler
my understanding is that
if a student receives special education
they very well may or may not
be able to participate in this private
school that they've reached a contract
with
which could then exclude them
i do know
when i was the superintendent in monroe
and we sent our students to
st johnsbury academy some students went
there some students went to woodsville
high school
that
parents of special education students
were discouraged from attending st
johnsbury academy at the time
and most of them ended up going to
woodsville high school so i think that
there is um there is some cautionary
notes
uh around this um
proposed legislation regarding uh
students with special needs
thank you
thank you very much um any further
questions
see none
[Music]
thank you mr chairman
thank you we will close the hearing on
no i'm sorry no not yet no
okay um
so we just uh
did you have the number of people that
uh
okay so that hearing is closed now
uh i'm going to open up
hb45k
this is a bill relative of division of
menstrual products for students in need
and i'm going to
recess the hearing
to take place following the last
i think someone who
was going to testify
at this point
so with that um we will recess that bill
to
follow
234 this afternoon likely to be
somewhere around 3 30 thereabouts
so with that we're going to break for
our lunch right now and reconvene at 12
45.
um
a point of order i think
deals with the recessing
of uh 458
i think if you recess
don't you have to
i mean i i recall last year we we did
that and we had to do it i mean the
problem is you've got people in the
queue
who have wanted to you know who want to
testify on this
and you're now saying well wait we're
going to have to do it later in the day
i i think procedurally if you recess it
you have to repost it
so it's it's a question
it's a question of of the chair
uh a procedural on this thing
why wouldn't we just go ahead and do
just if we just go ahead then you
that's true we we could put that right
in there
i'm just i'm just conscious of those who
are
you know are in the queue and have
waited for this so that's all last we
have you know i don't know recess the
word we've opened it up
and and then taking a break
and and come back
i know there are some bills we have
actually done what what i suggested to
do but i'm all for just going right on
rather than
then uh putting it off let's go ahead
and address it right now and just keep
marching down through our agenda
good
thank you mr chair
okay
point of information mr chair
yes
my only concern here is that you did
actually recess the hearing and indicate
that it would be done later this
afternoon which may have caused people
to already drop off the um
yeah see
and i did recess it and i did give it a
time approximately like 3 30. i recall
saying that yes
so i think there's nothing that's been
um
i recess it to that time
and it's today and three approximately
three
but the point of order mr chair i think
it has to be posted for public notice
and i i think that's what representative
miler was
talking about
you controlled the time all of those
have been posted you control the time
for the whole
whole day
i i will just call the course i just
are you checking with the clerk uh rick
salad
um
since you're entering in where you speak
yeah
it's the same thing that's been since
really
oh
[Music]
okay for the committee out there i did
contact the uh paul smith's office talk
with him
that's the clerk
and he is the process which we took is
is appropriate it's been done before in
other words i opened it up i reassessed
it to uh follow 234 and set a time
approximately 3 30.
um
the other process is also acceptable
where you just put it off till after
lunch and you keep marching down through
but because i did announce that i'd be
doing it this afternoon at approximately
3 30 after i opened it up
that's the one we have to stay with
okay thank you mr thank you mr chair for
the clarification okay good so what
we're going to do now is we're going to
continue
on our schedule
that we're a little bit behind on here
now uh with uh four zero one
is the bill relative to the duty of
school superintendents regarding
that's right welcome representative
thank you very much mr chair and i just
want you to know how happy
lieutenant mike mcquaid from the
department of safety and attorney diana
fenton from the department of education
are
that you s stuck with 401 right now
because i know they're out there
uh and some of them might even be on
vacation this week so uh
thank you for having me uh in today and
i will begin and i will be brief
uh house bill 401 actually began its
life as house bill 1136
last session
it is a bill
designed to
give the authority to appoint a designee
to the superintendent of each school
district to assist with criminal
background record history checks and uh
it went through with strong bipartisan
when uh everything went sideways last
march so it is back to you today
in a new improved form and i just want
to go over with you a little bit about
the intent of the bill and the amendment
that i sent out yesterday
i apologize for this i just want to
reassure you it's not covid it's uh an
allergy
so um
401 would grant the superintendent the
ability to appoint as a designee
specific people within the supervisory
union to act either in his or her stead
or uh in addition to
we heard testimony last time that the
bill came before us about situations
that might require a superintendent to
need help
ranging from
uh what would happen if a superintendent
became ill or needed surgery and was out
of commission and was the only person
that could review criminal uh history
checks
uh how would that impede hiring in a
timely fashion
we heard about
things like superintendents being on
vacation and last minute resignations
coming in over the summer and school
districts being unable to hire people
because they did not have the
superintendent on site
we heard about the fact that the size of
a school district greatly affects
whether or not this is a one-person job
or it could in fact require more than
one person to manage the the the number
of uh
cases that were being investigated for
potential employment
so uh hb 401 seeks to give the
superintendent that authority
subsequent to
1136 which was representative eisner's
bill the last time
uh last session house bill 1558 made
changes to
13 a which is the criminal history
statute
and broadened the scope
so in conversation with the department
of education
specifically attorney diana fenton
we discussed the need for expanding
training for superintendents and now
potentially their designees
to
learn how to read and interpret the
information that was going to be put in
front of them
because
1558 actually allowed fbi checks to to
happen
and so the scope of the criminal history
check became
larger
uh originally attorney fenton and i
thought that this training was going to
be done uh with conjunction with the
department of safety
but the department of safety having the
bill already been drafted uh came to
both attorney fenton and myself
and talked about their belief that the
training
best lies in the hands of the department
of education
and so the amendment that came to you
over the weekend
simply move removes the department of
safety
from the training process and puts it
squarely back into the hands of the
department of education
and uh attorney fenton and lieutenant
mcquade are both in attendance today to
speak to the various aspects of the bill
i am happy to answer any questions that
anybody would have
and i would now turn it back over to you
thank you very much uh represent mullen
uh represent like this do you have a
question
yes i do thank you representative mullen
for answering our country
um it has to do remember last time when
we did this
said that because of some fbi rules or
whatever that we couldn't have a
designee
have you since talked to them and
figured out i i have uh the
what they were initially objecting to
was just the term designee
subsequent to that to what we did the
last time around um what they were
actually looking for were specific
people to be
designees and so if you look at the bill
the designees are the assistant
superintendent the head of personnel the
director of human resources
out in the bill
and
uh i'd love to be able to tell you which
line they're on but i can't see it at
oh 11. hello in the bolded print yeah
so uh head of human resources personnel
director the business administrator the
finance director some of those people
seem um i don't know perhaps a little
odd you know why would the finance
director be the alternate uh to looking
at criminal history checks
but in some of the smaller districts
they don't have people to fill the
positions the other positions that are
listed
and so what we tried to do was look at
the makeup of a variety of districts and
sizes and determine okay
who
who would be a person that would be able
to be a second in a district
uh hence the finance director the
and your representative has a follow up
thank you
welcome
so the um
safety people were fine with the wording
the way it is now
yes and and uh they will be up
there they're in attendance today so
you'll get an opportunity to ask them
any additional questions thank you very
i'm not seeing anybody opposed to this
bill
i think everybody's seeing it as pretty
much supportive that's my looking around
everybody else is so i'm going to go
ahead but i asked that
folks
are testifying tried to
you know keep it short and perhaps we
could
accept this bill at the same time
representative whitcock
thank you mr chair representative mullen
thank you for taking my question as i
read through this i i'm trying to
determine
if each district is allowed a singular
designee or multiple designees i
couldn't pick that up so
uh i don't think that it's it i i don't
think it's spelled out in the bill
representative woodcock
uh i i would like to
say that
that that's on purpose it's not
uh but
i would think that it would be up to the
superintendent whether or not they felt
that
if they had 400 criminal record checks
that were sitting on their desks then
perhaps they would employ you know
designate human resources and personnel
okay are there are there any further
people in question
okay we'll go on to the next person's
testimony
hello can you hear me
yes
thank you mr chairman good afternoon
committee members my name is mary eisner
i'm from derry new hampshire
hb 401 is being introduced from hb 1136
which was passed by this committee and
by the house in the last session but due
to the impact of coven 19 was laid on
the table by the senate which
representative mullin has previously
stated
currently only superintendents are
allowed to process criminal records in
the application process this bill
specifies who the superintendents might
choose may choose as a designee the
assistant superintendent head of human
resources personnel director business
administrator or finance director
by allowing a designee to process
criminal history records it relieves
superintendents from this employment
application function by statute
superintendents have 20
educational responsibilities to perform
providing adequate staffing for school
districts is an ongoing process
throughout the year
derry is the third largest school
district in the state derry school
district had approximately 886 employees
from july 1st through october 17th of
201 219
192 records were requested
as of 2020 the human resources
office fingerprinted approximately 178
people with 605 employees not counting
substitutes
once records are received and reviewed
and there may be a question or concern
additional time is needed by
superintendents to follow up on
interviews in most cases requiring
numerous contact attempts to schedule
interviews
by allowing superintendents to appoint a
designate to perform the criminal
background checks in the employment
application process is in the best
interest of our school districts and
would allow superintendents to perform
their main responsibility by educating
our children
this bill considers the time factor
involved in normal times for
superintendents to process criminal
background checks if there are any
doubts about the importance of this bill
we need only be reminded of how much
time that all school administrators have
invested this past year and will
continue to do so because of covert 19
in order to keep our schools safe and
our educational system functioning
recent reporting projects that we will
not be back to our normal lives until
the summer or fall
given the ongoing impact of this
pandemic and any similar issues that may
occur in the future this bill certainly
would be a welcome benefit to our school
superintendents and to our educational
system
therefore i encourage this committee to
approve this bill
thank you for your time
and i'm open to any questions
are there any questions
not cnn thank you very much
thank you
if those are just technical support i
lieutenant mcquaid
uh
can everybody hear me
yes you can okay i'm sorry about that um
i tried to uh log in as uh testifying
but uh for some reason it wouldn't allow
me um i i don't really have anything uh
additional to add uh
from uh representative mullins uh
testimony uh the only thing is i just
want to make myself available if anybody
has any questions um
and uh regarding the language to the fbi
nobody really truly knows what the fbi
is going to approve uh this is the best
laid uh plan to go forward to get this
legislation approved and we believe that
the uh the as far as the designee
outlining the parameters of who would be
included into that designee
pool will
push this legislation through to
thank you very much are there any
questions for lieutenant
thank you very much
with that i'm going to close this
hearing
we had 67 in support one of those one
neutral
and several testifying here
i'd like to close the hearing and go
right into executive session
so this hearing is closed i'd like to
recognize represent
for a motion on the amendment
which is zero one four eight
thank you miss j i made a motion to
so we have a motion on the floor to
approve
zero one four eight h
made by reps and boom and second by
representative mullen
further discussion
with that i'd ask that representation
please
yes
representative allard
yes representative lakes
yes
representative moffat
representative hobson
yes
representative andrus
representative ford
yes
representative leon
representative sodhi
yes
representative miller
representative luno
yes representative shaw yes
representative cornell
yes
representative tanner
representative tanner is at a doctor's
appointment and will be back later this
afternoon
okay
representative ellison
yes
representative woodcock yes
representative ladd yes
19-0
representative do you have a motion
yes mr chairman i make a motion to uh
ought to pass on
to pass as amendment and men did on
house bill 401
is there a second represent
i'll i'll second it thank you very much
so we have a motion made to approve hb
401 as amended with zero one four eight
h
representation
representative cordelli
yes
representative baum yes
representative allard
yes representative
yes
representative moffat
representative hobson
yes
representative andres
representative ford
yes representative leon
yes
representative soti
representative miller yes
president luna
yes
representative shaw yes representative
cornell yes
representative uh ellison
yes
representative mullen yes representative
lay
yes
representative woodcock yes
representative ladd
yes
19-0
consent
yes yes
consent yes
thank you
which we had previously that got messed
up last year right uh i think the
representative we're sending forward
even a better bill what you've done with
okay we are
a couple minutes out of uh doing the
next bill here
you can get a drink of water or
something we'll start right at uh a 115
for the next bill
that's your bill
can you tell me representative i mean uh
lieutenant mcquaid's first name
lieutenant
yes it's michael thank you i thought it
was but it wasn't positive i just want
we always refer to lieutenant's lt
um
okay
[Music]
okay it's now 1 15 we're ready to go
ahead with the next hearing
which is going to be hb 321
requiring
school districts to submit an annual
report concerning gifted students
the prime sponsor this bill is
represented
uh representative moffitt are you ready
to present
uh yes mr chairman
well
thank you mr chairman for the record i
am mike moffat state representative for
merrimack district nine which does
include the towns of canterbury and
loudoun
okay this measure measured very simply
calls for a uh best practices folder of
sorts uh or a virtual folder at the doe
department of education for districts to
simply share
policies or initiatives that address the
unique needs of so-called gifted
students
there is no policy mandate there is no
spending requirement and there is no
expectation that anyone process or
analyze data or information unless they
wanted to
it very simply just involves a best
practices folder to facilitate the
the sharing of ideas and approaches and
also to perhaps
raise some awareness in this area
uh this was first introduced a couple
times ago
uh one rep looked at it and said uh this
just sets up a folder uh this should
probably go on consent calendar
but it did not so why did it not and the
answer
lies in our legislative committee
process and how we
uh properly do due diligence and we ask
questions and we scrutinize and
sometimes over scrutinize every aspect
of possible consequence of a bill
and this process is useful in preventing
bad bills from moving forward which we i
think we're pretty good at i hope
but i think that occasionally
overthinking or over scrutinizing
prevents split bells from moving forward
like uh i think is the case here
uh during the exec session three years
ago considerable time was spent
discussing the issue of defining what
may constitute a gifted student
so this bill intentionally describes
gifted only in the broadest terms
preferring to let
local districts properly decide what
they feel constitutes gifted as opposed
to having a
prescriptive definition imposed upon
them
uh there are also concerns about
imposing a new reporting requirement
but again all this measure involved or
involves is simply mailing or emailing a
message with appropriate attachments if
there are any uh simply just describing
existing policies or initiatives
regarding gifted students
if there are any
the requirement pretty much could be
satisfied in a minute or so with an
email a link or an attachment just uh
sharing what is in place if anything is
in place
uh and sadly i think because so many
districts do a little or in some cases
nothing in this area the uh the message
was simply say
i think in too many cases we currently
have no programs or initiatives
regarding gifted students
uh going back three years another
concern back then was about imposing
another administrative requirement on
d.o.e um
and back then i did talk to some folks
at the aoe
in fact they talked to
one just earlier this week
there is no expectation the attendance
measure does not ask or expect the dna
do anything other than simply maintain
the information so someone can access it
if they wanted to
the
best practices for the virtual or
otherwise
there's no requirement for analysis
there's no requirement really for
anything
unless they wanted to in which case uh
dna would have some material to process
if there was some interest in doing
something
again uh three years ago speaking to
several doe people uh i sense some
some of them were intrigued and even
excited about this this measure
uh and yet another fair question that
came up last time around involved the uh
the notion that this
folder could be requested or set up via
doe or some other organization a
professional association
as opposed to
the legislature
and the response to that is that
we feel this is such a neglected area
that is so important that
it needs the imprimatur of legislative
statute to underscore
how seriously we take the problem
of a vastly underserved school
population
uh sending a request for paperwork from
some administrative offices is one thing
that's easily ignored
but passing a statue
shows that people are paying attention
and they take this
properly seriously
and that's why there's so many people
tuning into the sharing or at least
tracking this girl's progress right
there's
probably some press accounts and
widespread interests and what if
anything flows forth from here
again going back three years jennifer
four very
wonderfully helped me to research what
other states do in this area and as i
said then i'll say now
new hampshire is arguably one of the
worst states some might even say the
worst state
in the country in terms of what we do
in terms of gifted students
they said back then that even
mississippi has more to show in this
area than we did you know i know
mississippi gets a bad rat
rap i've never been there nothing
against mississippi but i didn't say
that because looking at what mississippi
that did they had special schools that
they said a lot of cool stuff
that
that we don't
so anyway uh the the 20 2018 i thought
we had a little bit of paralysis by
analysis and so this proposal was sent
to refer to interim study
we
the chair set up a seven-person interim
study committee
uh representative shaw chaired it i was
on it and we met several times that
summer and thoroughly discussed all the
above issues and others
and then the interim study committee
overwhelmingly voted to recommend future
otp
and some of you will recall in in
september of 2018 the school committee
did have a meeting
and we discussed the interim study
recommendation of otp and
uh i always recover i remember
representative shaw making the motion uh
representative mary giles seconding it
uh and i lost the member of
representative meyer looking at me for a
moment and then smiling and voting otp
as well
and then the
the full committee recommendations for
otp however this was september 2018 it
was uh there was a new
session coming up and
there was no reaction to be taken then
uh and as you probably all know i was
not a member of the subsequent
legislature as the uh
the voters in their wisdom opted to give
me a hiatus so i i really don't know
what happened
uh last session in terms of this this uh
bill which had already been approved by
interim study and by the full committee
so anyway uh i hope we'll uh give it a
good look this time around and i'll also
say it was obviously it is very
bipartisan bill
my good friend senator loud alexander
was a co-sponsor then and now
and as i mentioned my democrat friends
on this committee were quite supportive
and god bless those who had questions
back then that hopefully have been
answered by now
so anyway um
we're hoping this moves forward this
time around
again with no policy requirements no
spending requirements uh
next to no administrative expectations
uh what this film would do would be to
facilitate some local conversations and
discussions
about how to better serve a long
neglected but very real and substantive
student population
now these local discussions that we hope
will flow from this may not always be
comfortable in some places but
we think they're overdue and
and we think that wonderful things could
flow from this uh at basically no cost
and finally is a product an advocate for
public education uh i and others see
this as another little measure that can
help increase support for
public education so
uh here we are back with the different
students proposal and i'd be happy to
take any questions thank you very much
representative martin are there
no
this might be this might seem obvious
thank you for taking my question and
thank you for allowing me to ask it
so
would you surmise that
[Music]
allowing programs for gifted students
might be more attractive to those that
might want to draw their children off
public school is that kind of like what
the intention of the bill is
uh thank you for your question
uh i hadn't really thought about that it
wasn't particularly the intent of the
bill to have that effect some may see
that as a side effect i hadn't really
thought about that but
uh
i i think that it could be a positive
by-product uh from just shining light on
this
thank you
representative i do have one question
for you um
is there going to be any guideline or
anything sent out from the department
regarding
um
if you're going to be asking for
including gifted as athletics and
academics
is there going to be a breakdown in
the gifted student sometimes is seen as
the student has the intelligence the
achievement
those more academic oriented side
and then the talented
side is those which are
like the athletics the basketball player
the high jumper the the
person in the theater
um they're artistic
so is there any any uh guidelines going
to be provided these districts so that
we're getting information reported back
that someone uh able to be collated into
a final report
uh thank you for your question mr chair
i think that question uh just might go
back to the point i made about
overthinking
uh
again we try to keep this as clean and
simple as possible
the format
of the report is totally at the
discretion of the reporting district so
there is no specific format
it does mention
three different areas academic artistic
and athletic
that could be potential areas for gifted
students to get attention but
that is is totally up to the district so
whatever the districts opt to send
they can format it any way that they
want uh so there is no reporting format
uh by design you just want to give them
a chance to share whatever they want to
share
gifted student means
should we be saying gifted and talented
student
thank you for your question and i
i know this came up uh last time around
and in
i think this was a bad time and now it's
kind of a case of getting down into the
weeds a little bit i know some folks see
a distinction between gifted versus
talented
and
and you could make that distinction
but again uh
this is something we would like the
the uh the districts to to think about
uh in terms of if they want to broaden
their response to
some description of what they think is
would be talented uh that's totally a
local decision we're just asking them to
share whatever they want to share if
they have anything to share thank you
very much
representative are there further
questions for representative
yes represent my own
uh thank you mr chair
and thank you uh
representative moffat for taking my
question
the concern that i have with this is
that
because you you want to have it
fairly open-ended
[Music]
what kind of data do you expect to
gather from this
and who at the department
will monitor the receipt
of this information
and how might the department use this
information so there really three
questions there
okay thank you for your question
representative uh so remember the first
point the first question had to do with
the data
uh
just remind me how you phrased the first
first one is this what what type of data
do you expect to get from a school
district
thank you for that question uh don't
know that's why we're asking uh very
simply um
we're
looking to say explain simply set up a
uh
eight say clearinghouse but just a place
a central place where
programs or initiatives or approaches
regarding
that are done locally for gifted
students could be
uh in a place where others could could
access them
and and look at them as a quick example
when i taught at trinity high school
they had a math club and a math team
uh now that might be an example of
something that was in place way back
then at trinity for
uh
students who either liked or gifted in
math
so if that was sent to them to the
father that would be a simple example of
something that the uh people who want to
look into this could see what's out
there being done
uh not looking for any uh specific as i
said to the chairman we're not looking
we have a format for requesting data we
just ask giving folks a chance to share
what they have
regarding at doe and i have had some
communication with them then and now
uh it made it clear to them that we or
those of us sponsors
uh certainly have no expectation that
they analyze or process this information
other than to uh have it in basically in
a folder so if somebody
wanted to see what's out there that they
could uh go through the folder and on
their own see what's there now as i said
earlier if doe or if if some other
entity
wanted to do some research or or correct
or
organize some of this information then
it would it would be there in a
convenient place
but there is no expectation for doe or
requirement for them to do anything
other than just just receive it and put
thank you
thank you further questions
thank you very much um
thank you very much miss rexella
um
are you able to hear me yes we are okay
great
um so good afternoon my name is anne
marie banfield and i'm an advocate for
parental rights and academic excellence
and education
i am here to testify in support of hb
i ask you to bear with me as i go
through this because i think that where
i'm coming from is
might be very different from where the
sponsor's coming from and i'm going to
touch on some of the reasons why i
support this bill but it may be not not
in his intention
this bill requires all public schools to
submit annual reports to the department
of education
there is a new focus on educational
equity but there is a difference between
equity and equality as it relates to
education reform
equality was considered a good thing
until recently
equality means treating people the same
equity by contrast means elevating some
groups of people so that the outcomes
are equal
that may sound okay but i think it's
important to look at how this is playing
out in the public schools
so looking for ways to elevate students
who have been marginalized in the past
in an effort to make sure that those
opportunities are available provides
equality of opportunities
compare this to eliminating gifted
programs so that all students are
performing at the same level
this would still deny marginalized
students opportunities but now there is
equity in outcomes
so i want to go back to the
massachusetts miracle
which was
which is a good example of equality for
all students the marginalized included
pre-common core the massachusetts
department of education focused on
improving it improving academic outcomes
and targeting marginalized students in
order to improve their opportunities
under the current model where
competency-based education is introduced
the focus becomes on closing the
achievement gap
we are seeing this played out by
bringing the top down in order to
achieve equity and outcomes
we've achieved equity by taking away
opportunities for the gifted children
instead of focusing on helping to
elevate the marginalized students to
gifted levels so that they can achieve
the success success that their peers
have achieved in the past
this was a topic that dr sanjay stotsky
spoke about when she addressed the state
board of education in new hampshire
several years ago
she was the senior associate
commissioner of the massachusetts
department of education from 1999 to
2003.
while there she directed complete
revisions of the state's pre-k to 12
standards of every major subject
that has been judged this has been
judged amongst to be amongst the best in
the country by independent experts
on the 2005 7 9 11 and 13 tests given by
nape massachusetts students had the
highest average scores in grades four
and eight four and eight in both
mathematics and reading
the scores of the state's low income
students compared to those in other
states on nape's the two seven thousand
tests were tied for first place in
grades 4 and 8th mathematics and in
grade 4 reading in grade 8 reading they
were tied for second place
the massachusetts miracle included
drafting the best academic standards in
the country a focus on academic content
and professional development
choice in educational options and
tutoring for students who needed extra
help
since 2010 in the adoption of common
core states have moved away from this
proven model
that has directly impacted opportunities
for all students who strive for gifted
programs
i'm going to send you a copy of this
written testimony with with actual
graphs that show how proficiency levels
have declined
the university of connecticut education
professor jonathan plucker criticized
school districts for using the common
core standards in order to cut funding
for gifted and advanced students in
education he said
we found plenty of evidence that may
that many districts are using the
implementation of common core to cut
services to advance students
this is when we began to see a real
effort to eliminate equality for all
students and focus instead on equity of
outcomes
this is what the national association
for gifted children had to say about
common core state standards despite the
obvious connection to the field of
gifted education the nature of advanced
work beyond the common core is not
addressed in fact the authors of common
core state these standards do not define
the nature of advanced work for students
who meet the standards prior to the end
of high school although the common core
are considered to be more rigorous than
most current states they fall short in
meeting specific needs of gifted
learners and if strictly held to the
standard could actually actually limit
learning
so what did this look like in indiana
the gifted program is to follow on grade
level with common core that ensures that
nothing special will occur for students
who are gifted even though the document
goes on to say that students will get
enrichment activities
it really implies that children will get
the same activities
that's equity of outcomes versus
removing barriers and offering extra
help to the student who has been
marginalized
[Applause]
for those of you who are interested in
improving public schools these are the
discussions and debates that we need
that need to take place providing the
direct help to marginalized students so
their opportunity for sex success is
available
why is it our nape scores have remained
stagnant or have declined since the
implementation of common core in 2010.
the massachusetts department of
education under new leadership abandoned
the reforms that elevated all of their
students and public schools the results
are shockingly dismal
but i suppose if you are looking for
equity they are now all underperforming
compared to what they were achieving
prior to prior to the adoption of common
core and competency-based education so
who in new hampshire is talking about
this
who has noted this problem and worked
towards making improvements
how much was invested in our public
schools since 2010 to align the
curriculum to common core standards
when will we finally start talking about
how to elevate public education in new
hampshire instead of settling from
mediocrity these are the discussions
parents are desperate to hear about
because parents do care about their
child's education and they care about
their public schools
the first
i'm just about done the first step is to
see what local schools are doing to
elevate these opportunities for all
children
marginalized students included not by
lowering the bar but by offering real
opportunities to improve the academic
content
so for these reasons i urge you to vote
ought to pass on 321. thank you for
taking my testimony
thank you very much mrs banfield are
i don't see any comments up nor here
okay
we have any others in the queue
jerry fruit okay from the school
administrators
okay mr crow you've been promoted to
oh yes i can can you hear me okay yes we
thank you mr chairman lad members of the
house education committee thanks for
taking our testimony regarding hb 321
we certainly appreciate the intent of
the sponsors of this legislation and we
have some significant concerns regarding
how this would be enacted practically
in the most glaring issue with this
proposed legislation is a lack of a
clear definition of gifted and talented
and without that definition there really
is no way to gather the data with any
validity
with 167 school districts and 18 000
1800 public and private schools in new
hampshire it's just not inconceivable to
think
there would be hundreds of definitions
of what constitutes a gifted and
talented student
we appreciate the sponsor's
concern and opportunity for
the gathering of the information and
placed in a file with the doe and
honestly there's nothing prohibiting
that from taking place now that could be
a great
tool
for utilization for districts who are
interested in participating and
accessing that data
each district or school determining its
own definition the data collected for
statewide reporting would just be
anecdotal at best and couldn't really be
used in any good way to determine what
programs resources or accessibility
actually exists for students
seems unclear as to how this data will
be collected analyzed and disseminated
and what's the purpose of the data
collection and if we're not going to
provide statewide assistance for
developing staffing and maintaining such
programs at the local level
then it would seem to have not much
purpose at all
those who have been around for a while
may recall once upon a time the state
had a gifted and talented coordinator
and was extremely involved and
supportive
in developing gifted and talented
programs in the schools and we might
submit that
thinking around
something around that
vein might be more beneficial to the
schools as well
we'd respectfully request that you
retain hb 321 to further define and
qualify the terminology and expectations
of the proposed legislation we would be
happy
and be prepared to assist you in any way
that you feel appropriate
um
it is an important
consideration to provide
gifted and talented opportunities and we
certainly would
welcome the opportunity to be uh a part
of those discussions moving forward
with that um i would thank you for
taking this testimony and
mr chairman i know that there's a
burning question in your mind wondering
whether i get the top bunk or the bottom
bunk and when i'm a good boy i get the
top bunk and when i'm a bad boy i get
the bottom bun
so i just wanted to put that to rest mr
chairman
thank you for taking my testimony this
afternoon very much sherry
are there any questions for the school
so i have one for you jerry
you reference what we once had here in
the state and i i unfortunately was not
here at that time i was administrator up
in another state
was our gifted program back then part of
the special ed program under that
umbrella
or was it
a program which was separate and apart
and funded through a different stream of
money
thank you for that question mr chairman
i do believe it was a separate program
funded in the department of education i
recall uh and those of you that may have
been around for a while mr allison
perhaps may remember michelle munson was
the person who was responsible for the
gifted and talented program and did an
excellent job working with school
have a a support with you please um
you speak of gifted and talented
uh whereas this report just says gifted
student
uh and i understand representative
moffett's rationale behind saying only
give the student he's trying to keep his
wife open
but
it
do you see the talented situation
talented side of this
as separate and apart from gifted
and if so how do we assess
the talented student
thank you for that question mr chairman
and i think that begs the very
opportunity that we talk of in terms of
retaining this piece of legislation and
working through those very questions
because i do think there's great merit
in um
in the in identifying the talented and
gifted components of what so many kids
have to offer um
their communities and and the community
at large
thank you are there further questions
for
not seeing any thank you very much
thank you mr chairman is there anybody
okay on this bill we had
or 12 i would say including the sponsors
and so that was for hb 321. with that i
will close that hearing and we will move
on in a minute here to the next bill
for the for the committee um
the schedule indicates that we
don't have the next one until 2 15 so
that leaves us a half hour
so we can uh open up discussion
on uh let's look back at this 321 bill
that we just finished
um is there any discussion we'd like to
have asked the committee on that you can
answer something like this
i think um
you're asking for specific definitions
of gifted and
putting talented in or not but i think
he's basically defined
gifted is a student identified as having
unique
academic artistic or athletics so that
would include talents and all of that
according to assessments selected and
administered locally so it's like if you
want further definition
that's the local
you know it's up to the local school
district to be fine and i
think that's
good because we're not looking to
do studies or you know evaluate or
whatever as he said it's just a place
for people to go and so the bigger the
pop the more things you're going to have
and so if a school is looking let's say
for what to do with their athletically
gifted
that'll be in the pot if somebody wants
to know what to do with their math
that'll be in the pot so making the pot
big you're more likely to have something
there
that another school district is looking
for
is there any further discussion griffin
milo
thank you mr chair you know i
i think represent moffat has
kicked this thing around a couple times
and and i don't think we've done it
enough serious to really look at this
um i mean there are students out there
that
obviously are gifted and
are not having
perhaps a kind of curriculum that should
be available to them
and and i i would think about retaining
this bill
and let's look at what this is all about
i mean if we you know we currently
are providing funding for some students
who are are struggling with reading for
example
why couldn't we have some funds
available to help
programs in school districts that can
deal with gifted issues and try to
identify something so i i'm looking at
this much broader than just
a file that you put stuff in that we
don't know
what the value of it is we don't know
what the definition of it is
it seems to me that that we ought to
look at this
in a much more serious way
than just um i'm not talking about
mandating things at this point in time
but to have a chance to really look at
this thing seriously for the first time
in a long time so that we can get a
handle on this so that we actually know
what we're talking about and know what
we might want to receive from school
districts that could benefit the best
practices for other school districts
so i think this is a little more to me
it's more serious than just uh creating
a file to sit on somebody's desk that
nobody's gonna look at it's gonna be on
that shelf of indecision and really uh
look at this in a much much more direct
way than perhaps the intent of this
is there any more discussion on this
particular topic from folks president
yeah um
i
i agree with both representative moffat
and representative myler in the sense
that i believe that you have to start
somewhere and you start somewhere by
taking your first step so
i understand representative moffitt's uh
desire to start gathering this
information
um
and i personally i mean i'm not that far
out from working in schools and i agree
that
uh sometimes our gifted kids are an
underserved population because
lots of them are able to learn
independently and they don't
you know shine a light on themselves as
needing the kinds of
uh
interventions that some of the other
kids do
but my question i i have a question in
and i'll poke fun at my own community
um
you know what do i do what do we do when
we think we have a hundred gifted soccer
players
you know i mean i get the fact that we
can give standardized assessments and
come up with scores and measure
achievement and uh
but how
i understand local
districts can measure their own but
how are they how are we going to
determine that one short stop is gifted
and the other one is just okay
so uh
i think that aspect the uh
the not the academic piece because i
think that's measurable uh but perhaps
thinking about what kinds of measures we
would use uh might
done you had your hands
thank you mr chair
this is an area that's definitely close
to my heart both with my experience
growing up with one of these programs
and because
so many so many kids and so many parents
in the state
are asking what's available for gifted
students they ask and they try and find
out what programs are available and
within the homeschooling community we
see huge numbers of students that are
leaving the schools
because they're not able to get the
challenges that they need within our
public school system and that's not just
for those traditionally gifted children
that's particularly important for the
twice exceptional students those who
have special needs and are gifted
because those children are better able
to hide their learning disabilities
because they get along well enough that
they don't uh call out that intention
i think that there are a lot of very
important different ways that you can be
gifted i mean i know that you call out
the idea representative mullin about
having a hundred gifted soccer players
but
you know you look at a small school like
zeus in the pacific back in our early
90s and you would never expect that
having the nigerian olympic team there
would bring in the nigerian nightmare
krishna nagoya coming up there but they
did because there was truly gifted group
of athletes at that school at that one
particular time and if our towns and
schools are able to
see where their population really
thrives there can be some wonderful
opportunities
that we can do with with a less
structured point of view i do know that
when people start talking about gifted
students especially academically there
comes into some of the issues about
equity and and other factors now i
started that i keep bringing up my mom's
school but with their 98 free and
reduced lunch they actually did have the
same number of students meeting those
academic requirements which was pretty
fascinating to see
but as we're able to recognize the way
that children really excel here in new
hampshire and we just collect that
information at this point so that when
somebody's asking what do we do for
gifted children
we can start
a better discussion with actual
information where somebody can actually
go to the department of education and
find out what's going on
i think that then when we see what's
actually happening on the ground in our
schools we much better positioned to
potentially do something to keep these
amazing talented students in our public
school system instead of watching them
quietly step out and pursue their
representative moffitt
yeah thank you mr chair let's have a
little extra time here real quick uh a
couple of things um
with regard to this going to file that
normal look at i just uh i think that's
a dismissive type of
uh
look at this i think a lot of people
will be very interested
uh in what was in that folder that they
could uh could look at
representative martin's point about the
soccer players is well taken and that's
why we uh want to leave this uh to a
local
uh
you know
let the localities uh you know have this
discussion as a process imposing some
prescriptive uh form or expectation
and uh and the last thing i wanted to
mention um
my word mentioned uh retaining uh
and we'll have more discussions about
this i think amending would be something
if i haven't seen me from them although
we could add the word talented i think
we should talk about amending before we
talk about retaining but then i have to
say that we've already done this dance
uh we sent this exact same bill to
interim study in 2018
uh we had a seven-person interim study
go through this in detail
uh overwhelmingly recommend that this
measure move forward with otp as i said
earlier in my testimony it came to this
or that for education with many at the
time which voted otp
in fact i already mentioned
representative meyer voted for otp back
then so rather than retain something
we've already done an interim study on i
think we should think about honoring the
the work that the union study committee
did in 2018
yeah there's number hands up here
uh thank you um and actually jerry few
was a superintendent in the school
district i worked in kearsarge
and you know
kearsarge had a math team
that really worked with the
the group that was highly uh motivated
and and gifted in math we had
um a literary group that worked with
people in
the arts and and
you know the drama program i mean
there's that's one of the the benefits
of extracurriculars is it gives it a
a venue for some of the people that are
gifted to actually pursue different
things that they are gifted in we also
at the middle school and elementary
school for a long time had a gifted and
talented teacher
and i don't think there was a big
problem in identifying who was gifted
and talented it was
you know the teacher that identified a
student who just wasn't motivated and
but she knew that or he knew that that
that student had a lot to offer
and um
there wasn't a lot of restriction on who
got into the gifted program and she ran
you know some some really
creative programs so i think
we've had that um you know around it's
it's
mainly in the schools that can afford it
and that that have the opportunity to to
do that i i think probably schools that
are struggling although they do have
math teams and things like that but you
know it's hard to offer
something else um
and i think it's it's a program that
needs to be discussed and needs to be
uh
you know researched um i i too think
that you know having something having a
coordinator at the department of
education
rather than just a portfolio
certainly gives more access to teachers
and and parents that want to want to
find out more about this so
um
i agree that the program is is this is a
a worthy bill um and i would like to see
us work on it a little bit so thank you
represent woodcock do you have your hand
up
thank you mr chair thank you so much
since you're taking commentary um
a couple of things come up in the
testimony how and one of the
realities is this bill
doesn't do anything more than what can
be done by doe themselves right now
schools send it in and put in the file
people going to access it but beyond
that i think representative
brings this to the table again that
wide of an issue than just a slim gifted
program it reminds me that that
doe doesn't have an advocate or someone
that's working to support this
and you look at the larger picture of
doe's support for curricular improvement
curricular review critical
administration across our academics um
they really haven't pushed a lot of
money or time and effort or efficacy for
whatever reason i'm not suggesting they
don't want to do it um or personnel to
look at all these curriculum places and
move them up and i think gifted
is just another piece and it's a
critical part of keeping kids in public
education uh and because our
cadre of youngsters now is so much
sharper and you know we need to be on
the upper level of that and we should
have an advocate there at doe i think
this bill has a huge potential um as doe
gets behind it as other curricular
pieces and starts to go forward but just
taking what is one school doing that can
be done now and i think representative
tanner's comments are uh on target as
schools have
money or individual initiatives from
certain teachers they go forward if not
they don't um
so i i would like to see the bill be
expanded but the bigger picture getting
doe to commit
uh resources and time and people to our
curriculum reviews so we can look at
what's the best for each area
thank you mr chair you represent like
this
yes thank you
sorry
the uh dele currently has that portal
where you can go and find out all that
information about schools and all kinds
of things so putting this file on
that portal so that other schools can go
and look and see what schools are doing
i think
should be fairly simple
and
gives that opening
this gets people
talking about
special ed i mean not talking about
gifted programs gets
school districts to say hmm
are we doing anything
we're not it starts the conversation
so we start the conversation here
look and see what's available look and
see what people have said they're doing
and then another bill
follows that conversation on to see what
do we need to go now but let's at least
get the conversation started because if
we keep saying
oh we need to oh we need to or we need
to and pumping this down the road and
down the road we're not even going to
start the conversation so this is to get
it started and then we'll go from there
thank you very much i just like to get
my two cents in for a second and
represent it forward
um
i think it's important that we get some
information in from the field
in my experience as a school principal
for years and that of a
a nationally recognized principle for
you know having excellence in the school
uh and school district
identification of these shopsters is
really important
there are a number of kids that i found
that become disciplinary problems
that are gifted
and just bored out of their minds
and with that they take the wrong path
i'm sure that you've seen that um
represent woodcock in the high school
we're losing a lot of them
so i i i really do feel that we need to
get on top of this and i don't want to
kick this tanning farther down the road
if we can get people thinking giftedness
and talented um
if you look at the bell curve
and you look at the people on the right
hand side of that bell curve what are we
doing other than maybe ap courses or
concurrent dual enrollment or
or odyssey of the mind or math counts or
grpps whatever you have in your schools
what are we doing to really get these
folks and and using their minds their
thinking skills and and and their
creativity and their leadership
um all this comes into play from gifted
kids
when i was a school administrator and
principal and teacher
we we had a program that was funded
locally where we did provide gifted
instruction with gifted teachers in each
school
and we identified kids based on
leadership creativity achievement
95s are higher on nationally recognized
standardized tests recommendations of
the teacher and the parents and also we
looked at the intelligence where are
they with their iq score
and a combination of those we brought
kids into the program
with the understanding there are some
kids that were very unique and maybe
didn't show up as well as they did an
achievement because quite frankly they
blew it off
uh so
i i would like very much to get
something out there i'd like to know
what kind of programs might be in
existence in this state right now
that are doing some of this
and having the ability to share that
with other school districts what i think
represents trying to do here
is what we've got to do we got to start
thinking this i put a bill in
must be four years ago
and
and it was shot down just like we shot
down this bill two years ago
and here we are dealing with it again so
we're we are kicking this can down the
road
so perhaps what we need to do
is before in the next several weeks here
or so put a couple people together on a
committee and work with representative
moffat to see how we might be able to
improve this if we are going to do some
kind of fact-finding from the school
districts let's try to help out and
design this thing so it might be of some
potential and assistance to our our kids
throughout the state
cameron
that's where he said she's a co-sponsor
yes
um
when representative lakers basically
said everything that i was going to say
but uh
i just think that sometimes if you're
if you start out
with something
informative like what exactly is out
there you know take a look and then set
up a committee in another bill
that will look at this information and
bring it further
that's that's the way i look at it i
don't want to put any extra burden i
don't want to have anybody
uh have to uh spend
all kinds of money in their schools at
this particular time
but let's find out what exactly is out
there
there must might be tons of things
and as that material is connected
collected
at the um
at the doe
it'll be in a best practices boulder
then we set up a committee or a
commission to study it
and we can go forward from there but
just find out what's out there first
that's that's my
that's why i think this bill is good
right now just what's out there
and and send things in
and then we'll move forward from there
thank you
represent luna
thank you very much mr chair um
yeah i mean there's a lot of stuff out
there right now um you know referring to
what representative shaw was talking
about
and i think one of those things and it's
a very significant piece is a book
written by carol dweck called mindset
and
it's the observations that she makes in
that book that that real
really give me
um what it makes me want to be a little
bit cautious on on this particularly
using
terms like gifted or or talented
because one of the things um
the author points out in mindset is that
when um when children are sort of
labeled as gifted or talented then then
they they
um
they develop a
they develop a mindset that um that that
makes them very adverse
to failure to mistakes to taking
challenges
feeling that oh i've been given this
magical gift
and now i can't do this i don't want to
be proven proven wrong or proven
incapable or having people laugh at me
um
and there's a lot of evidence out there
that suggests that um at least as as
carol dweck lays out in her book
um so so she
on the other hand um and and i think
this is consistent with a lot of the
testimony that or a lot of our
discussion too
um
steers away from using words like gifted
and talented towards focusing on effort
and focusing on growth so a growth
mindset
and um and i guess you know
i guess it's sort of fundamentally for
me
gets gets down to the um you know at
base what's what's being referred to
here in the bill i i don't really think
has a positive outcome for for for
students whether they're gifted talented
or otherwise and and that in enforcing
you know this this this
thought of effort um
or the the idea of effort or and and
desire and
passion for for certain things is is
really a way to be taken down and i
think again we may be looking at
at the same type of challenge but
but maybe through um through a different
um different lens
thank you mr chair
[Music]
okay can you hear me now yes you can
what i don't hear in our discussion here
is what i also didn't hear in the
testimony about hv 20.
no one mentions innovation
no one mentions sort of creative stuff
and maybe a better word is creative kids
generating the very creativity that's
out there
i think of a high school in texas that
gave
letters like football letters but in
things like latin
and i thought oh that's kind of an
interesting idea
no one did that in my high school but i
was in louisiana so maybe we were you
know backward
but
it's just the idea of getting again uh
what
has been said about
tagging kids we don't have any problem
of tagging them as athletes
and there's an athletic program in every
school
but we do we have one that says hey
being creative innovative whatever
you know find a better term for it the
one that's not pejorative or doesn't
create unrealistic expectations but show
that we are concerned that that's
important
whether we go out
to find out whether the schools are
doing it or to suggest to them we sort
of expect you to come in and tell us
and they didn't tell us that in hb 20.
they didn't tell us any they just said
give us more money to keep doing what we
were doing
instead of oh we've got a better idea
about how to do this better
if you could give us some money for that
then that would be helpful i would have
loved to heard that
all i heard was status quo ante
again and again and again
and that wasn't terribly convincing to
me
uh i'm a famous chair for letting me
speak yet again and i want to thank ross
and leroy
ford everybody who's spoken
uh again i bet that this
it's wonderful to hear uh what
representative ford just said what
representative said they're getting into
uh philosophy and definitions and
mindsets
and uh that's actually the purpose of
this bill this bill recommends no policy
whatsoever the intent of it is uh
representative shaw said and his
representatives i think most people i
think are getting the attendance bill
simply to start uh baby step start the
process gather information and all these
uh wonderful conversations and
discussion points that are now flowing
forth are coming forth because this bill
is on the table so what's what's
happening here in a micro sense is what
we want to happen statewide
and this uh this ball is a catalyst i
think uh
a very simple simple clean simple
catalyst to start the conversation
we've had the interim study committee on
this and we've voted on it before
so i just look forward to seeing this
move forward this time so that more of
this great discussion
can manifest itself and thank you for
okay we're gonna call this one just to a
halt right here we have a few minutes
before we start
we're gonna take about a four minute
break here so we don't walk down the
hallway at least i can
and
then we'll come back and we'll hear
represent rome
okay
somebody's
yep
checks
it's
crashed
okay
um
[Music]
help
yes
[Music]
can you call me two three four
six eight two eight
yes
six eight two eight interesting yeah
sorry folks i didn't know any other way
those five thousand calls you're gonna
get now barbara yeah i know i know
that's all right everybody knows it
anyway
procedures or something like that
i heard everybody there talking about
programs
[Music]
guys
wouldn't be the first time
[Music]
two o'clock 3 30.
my wife's running up and down the stairs
downstairs
okay for those people who are still in
the audience here
or in the committee
we're ready to go ahead with hd 71
hp 71 is an act relative school district
emergency special meetings
and the prime sponsor being
representative
representative holm you're recognized to
present
thank you mr chairman and member of the
education committee
i am ralph paul seventh term
hillsborough district 20 town of
littlefield
this is what i call a no means no bill
in the past we have had a lot of special
meetings for multiple reasons
i believe in 1998 as well with chains of
trying to keep special meetings at a
minimum
however the law states of the judge to
consider
the power
this makes the current law move
this this bill doesn't wait with the
consider
if the vote is saying no to a wire
article then it should be it
until the following year
i've lived in this field for 44 years
during that time we have had one article
fail
including contracts
no special meeting contractors worked on
and passed next year
a couple of years ago a teacher contract
failed mainly because of the health
insurance part of the contract
the alliance group water flight for a
special meeting as i said earlier we've
had them fail before work done over a
year until the following year in this
case the special meeting was granted the
special meeting was held in october this
meeting was not well advertised so not
many people turned out to vote we are an
sb210
the meeting was not
the wrong article passed
what this did was cause our tax bill to
be late
and rather coming out late october came
out in late november this made the bank
bill do right before christmas
merry christmas
argument made them caught was that the
failure of the contract caused a lot of
teachers to leave
this happens every year anyway
we're a small town and at the small town
we are a training ground and teachers
always move
and we have had multiple values of
contracts over my 44 years and as a
former school board member i've
negotiated a number of contracts and
also
selected negotiating the police contract
so i know it goes into contracts this
bill states no means no let's fix the
law and keep it out of the hands of
activist judges how many times over the
years have we have to fix laws because
of judges doing what they think or
follow their political leaders those
should mean no thank you and i will take
questions
thank you very much representative are
there questions for the sponsor of the
bill
any questions representative
no thank you mr chair so if i if i'm
clear on this representative what you're
saying is that
uh if a con if a contract
and if an employee contract gets voted
down that's it
they basically will not they basically
will not have a chance to
look at that or the school board
would not have a chance to renegotiate
that even though both sides agreed to
the initial tentative agreement
that means that they would basically go
ahead with no contract until another
school district meeting is that correct
because that happened over many years
and many times i've been even on the
school board
you just renegotiate you spend the time
working on it and come back and usually
in most cases the following year
contract goes back to let you act you
fix what was bad
and so
in most cases that i've seen in contrast
the teachers just have to wait they'll
get their raise even for the preceding
year so yes
thank you
not seeing any hands
thank you very much representative
uh
yep okay so uh good afternoon my name is
laura gandia and i am a parent taxpayer
and resident in litchfield and i am also
a former state representative who served
two terms
i am here to speak in support of hb 71.
as you can
there are times when a bill comes before
you with a story and this is one of
those times so i'd like to share with
you a story from the town of litchfield
in 2019 the collective bargaining
agreement between the litchfield
education association and the litchfield
school board was set to expire on august
31st 2019.
negotiating teams from both the union
and the school board met several times
between august 23 2018 and december 3rd
2018 to negotiate a successive
collective bargaining agreement to their
2017-2019 collective bargaining
agreement
the parties reached an agreement which
was ratified by both parties and
submitted via a warrant article on march
12 2019
the school board recommended the warren
article by a vote of five to zero but
the budget committee did not recommend
the article due to a tie vote of four to
four
the warrant article was defeated by the
voters on march 12 2019
after the article was defeated the
school board in the union met and
renegotiated a different contract and
sought relief from the hillsborough
county superior court
to find that emergency existed per rsa
197 colon 3 allowing a special meaning
to be held all to the detriment and
wishes of the legislative body that i
was a part of who previously and clearly
defeated the warren article in march
the lea petition claimed an emergency
existed to justify another election
despite the legislative body voting down
the warren article and despite the
ability of the school board and the
union to present their renegotiated
contract at the town's annual meeting in
march
about six months away from the date of
the requested special election
all this without regard to the voter's
desire and wishes as clearly spelled out
at the march 2019 election and at a
significant significant cost to the
taxpayers of litchfield estimates for
the special election i believe are
around 8 000
um the lea claimed that an emergency
existed which required the immediate
expenditure of funds
typically if you look at case law that
surrounds rsa 197 colon 3
an emergency requiring the immediate
expenditure in funds includes the
acquisition of land because it could be
sold
and or the purchase or repair of a
building because there's an urgency to
that if the building is going to be sold
or the repairs are needed immediately
which would result in an immediate loss
that clearly wasn't what was happening
here the lea further claimed that the
teachers will not receive any salary
increases for the
2019-2020 school year the lack of raises
during the
2019-20 school year will cause a
hardship to the teachers and again
that's the least claim
and they also claim that it was
unforeseeable and unavoidable emergency
arose which required the immediate
expenditure of money within the meeting
of rsa 197 colon 3.
the fact that the collective bargaining
agreement as put forth to the voters did
not pass was in fact foreseeable in this
fact pattern
the warrant for the collective
bargaining agreement received mixed
reviews and did not carry unanimous
support from the budget committee when
presented
therefore going into the election it was
foreseeable that the collecting
bargaining agreement could fail
in any event having a collective
bargaining agreement defeated
with support or in this case without
unanimous support is not unforeseeable
nor is it unavoidable in fact it happens
quite often
all of these harms claimed by the lea
are present during any type of labor
negotiations and to claim that it was
elevated to an emergency is without
merit and doesn't go in line with the
intent of rsa 197 colon 3 as it relates
to an emergency
further
when the court granted the school
board's request this sets a dangerous
precedent especially in this particular
situation
the lea had the opportunity to go back
to the voters in march with this
contract
every collective bargaining agreement is
subject to defeat that's part of how we
work in new hampshire
and the lack of a raise
should not and does not rise to the
level of an emergency as enumerated in
the factors set forth in 197 colon 3.
as some of you can guess as i already
stated the request for a special
election was granted and then the
special election was held at an off time
in the fall when many residents and
taxpayers were unaware that one was even
being held in that the contract passed
it's also important to note that there's
no local newspaper for litchfield at
that time and the voter turnout i
believe was quite low in the vicinity of
seven plus or minor voters where there
are over 8 000 8 000 registered voters
in our town
there was no urgency
the leas contract was set to expire on
august 31 2019
and the lea could have waited for the
town's annual meeting in march
this was not the case where there are
multiple years without a contract
clearly no urgency existed as every
collective bargaining agreement that
fail would fall into this category if
you're creating an urgency requiring
special meetings and leading to
discourse
and expense to the taxpayer tax payers
and disruption of the process
the will and the voice of the voters in
these situations would be severely
diminished and in some cases ignored
the intent of hb71 is to have the
process respected
the laws followed and the will of the
taxpayers and the legislative bodies
honored and respected
h.b 71 would prohibit a special election
for the purposes of voting on a contract
that was voted down
at a regular meeting
this concept is fair and consistent with
how new hampshire operates
i do not believe that rsa 1973 was
created to allow the lea the union a
special election to ratify a contract
that was voted down by the taxpayers
no means no and your recourse is to
present a different renegotiated
contract at the next annual meeting
not to sidestep or backdoor the process
but to have full transparency in access
to the voters
thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much for your testimony
good afternoon thank you chairman ladd
um again members of the committee nice
to see you
barrett christina executive director of
the new hampshire school boards
association
um i want to thank uh representative
bohm um and the previous speaker whose
name i didn't catch for sort of
explaining the how and the why this bill
um
came to be um as i said uh we are
opposed to the bill um i understand that
the collective bargaining issue is a
little bit different i'll speak to that
um in
in a second what i think is important
for context if if the committee members
have not looked it up um looking at the
bills as the court shall not allow a
special meeting if the emergency
involves any of the following and i know
the previous speaker talked about the
definition of an emergency in rsa 197
colon 3 but i just want to read it um
again so the committee is clear
an emergency for the purposes of this
section shall mean a sudden or
unexpected situation or a current or
combination of occurrences of a serious
and urgent nature that demands prompt or
immediate action including the immediate
expenditure of money
so with that definition in mind nhsba's
concerns with the bill are primarily
paragraph one which i believe is on line
five
um and paragraph three that is on
that is on line eight uh when we look at
whether or not a warrant article that
was voted down at a at a regular meeting
certainly the will of the voters should
be respected but that's sort of where
the definition of emergency within rsa
1973 comes into play i mean i think the
easiest example is a school board may
put on the on the warrant um to raise an
appropriate five hundred thousand
dollars for i'm just gonna say some some
capital improvement a new roof a new
heating system a new boiler whatever the
case may be
um but if we get into december or
january and that boiler fails or we get
a windstorm and the roof blows away um
the only way to to to to to fix that
issue maybe go back to go back to to
superior court um
to to ask for that 500 000 to fix the
roof even though the voters last march
may have voted that down i think that's
a true emergency that we need to leave
some flexibility within the law um to
address these sort of unexpected
circumstances in these emergency
circumstances
um and i guess the same argument would
hold true for for paragraph three online
i uh on line eight any item in the
budget that was not approved at the
regular meeting
um
again i can think of a number of
scenarios again mostly related to sort
of your capital expenses um where uh the
board was not able to anticipate
that the boiler would blow up or that
the roof would blow away or that we
would have an ice storm that would
somehow damage damage the facility in
the middle of winter so it may not have
been approved by the voters back in
march because it was just that it wasn't
an unanticipated um
an unanticipated event occurrence
expense that that came up and nhsba is
concerned that by if you were to pass
this law um you'd be significantly
inhibiting true emergencies with respect
to the collective bargaining agreement
um when representative boehm was
speaking i had a chance to pull up the
uh the decision um from the litchfield
school district that that he brought up
and and i read through it a little bit
uh just a couple quick comments on that
um one i was
to be honest with you i was a little
surprised at that decision um i don't
know if there are any other superior
court decisions um indicating that the
the the failure to pass a collective
bargaining agreement um constitutes an
emergency if that's the first one in the
state again i'm not aware of um but i
think the better process which is
already allowed in law relative to the
collective bargaining agreements and
many of you have seen this on your own
your own warrants in your own local
towns is often they'll have the you know
the warrant article for the collective
bargaining agreement maybe article
number three
but oftentimes school district school
boards will put article number four will
say
you know in the event article number
three fails in the event the collective
bargaining agreement fails can we go
back you know do you authorize the
school board to hold a subsequent
meeting uh to revisit the the contract
that's pretty common um in new hampshire
on warrants of my understanding
truthfully i think that's a better way
to handle uh circumstances in the event
a collective bargaining agreement fails
at the annual meeting um that way if if
the if the if the contingent warrant
article passes the voters have had their
say and and we're
agreeing with the will of the voters so
um just i wanted to comment on that a
little bit so the collective bargaining
language in in in the bill um i i think
there were workarounds for that outside
of having to go to superior court again
that superior court decision just
reading through it quickly um when
representative boehm was speaking kind
of caught me off guard but nhsba does
have concerns about again paragraph one
on line five and paragraph three on line
eight that in in our opinion those would
um address sort of true emergencies
which i think um the origins of rsa 193
colon three and going to superior court
are truly intended um to address so uh
we'd like to keep those provisions um
within the law in case those emergency
circumstances exigent circumstances
arise such that um you know the
immediate needs of the district and the
students can can be met in in some
manner uh that concludes nhsba's
testimony and i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you very much mr christina are
there any questions
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
christina uh i guess my first question
you may have addressed it sounds like
well in daring we do put those warrants
particle questions about uh having a
subsequent meeting so it sounds like in
your opinion that's a better way to deal
with it instead of leaving this up in
the air and then i'll have a follow up
sure thank you for the question
representative yes i think having that
contingent warrant article that follows
the the collective bargaining agreement
warrant article is a smoother process
both for the voters and the teachers and
and the school board rather than having
to potentially go off to uh to superior
court seeking judicial remedy to revisit
the collective bargaining agreement the
the the way i liken it as i mentioned if
you put that contingency warrant article
in front of the voters and they pass it
then you're allowed to you're allowed to
hold a subsequent meeting in line with
what the voters have authorized you to
do
thank you and then my follow-up is
similarly isn't there a process where if
there's something that wasn't approved
at the regular meeting they can go to
the dra or the budget committee in order
to be able to spend some unanticipated
revenues
thank you for the question
representative um
not to my knowledge not to the certainly
not to the the budget committee the
budget committee makes recommendations
on the on the on the budget the voters
then vote to adopt it and so the school
board is within the constraints of
whatever the voters have adopted whether
or not there's a process to go to the
department of revenue administration for
sort of emergency spending if if there
are there further questions for
christina
i i could not hear anything it was all
sort of garbled and choppy my apologies
so we uh asked
are are schools required to have
insurance to cover these uh unknown
thank you thank you for the
clarification uh chairman larry
i believe they are um
you know
any school district is going to have um
property liability insurance um and
insurance on on on the structure itself
um how that works i i can't necessarily
say but you know certainly in times of
covet i heard of at least a couple
school districts that had to go back and
ask for additional money to fix their
hvac systems over the uh over the summer
because the the hvac system was not um
well it wasn't it wasn't up to certainly
current you know best standards and in
times of covid um there were issues you
know relative to air quality within
schools so
i mean yes school districts that do have
insurance um
so i mean that may be that maybe one
avenue i don't know if insurance is
necessarily going to cover
the entire cost of the capital project
that may be necessary due to the
emergency
thank you
are there further questions
association
not seeing anything thank you very much
thank you very much mr chair you're
welcome
uh thank you
for charming next day
okay
welcome mr pro
thank you mr chairman thank you members
of
house education committee for listening
to testimony this afternoon i'll make it
brief you've got an ambitious agenda and
a long day
uh
many of the points that we would make
were eloquently stated by mr christina
we certainly uh
would agree with um
rsa 197 colon 3 and the opportunities
that are spelled out in that
existing legislation
also
the opportunities of collective
bargaining
and the school board being authorized to
petition for a special meeting
is important this proposed legislation
would eliminate the locally elected
representatives the opportunity to
determine the best course of action for
the school district in case of an
emergency or change in circumstances and
we see that particularly
in line with collective bargaining and
other issues so
we would respectfully
request that you find hb 71 in expedient
to legislate
there are remedies already in place to
handle those situations and i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you very much are there any
questions for mr pruitt
so where'd you get that bump behind you
i need to get one
i have to consult with my furniture
designer i'm my wife in other words
looks good
any any questions for jerry
thank you very much
yes brian ryan hawkins from uh
exactly
thank you mr chairman can you hear me
okay
yeah
good uh and i think i figured out my
camera too which was uh
looked like i had it half blocked at the
last
time i was testifying this morning
for the record of brian hawkins nea new
hampshire
here in opposition to house bill 71
we think that this
bill is a solution in search of a
problem um
and and some of the provisions of this
are far too broad
first off i'd say from the collective
bargaining
uh
piece um
uh inquired from one of our attorneys uh
how often
uh she's seen this um occur and at least
in her the last six years that she's
been at our organization
um this has only been um sought twice in
the last
six years across the entire state and we
and we represent the you know the bulk
of uh collective bargaining agreements
for for uh educators in the state so
this is not something that is sort of a
runaway train of uh people seeking
you know follow-up
uh
remedies from the court um
and
i think why would we want to take this
away
from a district
if they're trying to solve
an urgent matter i think it's
unnecessary to do that why not let the
parties go before the court if they're
going to make a case
for an urgent matter
as mr christina had uh mentioned you
know the guidance in the statute that
the court looks at and they looked at in
the
um
in the case that
representative bone mentioned was
they assessed the severity of the harm
to be avoided the urgency of the
petitioner's need
whether the claimed emergency was
foreseeable or avoidable
whether the appropriation could have
been made at the annual meeting
and whether there are alternative
remedies uh
not requiring an appropriation and uh
happy to submit that um to the committee
if you like the decision that was
rendered in the in the litchfield case
because i think it does
outline the reasons where
uh you know the petitioner in that case
met those um standards according to the
judge
um
so let them you know go before the court
the court can say no uh that has
happened uh gone
uh be before the court and that and that
and that has not been granted
um you know i think this is also a good
provision for taxpayers and for
um and for the educators in our state so
you know we start i think from the
standpoint of wanting good labor
relations in the state we want our
educators i think the legislature has
said we want our educators to be
to have agreements um i think this is
true from at the local level from you
know school boards and superintendents
we want an agreement to be in place
everyone is better off in that situation
from from that standpoint um you know if
if if after the process has concluded
and we've brought a collective
bargaining agreement to the voters and
they've said no
and we go back
and
seek another solution
that can be presented before the voters
because of the urgency
that the court agreed with in
for example the litchfield case
why not give the um the voters the
opportunity to
to say
you know
we said no originally the contract cost
too much um you went back
you came back with another agreement
that is going to cost less and that you
know gives us an opportunity to satisfy
uh both needs both the you know
something that costs a little less and
so that our employees
can have an agreement um
you know there are urgent circumstances
with regard to uh collective bargaining
agreements you know in the i think this
was true
and the reasoning that the
this was granted in the in the
litchfield case which is you know we're
in a very competitive uh environment
with respect to
um
teacher pay
and uh critical shortage needs
um why so
and as as representative bone mentioned
in his testimony
there were
the school district was losing um
educators
um as a result of this
uh the multiple contracts fought when
you fall behind on multiple contracts
it does
reach a point when
you know you are really in an urgent
situation uh with respect to making sure
that your district is competitive that's
good
for uh
the
people in the town it's good for the
students to make sure um that you have a
competitive
agreement in place we don't have you
know statewide salary scales we have
individual school district scales and so
all the more reason that that's
important
i'm just looking at back in my notes for
the uh testimony that was
put forward before um yes so i would say
you know in the case
that was brought up uh earlier you know
i think the parties did exactly what
they were supposed to do they heard a
message from the voters they went back
and they fixed an agreement that was
needed and needed to be put in place
in an urgent fashion last point i'll
make is not related to the collective
bargaining piece but to the
um you know the provisions that would
prohibit a warrant article or a line
item from returning
um
you know i think we've seen some urgent
examples of
the need to be able to go to court
uh
mr christina brought up a couple of
examples but you know if if if you had
had a warrant article in
march for everything shut down for the
pandemic that said we want to replace or
you know have a
substantial
fix to our hvac system and it was voted
down
um
according to the language at least as
how i read this bill you couldn't bring
that back uh
you know you would be the corps would be
prohibited from
allowing you to uh
to allow the voters to even consider
that so why why take that out of um
the hands of the district and again it's
the district that needs to come before
the court to uh to request this not the
union or not um you know an individual
so
uh
i i see this as tying a district's hands
when they're trying to fix a problem
i'll conclude my testimony there and
happy to take any questions thank you
very much brian any questions for mr
hawkins
thank you very much
thank you for your time
do we have any other folks that are
signed up under attendees
oh so that's it on hbe 71
in conclusion we had two people
supporting 67 opposed zero neutral
and
four testifying
thank you very much uh this hearing is
closed
the next hearing which we have is hb 234
this is relative to freedom of speech
association on college campuses
uh time spent uh sponsored this bill is
represented alexander
i am here mr chair
welcome representative alexander
um thank you thank you mr chair um
members and friends of house education
um my name is representative joe
alexander i am a representative of
goffstown new hampshire or hillsborough
district six
um i'm here to speak on behalf and in
favor and move on house bill um 234.
um this is regarding uh freedom of
speech and association on college
campuses
free speech is under attack the knight
foundation reports 61 percent of
students believe that the climate on
their campus prevents some students from
expressing their views
58 of americans are not confident that
others can hold civil conversations with
people who have different views
fifty percent of americans say that
universities should disinvite speakers
that will offend some part of the campus
population
this bill seeks to further enshrine
protections for all all speech on our
public colleges and universities
so some of the things this bill would do
it would increase the environment of
mutual respect among a diversity of
sincerely held beliefs
it would provide for that public
institutions of higher education in our
state protect all speech even those that
are considered
unwelcome disagreeable or even deeply
offensive
it protects students against actions by
others that materially and substantively
disrupt their practice of the first
amendment
it mandates the institutions of higher
education make public in their handbooks
websites and through orientation
programs the policies around speech and
expectations around the freedom of
expression
it provides for injunctive relief should
a university fail to do these things
monetary damages and reasonable
attorneys fees and court costs
and finally it would prohibit speech
zones and speech codes so it sets a
minimum standard for upholding free
speech on our public colleges university
system
um it sets the minimum standard and any
university or college would be welcome
to adopt um increased standards should
they see fit so um with that i have um
students ready to testify and other
people ready to testify and support so
i'd be happy to take any questions to
start
experimenting
alexander are there questions for the
representatives
represent lady
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking the question
um just a simple one do you have any uh
specific examples that have occurred in
the last couple of years that would uh
raise this issue
from new hampshire from the new
hampshire schools
i i do thank you very much
representative light for
asking that question um i would say that
there are
instances at the university of november
system in which
speakers were invited and there were
students that were blocking doorways um
a speaker from prageru
that was blocking the door our students
were blocking the doorways and not
allowing access to our students for our
students to
attend the event so
there have been recent examples um
another example was from unh where um a
student was seen and recorded on video
it actually went viral of the student
tearing down posters of a local
conservative group
that was endorsed by the college
follow up mr chairman
just one
thank you uh
now i'm trying to remember what it was
uh i forgot
i did such a good job
i guess you did
you're young and i'm old so
again okay we'll go to representative
thank you very much uh thank you for
taking my question representative
alexander
uh uh
uh a question and then a couple
situations i'd like to ask you about
do you believe that there is any
any should there be any restriction
i mean
i i don't no i don't all right so
here are here are a couple of examples
and how would you treat them how would
graduation
graduation obviously is kind of a
hallowed
experience for students etc
should
should free speech
interrupt a graduation based upon a
protest or whatever
that's question one question two
is that if i'm teaching a class
in a college and i've got somebody
outside my window who is practicing his
free speech rights that's interrupting
my presentation or the
process of that school should that be
restricted so those are two two examples
i'd like to have you respond to thank
you
yeah absolutely thank you representative
milor for asking those questions um i'll
address the second one first um there is
text in this bill that would say um the
the system and the administration is
allowed to impose time manner and place
restrictions on some speech um depending
on the educational to provide that
everyone has the equal opportunity
education um so that's in the bill just
to make sure that that is protected in
that case and then regarding the
graduation um i mean the the the
university system
you know
usually i mean i went to saint a's but i
also went to unh for graduate school but
sane's kind of had this like essay
contest on who got to be the student
speaker and it was kind of an
opportunity for everybody to opt and
give their give their say on why they
should be the student speaker so that
speech i think is still protected um
with regard to the graduation i mean
there's already free speech being
practiced on
during graduation so for instance um i
decorated my cap um with a like i'm
still a republican after college kind of
cap and that was an exercise of free
speech um during a hallowed ceremony
that would still be protected under this
bill yeah just as a follow-up mister
chairman lett
yeah the the issue of the putting
something on a mortar board is terrific
i mean you
you can do whatever you want to there
it's your head my concern is that if in
fact during the
actual graduation ceremonies
there is an attempt on the part of
somebody who wants to express their free
speech through
verbal
uh verb verbosity of the expression that
would interrupt the ceremony
is that
a permissible restriction of that
person's free speech it's very similar
to can somebody just stand up in a in a
crowded auditorium and said yell fire i
mean there's restrictions
there
would that same kind of restriction
be limited in this particular bill
well i would say just um to respond is
that that kind of disruption is already
happening during graduation ceremonies i
mean there was one one time where
president former president trump was the
keynote speaker and there were many
graduates that choose chose to walk out
in that situation and um in that example
that was a great exercise of their
freedom of speech to do that so um again
i think this bill adequately covers um
with is covered with a time place and
manner restriction um on it and i think
that would help answer your question
with that situation thank you very much
thank you you're welcome further
questions
not seeing any hands up uh thank you
very much represent alexander
next we have ben dickens i've promoted
him
hello there can you all uh hear me all
right
yes
very good thank you
uh i would like to begin my remarks by
thanking representative alexander as
well as the education committee not only
for hosting me but for to putting
together a hearing on an important issue
my name is ben mickens and i'm a new
hampshire college student i'm here first
and foremost to argue that freedom of
speech is a fundamental pillar of our
democracy
with it our ideas are exchanged and
tested against one another in the public
square this not only leads to a stronger
underpinning for democracy at large but
it helps us understand those who we
might otherwise not hear from
alas on college campuses today freedom
of speech is a shell of what's what of
what it once was
conservatives in new hampshire and
around the country often feel pressured
to stay silent while they're on campus
it's pretty rare for a college
conservative like myself
to consistently advocate for what they
believe in on campus
this is not healthy for our country
generally and it's especially not
healthy for academia more specifically
a little more than a year ago the union
leader ran a piece a piece on unh
college republicans expressing their
hesitancy with speaking freely on campus
including uh not being
comfortable showing their support for
president trump when he was running for
re-election
now while some conservatives will speak
anyway it is nevertheless for pressing
conservative voices at march
with this bill under discussion today
new hampshire can stake its claim as a
leader for freedom of speech in this
country
we should celebrate each other's
viewpoints and be working together to
complete our understanding of the world
not shutting each other out and tearing
each other down
i believe this bill will not only help
conservative students to feel more
comfortable to speak out on campus but
to help liberal students gain a deeper
and more personal understanding of
conservative thought
this is fundamentally good for our dem
for our country and for the state of new
hampshire and i urge this committee to
thank you very much
are there any questions for uh mr
mickens
from representative
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking the question
so you said you know you referenced a
kind of hesitancy to speak out and to um
articulate publicly uh political views
uh but i guess what i what i'm trying to
figure out here is what has the
university done
that has that has created that for you i
mean there may be one thing where
students you're feeling pressure from
peers etc
but what specifically has the university
done
that has
led you to be hesitant to articulate
yes um
so i think as representative alexander
brought up earlier um a pretty crystal
clear example of what this might be is
when conservative speakers get brought
onto college campuses not only in new
hampshire but you generally see this
throughout the country
is that uh um if people show up and
start blocking physically your way to
get in and stuff like that that's
sending a signal of you know
you're not welcome here you're not
allowed to speak you're not allowed to
think the way you think
um so that and and
when college administrations don't have
an adequate response to situations like
that which they tend not to
not to have
um that's what helps lead into this
culture of
well you know i'm a conservative but i
don't want to say anything because i
don't want to get uh targeted by other
people because there's not that
underpinning of support that i believe
that this bill um would help put into
place here in new hampshire
that answers follow up mr chairman
follow up
thank you uh so again um and and i i
actually agree with you that you know
people of any persuasion should be
permitted to speak
i don't support you know preventing
speakers but
again
what i mean the universe did the
university have any disciplinary
procedure in place for
uh these people who did interfere and
blocked people blocked fellow students
from entering the the arena or wherever
the speech was was anything done on that
or was it or
is the issue that there's a lack of any
sort of disciplinary
consequences for that action of blocking
students from accessing the speaker
yeah yes and that's a that's a good
clarification so
the problem that i i would
cite more specifically is the lack of
action
um on college campuses to allow
freedom of speech on campus so um
yeah i think you i think you hit it on
the head with the second part of your
question
[Music]
we
will be do have ron
bit later if he's from the university
system of new hampshire from the agency
itself that might be a good question for
them
thank you mr mckinnon
next we have brandon flaherty he's been
promoted for his education
i all thank you for having me i just
want to make sure you can all hear me
are we good
okay great i know zoom tends to be a
problem with with covet and everything
um so uh good afternoon um like my pres
the the predecessor
uh mr mickens um i'd like to thank
representative alexander and the house
education committee for hosting us this
afternoon and providing us the
opportunity to speak on this bill
my name is brendan flaherty i'm a
lifelong resident of nashua and a new
hampshire college student and i'm
joining you today to voice my support
for house bill 234
we're fortunate
that mass demonstrations against campus
speakers aren't all that much of an
issue here on new hampshire's college
campuses in the way that we might see
elsewhere in the country for example
university of california uc berkeley
comes to mind almost immediately when
thinking about issues pertaining to
political speech on college campuses and
the inability of college college
administrations to adequately
accommodate certain speakers whether by
deliberate choice or incompetence
while we're lucky that college students
don't face
those kinds of issues with mass
demonstrations and protests and and
riots uh as elsewhere in the country
that does not mean that we are immune to
those kinds of problems um most colleges
here in the state allow outside groups
to conduct politically motivated
operations which is um or club
activities which in its most basic form
is a good thing to have because civic
discourse and engaging with each other
is a foundational component of living in
a larger community
however some of the groups on our
campuses like to take their actions to
to new heights excuse me um i'm thinking
of organ organizations like next gen at
plymouth state university they've been
have some had they've had uh some
problems in the past with harassment of
students on campus especially around
election season
but like i mentioned before
we've really been lucky on our campuses
because we don't see i mean harassment
is not nearly the same as rioting and i
think it's important to clarify that
um but that being said house bill 234
really takes attempts to take a
proactive approach in establishing a
legal standard for colleges to use um in
issues that might arise pertaining to
free speech and association issues on
campuses
um what house bill 234 proposes isn't
and should is not and should be seen um
as an indication that colleges in the
granite state are in any way suppressing
free speech but rather the build should
be seen as a framework for how to deal
with those issues that come up um in
fostering the formulation and
articulation of political ideas
i think that having a standard before
any of those issues arise would serve
our campuses well
at a time where political issues are
becoming increasingly
more sensitive and touchy
[Music]
and it's important that students be
allowed to learn and engage in those
different ideas respectfully with the
support of their colleges um the law
presented here today would be beneficial
for our campuses in the long run and
hopefully i would foster true
intellectual growth for our college
students here in the granite state uh
thank you so much for your time
thank you very much are there any
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank
and yours ron
thank you i can yes um
thank you mr chairman thank you members
of the education committee um i'm ronald
rodgers the general counsel for the
university system of new hampshire and
for each of its four institutions i'm
here to testify in opposition to house
bill 234 i have written testimony that
was submitted
i won't go through that i just have
three points that i'd like to make for
you this afternoon and then of course
i'd be happy to answer questions
the first is that our institutions of
the university system of new hampshire
agree with the principles that are
stated
as underlying this bill
right at the beginning the bill is
for the purpose of protecting
the rights of free speech
free association free assembly
and
those are values
that university system institutions hold
dear and have
policies of processes personnel
the bill goes on though from stating
that purpose
to
describe a whole host of
interpretations of those constitutional
provisions
and various
procedures and processes requirements
reports to be filed
to
[Music]
and causes of action that might be
invoked
in order to protect those protections
in fact though
the u.s constitution and the state of
new hampshire constitution which also
has a free speech clause
has a a substantial body of
jurisprudence interpreting it and
applying it
we're a public institution we can be
sued for violations of
any of those principles
all of what the
authors of this bill claim they want to
accomplish is already in place and the
bill's not necessary
point number two is
those policies that we have in place to
protect
free speech free assembly free
association
have been
independently reviewed by
the
foundation for
individual
rights in education or fire
this committee knows
that organization from philadelphia
they've testified in front of the house
education committee before and they've
given each of our three institutions a
green light rating their highest rating
it's
if you can click on the states on their
website and there are a lot of states
surrounding the state of new hampshire
in which no public institutions have
green lights they've got red lights
they've got yellow lights in fact
fewer than one out of ten public
institutions across the
nation have green lights from this
public advocacy group each of the
university system residential campuses
have those green lights
in addition
i've been the general counsel for the
university system for 34 years we
haven't had any complaints
you know not only
no lawsuits
[Music]
we haven't had
complaints in front of any uh federal or
state agency
about any of these issues
[Music]
the
administrations care about the issues
they're responsive and they've kept
their policies
current and and effective
finally point number three
this is not a new hampshire solution
i'm sure you realized when you read the
bill that this is
drafted by a national advocacy group out
of the dc area
it is a bill that has been
encouraged in all of the legislators at
slater's across the across the nation
and it is not it doesn't fit new
hampshire it doesn't fit our
circumstances it doesn't fit our issues
and you can tell that um it's not
addressed in new hampshire
for number one we haven't had any
complaints this isn't responding to any
real issues
number two
there's no mention in that bill of the
new hampshire constitution which as i
mentioned it's got a free speech
protection in it
and
it's completely ignored
and then finally
you'll notice toward the end of the bill
there is a provision that would have the
legislature waive 11th amendment
immunity for
the university system institutions and
what that means is we'd be
subject to suit in the federal court
well guess what we don't have 11th
amendment immunity because of the way
the university system is structured we
already get sued in federal court that
provision is absolutely not necessary
this bill was written for other people's
problems it may be a good solution to
their problems it's not a new hampshire
answer to any problem that we have
and so for those reasons uh on behalf of
the board of trustees and the university
system
we urge you to vote inexpedient to
legislate
i'd be happy to uh answer any questions
you may have
are there any questions for ron rogers
thank you mr chairman attorney rodney
thank you for taking my question a
moment ago you were talking about this
bill has been um
um reflective of a national agency bill
that's sort of boilerplate across the
country and doesn't fit new hampshire
could you repeat for me please i didn't
capture it on zoom here could you repeat
for me the name of the national
organization typically orchestrates this
bill
this one is from uh alec the american
legislative exchange council
right on their website they've got the
language it's almost verbatim there have
been a couple of adjustments but almost
verbatim and
the encouragement
i mean the point is to encourage
legislators all legislatures all over
the country to consider the bill
uh
thank you mr chair thank you attorney i
just appreciate it
thank you represent milo uh thank you mr
chair and thank you mr rogers for taking
my question
um
how has the university
attempted to
provide for free speech for students
what are the policies and the the
practices that they've had
to ensure that uh
we do get the quote green green light uh
from fire
those policies uh that fire is was
particularly interested in its review
have to do with um
assembly uh the free speech
you know typically in the uh
in the public um forums uh outside of uh
buildings
uh the solicitation uh uh
along the walkways and outside the
public buildings and then also
uh the handing out of uh materials and
so the policies cover
all of those issues
they also cover
the
rights of the students and student
groups to invite speakers
and
they
cover the way in which
security will be provided and
the
university will ensure that the speakers
are able to speak without this without
interruption without being disrupted and
that the members of the audience and the
community
are safe as a result of that
the university has
a public safety office which
has advanced notice of these events
has a protocol that he goes through to
ensure that the personnel are deployed
necessary in order to be able to
ensure
the protection of free speech but also
the safety and welfare of the
members of the audience and the uh you
know and the community at large and
they've done that uh for groups that and
speakers that are both uh from from both
sides of the spectrum of the political
spectrum uh including one notable
example of
an organization called turning point usa
a particular focus on
conservative presentations at college
and university campuses
thank you
i have a question for you mr doctors um
we've had this discussion on the
education for many entire years
and one of the areas which we can just
have to discuss are the free speech
zones in the outdoor areas
can you tell me what the policies are
can a
an area that's used for instruction and
curriculum
be
taken over by those advocating free
speech
excellent question like so much of
these constitutional issues free speech
free assembly free association
the the protection of the rights
you know comes with an obligation to
balance
the rights of all people involved
that leads to
a
set of policies that include
the regulation of speech on time place
and manner and so there are places in
the university where
the
institution has said
they number one aren't open to the
public and
number two that the speech can be
regulated in order that the mission of
the institution not be disrupted
one of those places is in the classrooms
the
faculty in charge of the class teaching
the class are in charge of those classes
in charge of the classroom and
are able to
decide
when
the speech is appropriate and when it
will be disruptive
provided that they don't do it provided
that they do do it on a viewpoint
neutral basis
they aren't about picking uh
among various opportunities to speak
based on the content of the speech
it's about the
ability it's about maintaining the
ability to get the
mission of the
educational institution accomplished
is that responsive to your question yes
it is that's fine by the representative
canada
yes i had a question you had um
referred to
this just
using the
united states and not being specific to
new hampshire
and i'm reading it says in part one
article 22 of the new hampshire
constitution and i'm wondering what else
you would what other references
you would want for it to apply to new
hampshire
uh i have to apologize i guess i must
have missed that in my reading of the of
the bill um could you direct me to the
section you're referring to please
yes that's um part five
you know roman numeral five on line 22.
well it goes down to 20
uh um but and and which page is that
oh i see it yes i'm sorry physically
blocking amendment uh
uh part one article 22.
you're exactly right um and i apologize
there is a reference
to um the free speech article article
22. uh there are other articles in the
new hampshire constitution but uh they
have uh in that one place uh recognized
uh
one of the questions representative
thank you mr chair uh and mr rogers you
may you may recall around three years
ago we had a somewhat similar bill that
i chaired a subcommittee on and you were
wonderful to come and speak to that
subcommittee and at that time i recall
keene state had a red rating from fire
and uh unh said something
less than than
green plymouth state actually was great
but since then i i've noticed that your
your ratings have improved i want to ask
you one question uh i recall we had this
subcommittee before one of the concerns
at durham was
the requirement to in order to have like
a gathering or
uh a demonstration or whatever the
unique the a permit was needed from the
campus police
uh
is
what's the status of that requirement
today
working with um
the lawyers from fire the university
adjusted that has adjusted it amended it
so that now spontaneous gatherings of
less than 25 people
are permitted
gatherings that are pre-planned or are
more than 25
still is a permit requirement
the way in which the permits were
applied
way in which
students apply for the permits has also
been adjusted to make it
easier and quicker to access
okay thank you
thank you
thank you very much mr rogers thank you
[Music]
hello
yes we can hear you paul i'm sorry about
that i'm going from a cell phone i'll
make this uh
statement quick uh greetings and thank
you for letting me voice support for hb
234 my name is paul esmond i am a new
yorker and as such i appreciate that it
may be strange that i am submitting
testimony in support of your state's
bill in my previous career i was a
legislative analyst for the new york
state assembly and in this role i
received testimony and memos of support
for or opposition from residents and
businesses outside of new york state
because many people correctly or
incorrectly see new york as a national
policy leader there was a tremendous
interest from non-new yorkers and what
went on in our state house
now i'm on the opposite end looking in
with profound interest interest in your
bill
i hope that it will become law or at
least portions and provisions of it
will and that new hampshire will be
regarded as
leading the way in protecting what i
consider the endangered species of free
speech
on college campuses and also other parts
of public life this bill is uh
nonpartisan it affords the same
protections for all students regardless
of their political economic social or
religious perspectives
the bill
merely establishes standards and sets
the expectations the students first
amendments rights will not be trampled
on or watered down by administrators and
disruptive students
the legislation would prevent public
colleges and universities which belong
to the people of the granite state
by virtue of their subsidization
from fostering an environment of
illiberal behavior towards speech
that is deemed unpopular
universities and colleges must never
allow for the intimidation of students
organizations or speakers even if the
views they hold may not be in the
mainstream it is not the mission of a
university to endorse or condemn speech
or opinions particularly if such speech
or opinions do not promote or incite
violence in recent years institutions of
higher education have been the site of
def de-platforming and violence directed
at students campus organizations
and guest speakers who are expressing
unpopular views in many cases
administrators have looked the other way
and allowed the hecklers mob to have the
final say
this is unacceptable it only serves to
create groupthink in american society
the free exchange of ideas is critical
in higher education
unfortunately this spirit seems to be
dimming
as evidenced by instance in recent years
including one that happened here in new
york state in 2019 at the
university at binghamton where
administrators looked the other way as
students set upon a campus group handing
out literature for an upcoming speech by
a conservative economist
and then
in a sense allowed his speech to be
disrupted
hundreds more examples have been
documented uh in the news
and um have largely gone uh unpunished
and um one
what i just want to say is that uh you
know this type of behavior uh seems to
be growingly tacitly accepted
and it should not be accepted
um i like that the bill is nonpartisan
in spirit it protects every student left
right or in between
and i would urge you to to move some
version of this bill
and enshrine
some protections in your statutes
to preserve the free speech
at your public colleges and universities
and
hold administrators and students uh
accountable
and i just want to thank you for this
opportunity and
thank you very much mr esmen
are there any questions for the
presenter
yes
excellent uh well thank you mr chairman
and members of the committee for holding
this hearing today
just for the record my name is ross
connolly i'm the deputy state director
for americans for prosperity new
hampshire and i'm just here to voice our
support for hb 234
free speech is the cornerstone to any
free society
students at the university system of new
hampshire and community college system
institutions
should feel free to speak their minds
ask questions and be intellectually
curious
however currently these schools do not
have many provisions for incentivizing
uh and protecting these rights and in
many cases it's just the opposite
schools like unh durham and keene state
college have enacted and retracted
certain speech codes and speech zones
for years
uh as previous speakers pointed out
uh that that many of those institutions
have been greenlit by fire but just a
couple of years ago many had red lights
uh this bill would stop uh that practice
from the constant switching based on
administration control it would stop
that practice from occurring
and if we are to be more united as a
nation we must really start speaking to
one another listening and understanding
our differences at the most local level
and the best place to start that change
is in our schools so that future
generations do not look at their fellow
americans
as the enemy but instead understand our
differences and work together on the
extensive common ground that exists
teaching our young people the virtues of
respectful civil debate and disagreement
will be critical in the coming years
luckily hb 234 would take a giant leap
towards fostering this culture of
inclusion
and tolerance on campus
as has been pointed out this bill would
require new hampshire public
institutions of higher learning to adopt
policies of free speech into their
student handbooks and codes of conduct
what it does not allow is for a speech
that has calls to commit violence or
harassment
it still allows to answer some of the
previous questions
it still allows the institution to halt
demonstrations that disrupt campus
activities and and that is uh that
decision would would rest with the
university
this small reasonable change would start
the process of moving campuses back to
centers of learning questioning and
critical thought
differences of differences of opinion
are normal
and higher education was founded on
teaching students how to think
critically and challenge
their own beliefs and 19 states and
counting have enacted a similar
legislation to h.b 234 including states
under both republican and democratic
majorities
free speech expression and association
should not be a partisan issue we really
must learn to speak and listen to one
another again and that is the intent
between h
behind hb 234
and and for all these reasons we urge
the committee to move hb 234 ought to
pass and i'd be happy to take any
questions if there are any thank you
very much mr connolly are there
not seeing enhanced thank you very much
thanks so much for your time yeah
you can't hear me and can you see me i'm
not quite sure how this works yes okay
um thank you my name is shannon reed i'm
director of government affairs
for the community college system of new
hampshire thank you for the opportunity
to testify i apologize for not signing
in early enough to be captured in the
portal but thank you for allowing me to
speak nonetheless
i certainly don't argue with what the
prior student speakers have said about
their experiences with fellow students
and i've even seen that type of peer
pressure operating on my own teenagers
who are more conservative than many of
their peers
however
this bill declares that post-secondary
institutions must follow the principles
of the first amendment and the new
hampshire constitution the community
college system has policies that were
written specifically to ensure support
and protection of first amendment rights
our history has shown that we actively
seek to be venues where diverse public
discourse takes place
our policies are consistent and content
neutral have been developed to support
first amendment protections for all and
have been effective in achieving those
objectives
given the policies in place at our
institutions we're unsure why the
sponsors believe this bill is needed
here in new hampshire
is the bill designed to go beyond
established first amendment protections
if so it would be helpful to have those
new boundaries laid out clearly and if
not we ask why this bill is needed
beyond that general question i have just
a few comments to to offer
on page three being on line six
the bill acknowledges the college's
rights to maintain reasonable time place
and manner restrictions which are
content neutral and which our policies
reflect there appears to be a
contradiction with the statement
immediately preceding that language
forbidding the college from designated
areas for expressive activity we
understand the colleges may not
designate so-called free speech zones
that have the effect of removing
expressive activity from accessible
parts of campus
but the colleges do exercise their right
to require certain areas to remain
unblocked by such activity for instance
so that students and other members of
the campus can go about their business
unimpeded
the colleges have a safety obligation to
our students employees and visitors this
includes the ability to plan for events
or gatherings to ensure they don't
unduly disrupt the learning experience
for which students attend our colleges
and pay tuition
or put anyone at risk from destructive
actions
for instance working cooperatively with
groups in advance and understanding the
likely scope of an event enables our
colleges to plan appropriately
we're also concerned that the bill
establishes a separate right of action
involving injunctive relief monetary
damages attorneys fees and court costs
since we already have a grievance
procedure in place that protects
students rights and this is on page four
toward the bottom
we would ask that the committee consider
striking that section rather than create
a separate track and process for
grievance resolution
on page 3 toward the bottom of the page
we're unclear what is meant by the
language in roman 2
which provides that the institution may
not discriminate against a student
organization based on the expression of
the organization including any
requirement that the leaders of such
organizations comply with the
organization's standards of conduct we
ask the sponsors please clarify what is
meant by that language
finally on page four the accountability
section
requires the institutions to report to
the governor and the state legislature
prior to the beginning of the state
legislative session detailing the course
of action implemented to be in
compliance with the requirements of the
chapter
with report on any changes or updates to
the chosen course of action this section
outlines additional details on what
should be included in the report and how
such information must be disseminated
i'll just share two points about that
section
first the bill includes an unusually
detailed series of reporting
requirements we would ask that you
consider limiting the level of detail in
a way that honors the sponsor's intent
but does not create this new level of
administrative workload for our
organizations
and second we recommend you define to
whom the reports should go instead of
simply to the legislature that may be a
result of this being boilerplate
language but um for instance other
reporting requirements in new hampshire
statute would specify um the speaker of
the house and the senate president
and that concludes my testimony thank
you for your consideration
thank you very much uh shannon
uh are there questions for the community
college system
[Music]
representative uh thank you mr chair
thank you miss reed for taking my
question
in your experience with the
community college system have you had
any problems in recent future in the
recent past in dealing with free speech
issues on any of the seven campuses of
the community colleges
no not at all that i'm aware of thank
you very much
further questions
yes president pardelli
thank you thank you
of course yes i will
thank you
further questions
thank you very much
do you have any other
participants or hands up nothing
okay with that i'm going to close hb
we had
testifying
13 support
opposition
or 92
and neutral one
and testifying we had
seven
so we're done hb 234 now and we will
enter into the next bill which we have
which we brought forward from this this
morning
um
uh hb 258
with that i'd like to ask do we have the
thank you uh it's good to see everybody
i'm sure you had a very long day
good afternoon education committee my
name is representative judy aaron
and i represent sullivan county district
seven that's acworth goshen langdon
leemster and washington
so
in 2019
sb 142 was passed in the state
legislature
in response to accommodating a need that
was identified having to do with
providing students attending
new hampshire public middle and high
schools who could not afford feminine
hygiene products
with sanitary napkins and tampons and
school bathrooms
the concept had and still has much merit
however there are several things wrong
with the current statute which needs to
be fixed which is why i'm presenting
this bill to you today
first and foremost
it is our sworn oath and duty to uphold
the new hampshire constitution
our new hampshire constitution makes it
very clear in article 28a having to do
with mandated programs the state shall
not mandate or assign any new expanded
or modified programs or responsibilities
to any political subdivision in such a
way as to necessitate additional local
expenditures by the political
subdivision unless such programs or
responsibilities are fully funded by the
state or unless such programs or
responsibilities
are approved for funding by a vote of
the local legislative body or of the
political subdivision
so
this statute that was created in 2019
created an unfunded mandate to our
school systems
it first mandates through rsa 189-16a
that menstrual hydrine products must be
made available at no cost in all gender
neutral bathrooms and bathrooms
designated for females
located in public middle and high
schools and then it goes on to further
say in rsa 189-16a
that the school district shall bear the
cost of supplying menstrual hygiene
products
that is clearly a violation of article
28a of the new hampshire constitution
i believe that needs to be fixed
so the bill that i'm presenting seeks to
repeal
the statute and replace it with one that
is in line with our constitutional oath
and duty
yet it still allows for females in need
to be provided with menstrual products
first of all
i thought it was better to place this
statute in a section more appropriate
for the topic
as this does not really belong in an
area of statute having to do with school
boards transportation and instruction of
pupils instead it seems better suited to
be in the section of the education
statute
having to do with school health and
sanitation
usually young ladies would go to the
nurse's office if they were in need of
sanitary supplies
nurses offices always had supplies
available in an emergency or if someone
was genuinely in need
this bill also leaves it up to the
school administration
to decide for themselves if they have an
issue of students being in need of
menstrual products and to determine
themselves how and where to provide
those products
i don't think the state of new hampshire
should be micromanaging schools
regarding how and where to provide these
products
those things should be left up to the
discretion of the school administration
and when writing this bill
i heard from people telling me that
their schools were experiencing problems
with the current policy set in 2019 by
rsa 189 colon 16a
in passing
people told me the current policy has
been very costly for their school and
ultimately the local taxpayers
schools have had to buy machines or
other distribution devices for every
bathroom
at great cost and they constantly have
to refill product that is left in the
restrooms
products are ending up being hoarded by
all students and worse removed by
non-students
the truth is if you leave a basket of
tampons or napkins they will disappear
in a flash
clearly this was not the intention of
this statute
the unintended consequence here is that
the reality is that schools are
supplying all students plus any school
visitors with menstrual products and not
just those who are in need
this is a costly proposition for schools
and may in fact not allow products to be
actually available
by the ladies who this rsa was intended
to help
if product is gone from the restroom
when they are there
they won't have access to them
i think it makes much more sense for the
schools to decide their own policies
regarding the availability of menstrual
supplies and how to distribute them to
those who truly need them
if they want to supply product to
everyone then that's their choice as
well
with regard to how school districts pay
for these supplies
that's also another matter
since this bill before you doesn't
mandate that every bathroom and every
school offer these products it is no
longer an unfunded mandate
the bill also states clearly that if a
school decides to offer product that the
cost can be covered by donations to the
school
or purchased via available grant money
or through any available state or local
funding reimbursement programs
this bill still allows product to be
available and i think that's very
important
but it leaves decisions regarding
availability to be made by the local
administration and allows them the
flexibility regarding how to cover the
cost of these products
this makes for constitutionally sound
and flexible statute
which overall benefits our schools as
well as our students that are in need
so i appreciate your time and listening
and i look forward to your question
thank you very much representative are
not seeing any hands thank you very much
appreciate it representative ladd
yes i do have a question
okay go for it
thank you uh remember in the back on the
bottom of your
uh
proposal
the part that talks about the nonprofit
community grants i think is line nine
actually um that is the same
uh language that was in the bill that's
approved
so so that hasn't changed that correct
well the uh the current language says
the school district shall bear the cost
of supplying menstrual hydro hygiene
products
um a school district may seek grants or
partner with an entrepreneur it's the
part that is a mandate
is that the school district shall bear
the cost
of supplying menstrual products
and that's the example the grant because
the grant question was the provinces so
there i guess i want to go back to um
the rationale for this bill
uh i was a look at i don't know how much
your school system paid for menstrual
products last year i do have a couple uh
report outs outside schools here um
interesting to know at least none up
here in the north country can
talk to any of the schools being uh uh
being left empty or taken away or
damaged uh from those uh
uh as you recall this as i'm sure you
recall from doing your research on this
bill that was a rochester school board
and a school of student that started
this bill
um
because
for the people who were not on the
committee last year this this falls into
the term called period poverty
yeah
it has a significant issue
uh as regards student attendance
uh or the lack thereof because of the
lack of feminine products for
adolescents
the other part we found after the
legislation last year or last session in
the hearing
over and over and over again i'm sure
you're aware
a school saying the kids did not come to
school they did not come to school
because of this this difficulty in the
financial issues which obviously are
more
critical now so i guess i guess i'm
asking you how do you balance
student attendance
and minimal costs they're looking at
interesting you know the the new
hampshire the school district down there
by hampton arai and seabrook knows
the average a uh just for your insurance
12 500 for toilet products and .05 cents
for feminine hygiene products out of the
whole district and we have other data
from that but how do you how do you get
to that point
um that we want to make this this you're
you're agreeing that the need is there
because you said you agree with the bill
is that correct i agree the need is
there and this bill addresses it but it
doesn't mandate that the school
does certain things it leaves it up to
the school to decide
um you know where and when and how to
provide the product
that may if i may finally that that may
change the whole intent of the bill
may has been the way for all the years
the schools may do this to school majors
there teach the teachers uh have been
trying to provide uh assistance and
physical teachers and female teachers
and nurses
but the stigma that goes along with that
uh has been devastating for kids to the
point that they choose not to come to
class if they can't afford it uh or if
they're they don't have a change of
clothing because they can't afford the
product or the multiple user products so
it's a lot more
than just the the the absence of the
uh the process
um
this has a huge issue so once you go
back to may it does exactly what it was
for the last 30 years and we see it more
and more and more youngsters not coming
to school because they can't receive the
assistance because the financial
assistance is not there
representative woodcock do you believe
that schools would ignore a problem then
i believe schools yes i do but they're
not that ignore problems they have not
been able to keep up with the problem
well i'm sorry for the last 20 years
you've seen it
i i don't want to have this a debate
between the presenter and an individual
honor committee please
let's keep the questions from the
committee to the presenter
and that's the way we'll leave it thank
you chairman chairman lad may i also add
to that this bill does not
um
still recognizes that there is a need
but it removes the unfunded mandate
and i would suggest that if you want to
keep in the language of shall
that you then put in a stipulation for
the state to fund it
thank you very much are there further
thank you very much representative thank
you and i appreciate your time
welcome
we have um another representative jeff
edwards
so i'm representative jess edwards
representing auburn chester and sandown
and and one of the
things i do in my community is
for uh boy scouts i teach a citizenship
in the nature nation merit badge
and within that
course
we teach the importance
of
maintaining the checks and balances
within our government
and recognizing uh what our
constitutions
restrict the government from doing
you you may recall uh that the
constitution
was uh written primarily to tell
government what it shall not do
and so
in 1984
the new hampshire citizenry got together
and
and passed into our constitution a new
amendment
amendment or article 28 alpha
banning
banning prohibiting making it
impermissible
to
pass
unfunded mandates
and the way that the law is written now
it couldn't be more clear it couldn't be
a more textbook example
of an unfunded
unconstitutional mandate
and while it may
frustrate us as legislators
to use our authority to
do the right thing for society
part of doing the right thing
is maintaining our own legislative
discipline
so that we only do the things that are
permissible
the statute as it stands now is
currently broken
i support um
the the bill before you 458 as one way
to
fix the problem the other way to fix the
problem
inclu
includes but is not limited to
having the state pay for it if the
state's going to mandate it the state
has an obligation to pay for it that's
really what 28 a says to us and it's
said in very plain simple language
and if we refuse to obey our oath i
think maybe we should resign
so i'll take question if there are any
thank you very much representative
edwards are there questions for the
representatives
representative awesome thank you mr uh
thank you for taking my question i was
not in the mix when this came through
before
did not anyone
point out that this was an
unconstitutional unfunded mandate before
or is this the first time that this has
been flagged
thank you for the question um
the reason i found out about this rsa
was when i was talking to my senator
senator sharon carson
and she was livid that this got passed
over her objections about the
unconstitutionality of this mandate
but um it was just one of those bills
where you weren't going to get a bunch
of republican men
to oppose it because it would be too
easy to paint us politically as people
who don't care about women so so we fell
silent unfortunately while an unco
unknowingly unconstitutional bill that
would be simple to pass or fix
was allowed to pass and then
you know nobody got to the governor to
point out to him that he should veto it
over the constitutional issue but
uh so people did know and and not enough
people cared representative moffitt
thank you thank you very much are there
further questions of representatives
question
thank you just a question for
representative edwards
um being new to this process
representative
i was um
uh
interested to find out uh figure out if
you can help me with this
since the governor's staff and the
governor's people went through the bill
i'm sure before the governor signed it
to make it law
um would there be assumption then that
thank you for the question and i would
say
that given that the law itself prohibits
the state from funding it
it's very clear
so unless a policy committee
passes a policy
then the finance committee doesn't pick
up and then fund that policy
and in this case somebody decided to
write it so narrowly
that the state is essentially prohibited
from meeting its obligation under
thank you very much uh further questions
uh
representative
uh thank you mr chairman thank you
representative edwards for taking my uh
question
uh is
are you con is are you
aware that
is this the only bill
that we have passed on from this state
house and the state legislature that's
unfunded
aren't there other bills that we have
also
forwarded on to
so
so thank you for the question i would
say
that um
given the number of laws that we pass
and given
um sometimes
what seems to be a haphazard regard for
uh 28a
that there are probably other laws
out there that have passed unfunded
mandates
and i would encourage you that if you
come across one
that you
do what i'm doing do what representative
aaron is doing and that is fix the
problem don't ignore the problem fix the
problem
and um so
um i i've i've got another bill i don't
know if you're ever going to see it in
education but i had another solution to
this uh but i don't want to talk about
any bill other than the one that's
before you today
thank you
thank you very much
another question
representative
yeah i don't have a question i have an
answer to a question that was asked when
this came up yes not only did i mention
and other people mentioned that it was a
21a
um violation at the committee hearing i
spoke on the floor and said the exact
28 am sorry
definitely
yeah are there any other questions for
representative edwards
not seeing any hands or folks thank you
very much
thank you mr chair thank you members of
the education committee
okay um thank you uh thanks for allowing
me to testify i know it's the end of the
day i'll speak quickly um my name is
julia mead i'm at ob gyn i live in
lebanon and i practice in the state of
new hampshire
um and i'd like to speak in opposition
to house bill 458 um i'm strongly
opposed to this bill for several reasons
and i stand with the new hampshire
medical society as well as new hampshire
um american college of obstetricians and
gynecologists
um tipples this valve
um you know
i actually love to talk about the
menstrual cycle i love working with
patients um many of them who are
adolescents are teenagers
and and
to work with regulating their cycle
uh managing heavy bleeding or cramping
to allow them to live their lives that
they want to so many young women are
held back sports or
or like um
representative woodcock was talking
about not able to go to school not able
to participate fully in class um due to
their periods i personally in my school
um or had to leave class in the middle
of the day because of um painful periods
so i can definitely identify women are
feeling um
and it's unpleasant and embarrassing
enough without access to menstrual
products to kind of compound this issue
i know that
periods are kind of considered taboo or
embarrassing to talk about but i think
it's time that we you know recognize
this normal physiologic
occurrence and think of it as a way to
provide fair accommodation to
young women and adolescents in our state
so i don't think it's something that
should be shameful or embarrassing or a
cause for distress um you know i think
we can all imagine either ourselves or a
niece or a daughter um who
might someday need
menstrual products whether they can't
afford them they forget or they have
unexpected bleeding you know rather than
having um to have their clothes changed
or call home or
you know an embarrassing encounter and i
think having these products available to
everyone should be considered a human
right so
in conclusion
i'm opposed to this bill
and
thank you for the opportunity to speak
thank you are there any questions for
our mistake
and you've signed up to speak for four
minutes
thank
yeah what i'd like to do is try to
remind everybody that
the minutes that they've signed up for
try to stick to what you've signed up to
can you guys hear me
yeah
okay
um hi
my name is shulpa dr daria vamala i am a
resident physician
here in new hampshire
and i'm speaking on my own behalf and
these are my own thoughts
um i am talking in opposition of this
bill
we all know uh one in five girls misses
school during a menstrual cycle and one
in four can't access it in fact wick and
medicaid um many people and many
patients i have are on wigan medicaid
they consider pads and tampons a luxury
good
now women have cycles every month
in the same way they believe toilet
paper the conservative luxury good and
toilet paper and not menstrual pads is
an affront to women's dignity
um many families don't have disposable
income to afford sanitary products many
of these people you're talking for the
state of new hampshire right from
manchester super urban environment all
the way to berlin which is super rural
now imagine a young girl trying to go
buy pads you have to go up to the store
talk to the male store keeper sometimes
they don't even stock the pads that's a
known fact amongst other studies all
across the united states and to then
have to buy pads and walk out of there
is extremely embarrassing especially for
a 13 year old we don't talk about
menstrual cycles enough and i know that
because my patients come to me having no
idea about their own bodies and so to
say this is stigmatized is an
understatement
on top of that there's a racial divide
as well and i've seen i've worked in
manchester in the past and i've seen
patients come in and have even less of a
knowledge and less of access to
menstrual pattern cycles because of
cultural taboos now you're telling me
that this unfunded mandate should
require funding you are right i think
that should be some sort of funding here
but the fact that an unfunded mandate
was passed
that then requires schools to think
about this to offer this makes it
a sign of support for young girls
they're mistripping saying that we see
you as equals and we see that your
bodily biological needs are met at our
school in the same way we provide food
the same we provide toilet paper
same way we provide a space to learn and
study these girls might have upfront
costs for their pads in their tampons
but in the long run you are giving new
hampshire state a great workforce of
young ladies and women that can be
extremely effective change makers by
taking away
the access to pads and tampons you are
actually having a huge opportunity cost
loss in the future for your own state
um
i think it's not a luxury and it's not
something that we talk about often not
every body that menstruates is also
female so then to have this young person
who's gender non-conforming have to go
up and ask for menstrual pads when they
may or may not identify as a woman is
then adding trauma to the lives and i
think i see plenty of patients come to
my clinic with that issue as well
so we're about equity and we're about
racial equality and gender equality here
and we pass this law i highly support
that we continue that
extremely profound and honorable um
by keeping that law in place and not
repealing it and not changing it some of
the wording in the bill makes it
permissible to offer pads or tampons and
i think that's also inappropriate since
many people use one or the other for
cultural or personal reasons
um and so i thank you guys for your time
this honorable staff
representatives here that have sat and
listened to me kind of share my thoughts
i highly hope that you choose human
justice and gender equality and racial
equality today by voting against this
bill thank you so much
any much
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee my name is jeannie herreska
and i'm the political director for the
american civil liberties union of new
hampshire i really appreciate the
opportunity to testify today in
opposition to hb 458 the aclu strongly
supported the 2019
bill
and was very proud to be part of that
incredible effort to combat period
poverty in new hampshire
and it's just it's really
disappointing and disheartening to now
see legislation attempting to repeal
that legislation and to send students
back
into period poverty
i want to be clear here that access to
menstrual products is not about
convenience it's about public health
it's about dignity and it's even about
academic performance a student's access
to tampons and pads relates directly to
their education
if you can imagine for just a moment
trying to focus on a math problem while
wondering if your pad is leaking or if
your tampon will hold up for another
four hours
this anxiety and shame can significantly
impact a student's academic performance
for obvious reasons
i'll it's also worth noting that it's
actually unsanitary and unsafe to not
regularly change tampons or pads
and it bothers me to hear
discussion about student about whether
school should have to assess a student's
need for for tampons and pads i can't
imagine a school
that would try and determine a student's
need for toilet paper can you imagine a
student trying to prove to a school
nurse that they needed toilet paper or
that they needed more toilet paper we
would never ever do that
and yet to ask that a student have to
prove to a school that they need a
tampon
is is just to really misunderstand the
level of stigma and shame that can be
associated with periods
students to ask a student to publicize
their need for menstrual products
is just to not understand the shame
associated with periods and to ask
students that basically to go either the
entire school day with one tampon or one
pad which is highly unsanitary and
unsafe and distracting or to ask them to
to skip school i mean that's the reality
is that too many students actually miss
school
because they do not these products and i
understand that these products may only
apply to 50 of the student population
and therefore they're not seen as
necessary as like water or toilet paper
that apply to the the entire student
body but i would encourage you to think
of them in the same category of
necessity as you think of toilet paper
and you think of water
and i would just want to note that that
governor sununu did sign this
legislation in 2019
and when he signed it what he said at
the time was this quote this legislation
is about equality and dignity
sb 142 will help ensure young women in
new hampshire public schools will have
the freedom to learn without disruption
and free of shame or free of stigma
and this bill will undo that progress it
will send students back into period
poverty and it will result in more
students missing school
and for these reasons i respectfully
urge the members of this committee to
vote inexpedient to legislate on hb 458
i'm happy to take questions
thank you very much mr
[Music]
not seeing any thank you very much
okay next is ashley yang
hello
can you hear us
um yes i can hear you okay great thank
you very much for wanting to testify
today you can go ahead sure my name is
ashley yang i am a medical student at
dartmouth and i would like to testify
today in opposition to this bill
not only am i
a future medical provider i'm also a
product of
public schools
for my whole life and
from
speaking from both experiences i can say
that
the access having access to menstrual
products
is essential to young women's ability to
participate equally in school and
and engage fully in the learning
environment
from what i remember
as a student in public schools people
come from
a wide distribution of
family socioeconomic circumstances and
people have very different
abilities to afford these types of
essential products that previous
individuals have testified have been
viewed as luxury
items rather than necessities
just like we provide textbooks to
students in schools and school buses to
get them there we
must provide menstrual products as well
so that they can learn safely and
you know actually come to school and
be as prepared and able to participate
and it's also important to
have a way to
fund
the provision of these products rather
than just say that
we have to provide them or make a
reasonable effort to provide them
um
and
it is really essential for
the physical and mental health of young
people to feel like they can exist in
public with dignity and
the
having access to protected access to
sanitary products is a really crucial
way that they can get that so
i urge the committee to
not recommend that this bill
be passed so thank you very much thank
you very much ashley are there any
questions
not seeing any hands thank you very much
ashley thank you
thank you
good evening all right good afternoon
again uh thank you uh representative
vlad thank you members of the committee
it feels like night time doesn't that um
uh
a little levity at the end of the day i
hope that's all right with everybody um
uh bear christina executive director of
new hampshire school boards association
uh we are in support of house bill 558
uh please know that our support of this
bill has absolutely nothing to do with
the underlying policy issues
two years ago when i believe it was
senate bill 142
um was working its way through the
legislature nhsba did not take a
position on that uh however we certainly
did have some hallway conversations with
many representatives worried about the
fiscal impact
that it may be downshifted to local
school districts
so when the bill uh senate bill 142
came into law and school districts were
trying to come in compliance to buying
the menstrual products and buying the
the dispensers and and whatever
equipment was needed for the restroom
and hsba received a handful of phone
calls from superintendents and school
board members asking what our position
was on one on on senate bill 142 um and
they so explain to them why we didn't
take a position um how were the
competing interests relative to the the
policy impact of of helping uh these
young women versus the the fiscal impact
that school boards have to wrestle with
every single day um part of the um
reason nhsba is is supporting this bill
is in
in part echoing the comments of of
representative aaron and representative
edwards but um in speaking with some uh
representatives and not representatives
but people in manchester they went
through the manchester school district
they had a six-figure price tag to
implement this they were looking at 125
in a school district that is woefully
underfunded to begin with that is
shutting buildings um that um you know
has
has a low cost per pupil um
and you know that's obviously the
extreme the largest school district in
the state is going to have the most
significant expense i did certainly hear
from other school districts that were
looking at you know five ten fifteen
thousand dollar expenses as well too um
and we did it um and i don't know if you
know in part we did it because we were
told to do it in part school districts
did it because it was the right thing to
do um but the reality is it's an
unfunded mandate the school this the the
legislature through senate bill 142
created a new program created a new
directive and downshifted that cost to
to to local school districts um so
that's an hsba support of of the of the
bill if we want to maintain the policy
aspects relative to the bill um then the
legislature should should fund it um you
know we're in a budget cycle right now
uh you know i don't know what the
statewide costs for implementing this
are
um
but you know uh perhaps a survey could
go out but all i know is um you know
many school districts have had some
expense manchester had a very very
significant expense so that's the bulk
of nhsba support from this bill because
it undoes the unfunded mandate that the
senate bill um 142
um uh uh
that said senate bill 142 created um
representative miller do you yeah i
believe you asked representative edwards
how how much time do you have
representative um nhsba keeps an
informal list of unfunded mandates going
back probably about 10 years or so um i
haven't updated that in the last couple
years um and it's not a polished final
document by any means um but if we're
going to be talking about unfunded
mandates perhaps we could start with
adequacy aid um
just a thought but anyway uh house bill
um 450 one last point i did email some
comments to the committee as well too
about a half hour ago i wasn't sure if i
was going to be able to stay online for
the for the zoom so um
you should be getting my comments as as
well too but nhsba supports this solely
on the on the fiscal issue and the
fiscal impact that senate bill 142 was
had on on our member schools on our
member school board so um had with that
i'm happy to take any questions
thank you very much mr christina
school boards association are there any
questions for
ruxin at home
and thank you for taking the question
school districts provide other needs
such as toilet paper while being
a mandate by the state so don't you
think that school districts if they see
a need would survive that need
thank you for the question
representative i i think certainly
that's uh i mean that's certainly a
legitimate argument i know that that was
one of the arguments that um proponents
and supporters of senate bill 142 um
expressed a couple years ago that we
provide um you know kleenex and we
provide uh uh uh a toilet paper um you
know there may be a larger conversation
about sort of unconscious biases with
doing those things that i'm certainly
not qualified to speak about um but i
guess the difference is you know
the state is not telling school
districts that they have to buy toilet
paper and they have to buy they have to
buy kleenex and tissue um should
districts be providing this should they
have been doing so already i believe the
testimony from son of from senate bill
142 and one of the reasons it was gay it
was able to gain support was that many
districts
or at least some districts
were already providing feminine hygiene
products for free on their own but i
guess my response to that representative
would be that if it's embedded in the
local budget um local taxpayers have
decided that they're willing to pay for
those products
and whether or not everybody should pay
for it i guess it's a different argument
you know or whether or not every school
district should offer feminine hygiene
products in the schools a different
argument but when there's a mandate and
the direct the the impact of that
legislative mandate is that school
districts are expending 10 15 125 000
um then i think perhaps we need to
either revisit funding or revisit the
the bill itself
thank you very much uh any further
questions for the school board's
association
representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question
i'm wondering how much of that money is
actually
uh because people felt as our school
districts felt as though they had to get
dispensers
and that seems to be one of the big
ticket items in this and if so that
investment has already been made
for that particular
part of the bathroom so
once that's made
do you have any sense as to the
continuing cost
of having these items and i'll just
preface it by saying that i had talked
to an assistant principal about this
and uh she was like you know the kids
are taking them all over and everything
that calmed down within a month
of the kids uh goofing around with the
different uh free sanitary napkins
which also brought out a good discussion
about personal hygiene i guess
um but then things settle down and they
realized how how much it was important
to the school so just um
those kind of comments thank you for the
question representative i mean i
certainly haven't looked at a school
district budget or expenses as to
you know this amount of money for the
dispenser this amount of money for the
products themselves um
so that aspect i can't you know i i i
can't speak to i can't also i cannot
also speak to some of the the the
comments about parents taking you know
the products and the students hoarding
them i i haven't heard that specifically
and that's sort of not the bulk of of an
hsba's you know comments i guess what i
would say relative to the cost of the
dispensers that have already been
installed um there's a representative
luna's bill is looking at retroactive
building aid um so i suppose if the
state wanted to
pony up some money for this there might
be a way to
look at some retroactive um feminine
thank you very much further questions
thank you very much thank you very much
mr chair have a good afternoon everybody
i'm signed up to speak for
good afternoon yes
hi there sorry i just had a little bit
of a lag good afternoon chairman ladd
and members of the house education
committee for the record my name is
elizabeth canada i'm the advocacy
manager for planned parenthood new
hampshire action fund and planned
parenthood of northern new england and
we've submitted our testimony through
email as well
we urge you to vote itl on house bill
as background which you heard already in
2019 this body passed senate bill 142
which required new hampshire public high
school and middle schools to make
menstruation products available at no
cost in girls restrooms and gender
neutral restrooms that bill passed with
broad bipartisan support
house bill 458 however would repeal that
statute house bill 458 would no longer
require public schools to offer
menstrual products at no cost to
students in spaces that are accessible
without students needing to ask someone
this bill instead would make offering
free products optional for schools they
would also have the option to offer
products at a low cost to students
let's be clear
allowing for no-cost menstruation
products in public schools decreases
learning interruptions
students should not have to go to a
nurse's office to access needed supplies
they should have what they need in their
restroom to minimize any stigmatization
and time away from class
and we've heard earlier today this issue
surrounding need and to that i want to
bring up two points
first is that if you are operating a
middle or high school in a school
district you have students who
menstruate and they need tampons and
pets
and second the issue of stigmatization
and embarrassment is real when it comes
to financial need
we see that in how the number of
students who submit free reduced lunch
paperwork decreases as they become
teenagers students may feel embarrassed
that they are what we might refer to as
in financial need and this is magnified
when it comes to menstruation which is
already a stigmatized topic
in order to enable students to practice
proper hygiene we expect schools to
supply toilet paper soap towels and
dryers at no cost to students
and we expect schools to supply those
items where they are accessible to the
students
we should similarly expect schools to
supply products needed by students who
are menstruating
in short house bill 458 would increase
barriers for students and those barriers
will occur with regular monthly
frequency
the goal should be to support students
in feeling safe and comfortable in their
school buildings without feeling
stigmatized or singled out
and the good news is new hampshire
already has that law in the books and
other states and countries are following
our lead let's not roll back progress
we ask that you vote inexpedient to
legislate on house bill 458 thank you
for your time
thank you very much miss canada
are there any questions
or
thank you again for testifying today
thank you
you're welcome
lastly we have caroline
hello i'm caroline dillon some of you
may remember me from 2019 as i am the
one who approached former senator martha
hennessey with the idea for sb 142.
uh
as you can imagine i'm thoroughly
disappointed to be sitting here right
now
hashing this out again
um but it was amazing to see so many
people speaking in favor and um or in
opposition to hb 458
and they touched on most of my points so
i just have a few brief things
um
article 28a was
a huge argument in 2019 one that we
discussed thoroughly with
um a lot of the staff in the senate we
sent it around to like a bunch of
different people i discussed it with
governor sununu when i met with him and
he was telling me how excited he was
because he loved sb-142 um and
the general consensus was because
of the may in the second clause or
didn't contradict the shell like they
can um
get additional funding from other other
places but ultimately it's the school
district who's still
paying regardless of where that money
comes from
um as far as
budgets um
school district budgets are like
multi-million dollar things right so i
started this for rochester in 2019
before this bill was introduced um our
budget that year was around 70 million
dollars
and when i spoke to the school board
they hashed out the costs
and designated four thousand dollars a
year for these products for the middle
and high school
um and that includes dispensers the
actual estimate was like thirty two
hundred dollars and they were like oh
well we'll just you know increase that
whatever so the dispensers are a
one-time purchase
um
no school district should be spending
125 000 dollars if you are spending that
much you can look for a different type
of dispenser or you can have a basket it
does not say that you need to have a
specific dispenser you don't need to be
spending that much rochester spent four
thousand and that was
six thousandths of a percent
of the school budget
um
other states by the way have been
looking at us as um a really good
example personally since 2019 i have
been contacted with numerous people from
connecticut washington florida
california south carolina pennsylvania
and currently i am working with
massachusetts they are all trying to
base
bills off of sb 142 um and we are really
leading the charge in the country with
fighting period poverty so i i think
that passing
sb 450 or hb 458 sorry um that would be
a huge step back in our progress and
like just for public press
that would not look good for new
hampshire
um and then again with the engaging
needs um
school districts like if if you don't
have to pay for something like you're
not gonna do it right like why why spend
the money when you could just have it in
the bank um and so like how are you
going to gauge
the need
um
you really really can't do that unless
you're going to go through and ask every
single person who menstruates if they
have trouble affording tampons or if
they use something like newspapers
instead of pads
you don't want to do that because it's
uncomfortably and honestly even if i
myself was suffering from period poverty
there is absolutely no way i would be
brave enough to say
you know what mr superintendent yeah i
do skip school when i'm on my period so
i don't leak through my pants and bleed
over my chair
nobody's gonna do that
so
i mean unless you really want to i would
urge you to vote um an expedient to
legislate if anyone has any other
oppositions i would love to hear them
and if you have any questions that uh i
could answer to potentially change your
mind i want to answer them
i am sure you will hear from me again
because i will always be here to speak
up for others and i will always fight
for menstrual equity and that is a
promise so thank you very much for
hearing me today thank you very much
miss dylan are there any questions for
the presenter
not
so that concludes all the speakers for
458 i will go through what we have here
as far as the numbers
supporting the bill 20 opposed 245
neutral zero testifying a total of nine
thank you very much for hanging in there
today i appreciate it um
we are done for today's work we're
joining this meeting as at this point
tomorrow don't forget we have session
uh down in bedford or wherever over in
denver
i look forward to the experience of
visiting bedford
i wish you were mr chair i just want to
say that i wish that you were all coming
to my home tomorrow perhaps after
everybody is
vaccinated and or it's gone
we'll be able to do that in bedford
that's a wonderful invitation i'd much
rather be at your house tomorrow than in
uh
a huge room like we're going to be in
our store yes you would
first of all i'm just going to find the
place so
never been there before
i don't know but
it's not it's not tough to find if you
know where uh where target and lows are
in bedford i'm just saying
you go down with them on your right hand
side and you're just looking for uh the
yes
down by mark's show place uh right
yeah okay it's down to southern front of
the stage somewhere i don't freak your
neck of the woods up
well
we'll come get you we'll come find you
the easiest way
is to go right down the everett turnpike
through the toll
and went or not through the toll uh just
keep going down until you see the
airport road
yeah on this airport road not not 293
it's past that
you take that airport road the ray
resort highway and when you get off you
go toward
merrimack route 3
and you come down to the light and then
you take a right to go back toward
manchester and it's only about less than